Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Fühlst du dich machtlos?
Als Konsument nein, als Bürger ja.
Und das heißt, als Bürger siehst du dich in einer politischen Rolle und als Konsument in einer ökonomischen?
Richtig. Und in einer ökonomischen Rolle würde ich sagen, habe ich eine gewisse Wirksamkeit. Also ich kann nicht die Welt kaufen, mir stehen nicht alle Türen offen, aber ich kann doch vieles über Geld erledigen. Also ich kann jetzt sagen, heute organisiere ich. Genau. Ja, ja. Das ist also was mich persönlich jetzt gefragt. Und wenn ich jetzt sage, ich habe genügend Geld, um mir zum Beispiel einen schönen Abend zu gestalten, indem ich sage, ich gehe etwas essen und danach ins Kino. Und damit ist das eine Wirksamkeit, die ich erlebe, während ich als Bürger, der also politisch etwas bewegen will, in einer Schwierigkeit stecke, dass zwar die Erkenntnis da ist, dass sich etwas ändern muss, dass sogar diese Erkenntnis konsensuell ist. Also das ist ja das Interessante. Jeder weiß um zum Beispiel den Klimawandel. Es gibt fast niemanden, der ihn leugnet. Es sind ganz, ganz kleine Gruppen, die ihn leugnen. Nur ist trotzdem, und damit sind wir ja bei Blühdorn direkt, das Gefühl der Machtlosigkeit da, obwohl der Konsens der Gesellschaftliche absolut erreicht ist. Es muss nicht mehr für die Erkenntnis gekämpft werden, dass es den Klimawandel gibt. Und trotzdem geschieht angesichts der Erkenntnis so wenig.
Jetzt hast du mir aber eine intellektuelle Teilvorlage gegeben für eine Rückfrage. Du fühlst dich ökonomisch, ich will mal nicht sagen mächtig, sondern wirksam, weil du kannst in deinem Sinne ökonomisch handeln, indem du von deinem Geld, von was du hier hast, Anteile ausgibst. Die Frage der Währung ist also in der Ökonomie völlig klar. Meine Tochter kriegt von mir fünf Euro und sie weiß, das sind entweder zwei Kaugummis und ein Lucha oder ein Eis und ein Kaugummi oder eine Fanta und ein Lucha. Sie kann es wahnsinnig gut kombinieren, sie kann so richtig durchkonzeptionieren, wie sie ihren Tag gestaltet, wann sie wie viel Geld ausgibt. Sie weiß genau, was sie dafür bekommt, sie weiß das schon vorher, sie muss nicht erst abwarten. Wenn sie enttäuscht ist davon, geht sie zurück und sagt, das ist aber schlecht, ich will ein anderes, wie auch immer. Was ist denn die Währung in der Politik? Wir haben kein Geld in der Politik, wo wir einfach sagen können, ja ich investiere jetzt mal so ein bisschen meiner Stimmrechte und dafür kriege ich aber genau das. Und wenn das nicht kommt, dann gehe ich aber auf die Barrikade. Sondern, nee, wenn wir jetzt an Politik denken, ja wir haben so eine Stimme, keine Ahnung. Also im Vergleich zu, ich könnte jetzt für 10 Euro Joghurt kaufen, es gibt 30 verschiedene Joghurs im Regal. Ich kann also mit den 10 Euro 785.000 verschiedene Kombinationen von Joghurt kaufen. Ich bin auf mich zurückgeworfen, jetzt die beste Entscheidung zu treffen. Wenn ich mich einmal festgelegt habe, ist es mein Risiko, diese Enttäuschung dann für mich zu verwandeln. In der Politik, ja, Trump oder Harris? SPD oder CDU? Wann? Nein, nicht weil du jetzt gerade Lust hast, sondern die Wahl ist halt in drei Monaten und sieben Tagen. Wenn du sie verpasst, dass sie verpasst. Womit haben wir es da zu tun? Was ist das für ein Problem, dass wir auf der einen Seite, also dass du jetzt einfach so eine saloppe Unterscheidung machst zwischen Ökonomie und Politik und wir dann feststellen, ah, das funktioniert grundsätzlich anders. Wir haben gar keine politische Währung eigentlich. Klar können wir uns nicht selbstwirksam fühlen, verstehen, wie unser politisches Ansehen einmal zur Markte getragen, auch schon wieder ein ökonomischer Begriff auf politischen Markte, dass da was bei rumkommt. Wir müssen also grundsätzlich darüber nachdenken, wie wir über Politik nachdenken, bevor wir sie machen.
Und jetzt haben wir eine sehr einfache Opposition aufgemacht. Politik, Bürger auf der einen Seite, auf der anderen Seite Wirtschaft, Konsument. Und jetzt könnte ich ja einen Schritt weitergehen und damit kommen wir dann in eine gewisse Dialektik hinein. Was, wenn ich mir politisch etwas wünsche, zum Beispiel die Bekämpfung des Klimawandels als Bürger, als Konsument ich aber, als Teil meiner Selbstverwirklichung auch, verhandle ich dieses Thema grundsätzlich anders, nämlich egoistisch und denke nicht an das Wohl des Klimas, sondern an mein eigenes und sage mir, Fahrradfahren? Nein, ich lasse mich mit dem Auto fahren, ich bestelle mir ein Taxi oder mache den Flug in den Urlaub. Und damit widerspricht also der Konsument Wolfgang, dem Bürger Wolfgang. Und zugleich würde man sagen, es ist schon etwas dran, dass diese Art des Konsums auch eine Art der Selbstverwirklichung ist und Selbstverwirklichung ist doch ein ganz hohes Gut in unserer Gesellschaft. Und zugleich ist der Verzicht, der aber implizit oder explizit immer dabei ist, wenn wir über Klimawandel reden, ist auch das Denken kollektiv und nicht individualistisch eines, das wichtig ist. Etwas, was sich grundsätzlich widerspricht. Und damit sind wir doch eigentlich schon bei einem Kern dieses Buches, Unhaltbarkeit von Blühdorn angekommen.
Ich würde auch den Kern sofort mal nennen.
Wir haben da einen Widerspruch. Und vielleicht sagen wir erst etwas zu dem Titel. Dieser Titel Unhaltbarkeit. Was will der? Blühdorn sagt, will die Gleichzeitigkeit der tiefen Krise westlicher Gesellschaften und der Krise des öko-emanzipatorischen Projekts, das diese Gesellschaften transformieren wollte, aufzeigen. Gerade in den wohlhabenden Konsumgesellschaften des globalen Nordens fällt die Unhaltbarkeit des einen, der gesellschaftlichen Ordnung, der Nicht-Nachhaltigkeit, mit einer Krise des anderen, des Projekts der sozial-ökologischen Transformation zusammen. Und letztere hat ihre Ursache nicht einfach in den Widerständen des kapitalistischen Systems vielmehr zerbricht, wie ich später ausführen werde, das öko-emanzipatorische Projekt ganz wesentlich auch an seine eigenen Logik und seinen inneren Widersprüchen. Das heißt, die Antwort, warum wird nicht entsprechend gegen den Klimawandel gekämpft, soll hier nicht lauten, weil der Kapitalismus daran einfach schuld ist. Der Kapitalismus hat eine Schuld daran und das leugnet Blühdorn noch nicht. Er sagte aber, das gesamte sozial-ökologische, das öko-emanzipatorische Projekt, also da sehen wir, das sind zwei Wörter drin, Ökologie und Emanzipation, dieses Projekt hat innere Widersprüche. Und die sorgen eigentlich dafür, dass es nicht gelingen kann. Das Projekt unterminiert sich sozusagen selbst.
Ja. So, jetzt haben wir aber sozusagen, bevor wir mit dem Buch angefangen haben, also mit seiner Begrifflichkeit, Unhaltbarkeit gesagt oder festgestellt, aus einer rein lebenspraktischen Sichtweise. Wir gehen durch den Alltag unserer Lebenswelt einkaufen. Wir verdienen Geld, wir gehen arbeiten, wie auch immer. Können wir ökonomisch alles unterbrechen, minutiös? Wir kennen die Währung. Wir wissen, wie man aus zwei Euro ein Euro macht, um das zu halbieren, wie auch immer. Also wir sind absolute Herren über unser ökonomisches Geschick. Und wenn irgendwas schief läuft, wissen wir genau, wie die Forderung lautet. Die Miete ist zu hoch. Das Gehalt ist zu niedrig. Der Monat ist zu lang. Wie auch immer. In der Politik ist es schwer. Wir können diese Argumentation nicht einfach transferieren auf der Kanzler ist zu mächtig. Ich bin zu ohnmächtig. Was soll denn das bedeuten? Also man weiß gar nicht, die Debatte war zu lang oder sowas. Es steht zu spät auf der Tagesordnung. Also sowas, ich höre niemanden so reden. Wir können also aus der reinen Lebenspraxis jetzt nicht ableiten, wie wir politisch verbessern, was wir verbesserungswürdig finden. Wir brauchen also politische Denkangebote, die uns dargelegt werden. Die müssen immer auch begründet werden. Er macht ja welche. Wir kommen gleich darauf zu sprechen. Er begründet sie. Aber diese Unhaltbarkeit setzt er ziemlich paradigmatisch so als archimetischen Punkt seiner Argumentation. Er erklärt uns dann einiges, wie zum Beispiel, ich nehme mal den Begriff Unhaltbar, weil es geht mir eigentlich um Nachhaltigkeit. Aber dieser Begriff ist irgendwie, keine Ahnung, den will ich nicht benutzen. Also nehme ich Unhaltbarkeit. Dann redet er von einer doppelten Unhaltbarkeit, die hast du ja gerade schon umrissen. Wir haben zum einen eine nicht nachhaltige Gesellschaftsordnung, die also kritikwürdig ist, weil sie nicht auf Dauer gestellt werden kann. Dann kommen Menschen und wollen sie auf Dauer stellen, machen also sozial-ökologische Transformationsvorschläge, von denen er sagt, die sind auch unhaltbar. Also ist sowohl die gelebte Praxis in der Politik, als auch der Gegenentwurf oder das Ideal auch unhaltbar. Jetzt würde ich sagen, okay, dann steht das Buch, aber unter der Fragestellung, ist diese Unterscheidung eigentlich haltbar? Oder ist sie genauso unhaltbar? Wenn wir irgendwie feststellen, ja, also die gelebte Praxis und die Kritik daran ist unhaltbar. Brauchen wir jetzt eine bessere Kritik oder eine andere Unterscheidung? Oder wie auch immer. Also man müsste jetzt eigentlich viel mehr öffnen als er, das finde ich, öffnet, bevor er einsteigt. Also da, finde ich, steckt so ein Witz drin. Dass er das Wort unhaltbar nimmt für eine Konstruktion einer Unterscheidung, von der ich von Anfang an sage, die halte ich auch für unhaltbar, es sei denn, er argumentiert mir, warum das jetzt der Ausgangspunkt eine haltbare Unterscheidung ist, um Unhaltbarkeit zu diskutieren.
Das finde ich nicht. Ich finde, dass er mit diesem Unhaltbarkeitsbegriff doch etwas deutlich macht. Du wirst ja immer wieder darauf abziehen, dass er nicht empirisch arbeitet. Aber er arbeitet ja insofern empirisch, als er aus der Wirklichkeit, die wir vorfinden, heraus zu dem Schluss kommt. Und ich glaube, den kann niemand leugnen, dass das große transformatorische Projekt hinsichtlich Ökologie nicht stattfindet. Zumindest nicht in den westlichen Demokratien. Das kann man ja schon mal dahinstellen, dass es noch andere Modelle gibt, zum Beispiel China. Das gibt es nicht. Und dann gibt es verschiedene Ideale, die formuliert werden, zum Beispiel von Klimaaktivisten oder von Klimaforschern. Und er stellt sich jetzt die Frage, warum haben die denn nicht funktioniert? Denn das sind doch eigentlich gute Ansätze, mit denen er sympathisiert. Also er ist ja auch Nachhaltigkeitsforscher. Er ist ja jetzt niemand, der sagt, er interessiert mich eigentlich gar nicht, sondern das ist ja für ihn eigentlich ein Kernthema. Und diese Unhaltbarkeit darzustellen, jetzt zu sagen, naja, dann müsste er sagen, ist nicht sein Projekt auch unhaltbar. Siehst du etwas, was haltbar ist? Also das wäre ja jetzt meine Gegenfrage. Wenn du jetzt sagen würdest, nee, läuft doch super, funktioniert ja. Dann könnte man sagen, dass die Prämisse des Buches ist falsch. Aber die Prämisse ist ja zunächst einmal richtig. Also von dieser Krise sowohl der Demokratie wie auch solcher transformatorischer Projekte ist ja evident. Da wird ja niemand jetzt, der bei Trost ist, sagen, nee, klappt alles prima mit der Demokratie.
Ich würde auch erstmal sagen, ja, wir leben in einer Form von Gesellschaft, bei der wir eindeutig wissen, wenn alle acht Milliarden Menschen so leben würden wie wir, dann gäbe es die Erde noch ein Jahr und dann würden wir alle bei 45 Grad selbst in Grönland verglühen. Das ist also unhaltbar. Das ist unbestritten. Dann sagt er aber, seit den 1970er Jahren gibt es so eine sozioökologische, transformatorische Idee, die der Club of Rome sagt, es gibt so Grenzen des Wachstums. Dann gibt es zehn Jahre später in Kyoto oder 20 Jahre später so eine Idee, wir könnten das ja mal ökonomisch transformieren. Also wir doppeln jetzt alle ökonomischen Transaktionen immer mit so einem ökologischen Gegenkonto und sagen, das ist ein Zertifikatehandel, eine Idee, die damals nicht so gut funktionierte und von der FDP heute auf die Spitze getrieben wird. Was dann eben hieß, wenn das FDP-Programm, so wie es im Wahlprogramm steht, gelten würde, würde die Tonne CO2 mit 680 Euro auf diesem ökologischen Konto noch zusätzlich vergütet werden müssen. Das ökonomische, was wir haben, ist auf keinen Fall haltbar. Das wäre das Ende. Die Idee würde dann die Gesellschaft komplett zerstören. Aber schon bei dieser Frage, was ist denn jetzt die ökonomische Transformation, die da angedacht ist? Soll ich jetzt an Greta denken oder an das Kyoto-Protokoll und an den Club of Rome? Du sagst jetzt, der ist empirisch. Ich würde sagen, naja gut, er nennt mir halt noch mal die große Kritik von wir stehen am Abgrund des UN-Generalsekretärs Antonio Kutterisch. So, also das ist so ein empirischer Zugriff. Oder was sagt eigentlich?
Er passt es doch sehr konkret.
Karl Nehammer dazu, als österreichischer Bundeskanzler, der sagt, ne, stimmt doch gar nicht. So. Aber näher an die Gegenwart und Gesellschaft?
Also das öko-emanzipatorische Projekt, abgekürzt ÖEP, ist kein Projekt im Sinne von, das ist die und die Vereinigung. Das ist nicht wie Fridays for Future. Aber Fridays for Future ist auch Teil dieses Projekts. Genauso sind Leute wie Maja Göpel, sind die Grünen, sind Solarhersteller Teil dieses Projekts.
Nennt er Maja Göpel?
Er nennt Maja Göpel an mehreren Stellen sogar.
Nennt er die Grünen?
Er nennt die Grünen als Bewegung.
Was nennt er nicht? Also die Grenzziehung ist für mich unklar. Was jetzt genau gesprochen ist.
Er nennt Maja Göpel und einige andere dieser Autoren, die auch sehr populär sind und findet da sehr kritische Worte für. Nicht weil er deren Wunsch ablehnt nach einer anderen Gesellschaft, sondern er sieht nicht, dass es realistisch ist. Er spricht in Bezug auf Maja Göpel und andere aktivistischen Publikationen, die es gibt, von einer, das ist aus dem Fazit schon genommen, anrührenden Einfalt. Das heißt, er sympathisiert damit, sagt aber, das ist zu einfältig. Was ist jetzt dieses ÖEP? Weil das klingt so komisch, was hat jetzt Ökologie und Emanzipation miteinander zu tun? Nun, wenn man sich die Geschichte der Grünen ansieht und die Geschichte der Grünen ist auch eine Geschichte der Bundesrepublik und ist auch eine Geschichte des Westens, dann war das ja nicht einfach ein Umweltschutz, wie er zum Beispiel in den 20er Jahren schon da war, dass man sagt, die Natur ist toll, die müssen wir schützen. Oder das deutsche Volk muss hier in einer tollen Natur sein, also so eine rechte Ökologie. Sondern man sagte, die Klimakatastrophe wird uns alle einschränken, wird uns Schlimmes auferlegen und vor allem den Ärmeren wird ganz viel vernichten. Deswegen müssen wir etwas dagegen tun, damit unsere Lebenswelt erhalten bleibt. Und zugleich war das aber verknüpft an emanzipatorische Versprechen, weshalb ja zum Beispiel die Grünen sich als erste Partei ganz stark gemacht haben für so etwas wie die Ehe für alle, für Gleichberechtigung der Frau viel stärker forciert haben als andere Parteien. Und das wurde dann von anderen Parteien auch übernommen. Das heißt, das öko-emanzipatorische Projekt meinte Klimaschutz plus Freiheit, Gleichheit, Menschenrechte und meinte auch Selbstbestimmung. Also wir müssen diese Selbstbestimmung auch konkret und erweitert fassen. Also Selbstbestimmung, das Selbstbestimmungsrecht der Frau, also wenn wir über Abtreibung zum Beispiel reden. Und darüber hinaus aber, ich kann selbst bestimmen, wer ich sein will. Und da sagt er, diese Art der Selbstbestimmung und Selbstverwirklichung impliziert natürlich etwas, was dem ökologischen Projekt zuwiderlaufen kann, wenn ich sage, ich verwirkele mich, ich verwirkeliche mich selbst, ich habe mir einen SUV gekauft. Und da ist also ein Widerspruch, den er als solchen sehr ausführlich, man könnte mitunter auch sagen, redundant beschreibt.
Wenn man das so beobachtet, und das ist intuitiv absolut plausibel, weil es entspricht der Nachrichtenlage, die wir heute schon im Alltagesthema, am Ende kommt nicht nur das Wetter, sondern inzwischen auch ein Klimabericht. Und vorher wird über die ökonomischen Tatsachen berichtet. Der DAX geht hoch, aber gleichzeitig auch die Inflation. Also jeder weiß, ich verwirkliche mich hier nicht, aber irgendwer verwirklicht sich. Das geht aber gegen meine ökologischen Interessen, meine Kinder noch in der WC hinterlassen und so weiter. Da würde ich jetzt vorschlagen, diese Art der Unhaltbarkeiten, also die Gesellschaft, ist auf einem nicht nachhaltigen Gesellschaftsordnungsprinzip jetzt aufgesetzt, von dem wir wissen, das müssen wir ändern. Und dann ist ein Änderungsvorschlag, wir machen eine ökologische Wende. Und dann kommt ein anderer und sagt, wir können ja auch gleich eine emanzipatorische Transformation machen. Dann hat man da schon ein Widerspruch. Wieder, also nicht nur ein Widerspruch zwischen der einen Unhaltbarkeit und der anderen, sondern die Unhaltbarkeiten, die kritisiert werden. Die Kritik selber ist nochmal widersprüchlich, weil das eine Ziel, ich brauche ein SUV und mich selbst verwirklichen, und das andere Ziel passt dann auch nicht zusammen. Da würde ich jetzt vorschlagen. Warum nimmt man dann nicht einfach eine, wie soll man sagen, eine Spielfeldbearbeitung, wie sie Steffen Mau vorgelegt hat, und sagt, okay, die haben die empirische Arbeit gemacht, sie haben Arenen identifiziert. Und jetzt geht man die Namensliste durch. Blühdorn selbst, Ulrich Beck, Wolfgang Streeck, Niklas Luhmann, Emanuel Kant als die großen Ideengeber, dann irgendwie Eugen Roth, Antonio Gutierrez, Karl Nehammer auf so einem sozusagen widerstreitenden Posten, die reden übers Klima. Dann holen wir nochmal Andreas Reckwitz rein, Armin Nasee, Hartmut Rosa, Oliver Nachtwey, Johann Röckström und so weiter. So und das macht er ja. Das ist sozusagen sein empirischer Zugriff. Es wird ja über Sachen nachgedacht. Menschen in der Welt denken über die Welt nach. Also bediene ich mich an deren politischem Denken und deren Denk vorangeboten. Mir fehlt aber dieser Schritt, das jetzt mal zu platzieren. Zum Beispiel in so einer Arena-Diskussion, wo wir dann eben grundsätzliche Fragen, von denen wir ja schon gesagt haben, das ist wirklich gut zu sagen, führen die denn eine Diskussion in der Arena, wo sie hingehört, oder sind die irgendwie falsch platziert? Und da würde ich dann sagen, ja absolut, da kann man dann...
Nur ist es doch bei Mausow, dass diese Arenen so funktionieren, dass man sagt, man hat eine Bevölkerung und will die verorten und konfrontiert sie mit verschiedenen Themen. Und dann ergibt sich daraus ein komplexes Bild. Hier haben wir es ja nicht mit einem Ideenfeld zu tun, wir gucken mal, wo das Worted ist, sondern er sagt, es gibt einen allgemeinen Konsens, und es stimmte auch, dass der Klimawandel als ein Problem angesehen wird. Davon leitet sich aber noch nicht ab, dass alle sagen, ich tue etwas gegen den Klimawandel. Und daraus ergeben sich ja Fragen. Und dann stellt er doch eher die Frage, wie kann es sein, dass die Diagnosen alle da sind? Und wie kann es auch sein, dass wir so viel über die Bevölkerung wissen, was sie denkt und sie tut? Und trotzdem gibt es nicht den entscheidenden Schritt, oder kann es ihn nicht geben, oder kann es ihn im Rahmen der Demokratie nicht geben? Also ich würde es wirklich auch als eine Demokratie-Kritik verstehen, nicht im Sinne von, hier plädiert einer eigentlich für ein Königreich oder sowas, sondern dass er sagt, das demokratische Projekt ist ein aufklärerisches Projekt. Und du wirst jetzt natürlich immer sagen können, ja, in der Demokratie geht es am Ende nur um Macht, und es geht um Vertrauen und all das. Und diese Idee von dem aufgeklärten Subjekt, das ist ja auch etwas, was wir so nicht antreffen in der Wirklichkeit. Aber die Gründungsidee von der Demokratie ist ja eine solche. Also Demokratie beruht zumindest in Europa auf der Idee und in den USA auch, dass es autonome Subjekte gibt. Und jetzt ist es so, dass aber diese kategorischen Imperative, die daran anschließen, zwar nach wie vor einen hohen Wert haben. Und wir hören das ja auch allenthalben von allen Politikern, wie wichtig das ist, dass man so etwas wie Aufklärung gut heißt. Und zugleich kann aber es sein, dass gerade in diesem autonomen Subjektverständnis, aus dem dann auch so ein emanzipatorisches Projekt wird, man soll sich selbst verwirklichen und nicht nur die Männer, sondern auch die Frauen und auch die Minderheiten und so weiter. Dass das etwas ist, dass aber eigentlich ein normatives Fundament notwendig untergraben wird. Es ist auch kein Buch, das das beklagt. Also das sagt, Mensch, schade, das wäre schön, wenn wir wieder wie in den 70ern wären. Ganz im Gegenteil, dem erteilt er eine Absage. Er sagt nur, dass die Modernisierung selbst sich unterminiert, beziehungsweise die Demokratie wird durch die Modernisierung unterminiert. Und dann kommt man in einer anderen Moderne an.
Ja, also diese Wege nach vorne, die ihn ja besonders interessieren. Deswegen ja auch Beck mit seinem drei Phasen Modell und dann eigentlich ein Fünf-Phasen Modell, weil er immer noch diese Zwischenschritte hat. Dennoch nochmal mein Vorschlag, mit diesen hier auch so in Arene zu denken. Er sagt uns ja, also ich finde ja nicht, dass es sehr empirisch ist, aber beispielhaft nennt er ja mal Folgendes. Also in den 70ern beginnt dieses ökologische Bewusstsein, das dann versucht politische Dringlichkeit herzustellen und neu zu handeln. Agrarwände, Energiewende, Verkehrswende, Artenschutz, Klimaziele. Die nennt er. Dann allerdings, als man gerade dachte, wir haben doch einen Konsens hergestellt, 99 Prozent der Klimawissenschaftler sagen und so weiter, was auch immer, stellt man fest, wir haben aber noch akute Krisen. Pandemie, Inflation, Krieg, Terrorismus, Migration, Weltmachtanspruch, Chinas. Ich würde jetzt sagen, man kann jetzt nicht einfach kommen mit, auf der einen Seite haben wir die Gesellschaft, wie sie ist. Pandemie, Inflation, Krieg, Terrorismus, Migration. Das ist ja alles gar nicht nachhaltig. Das muss mal geändert werden. Und eine Antwort wäre, trotz dieser akuten Krisen, jetzt mal den Ideenapparat zu einer Agrarwende, zu einer Energiewende, zu einer Verkehrswende, zum Atemschutz zu mobilisieren. Sondern für mich sind hier auf Augenhöhe zwei Arenen, in denen gerade diskutiert wird. Und die einen reklamieren für sich, die Pandemie ist wichtiger als das Klima. Ich würde jetzt nicht einfach sagen, dass das stimmt. Bei ihm ist es einfach die Dringlichkeit, sagt. Die Pandemie ist jetzt gerade wichtiger als das Klima. Wir wissen alle noch, wie sich das angefühlt hat 2020, als es hieß, ja, ein tödliches Virus. Da war uns das Klima allen so ein bisschen egal. Bzw. wir haben uns dann so gefreut, wenn wir weniger Auto fahren, tun wir auch noch was fürs Klima. Also man hat das ziemlich vulgär da eingebaut. Aber für mich passt diese Ordnung hier einfach nicht zusammen. Denn auch das ist ja ein Prinzip, das mal zu hinterfragen ist. Wenn ich jetzt sage, es ist ja gar kein empirisches Buch. Ja, gibt es denn in der Politik so eine Empirie, die wir ontologisch voraussetzen können und der Rest sind so Diskussionen darüber oder ist nicht einfach alles immer Diskussion? Und da würde ich halt sagen, also Agrarwende, Energiewende, Verkehrswende, Artenschutz, Klimaziel auf der einen Seite und Pandemie, Inflation, Krieg, Terrorismus, Migration auf der anderen Seite. Nö, also da kann man auch einfach den archämedischen Punkt anders setzen. So mal vielleicht ein bisschen aus der Politik raus und mehr so in die Lebenswelt, so wie das auch in diesen neurechten Ideologien zum Beispiel ist. Die sagen, mein persönliches Leben, meine Selbstverwirklichung ist mir so wichtig, mir ist völlig egal, welchen politischen System darüber. Ich stelle hier alles in Frage. Das Überleben in der Gesellschaft ist für uns alle irgendwie relativ zentral. Wir möchten nicht, dass unser Freund stirbt. Wir reden also ganz konkret über jemanden, den wir namentlich benennen können. Und jetzt sortieren wir nochmal neu. Pandemie, Agrarwende, Verkehrswende, Inflation. Wenn mein Freund 90 Jahre alt ist, ist Pandemie wichtig. Wenn ich aber eine Schulklasse habe, die einfach nur Fußball spielen will, für die ist dann vielleicht ein Artenschutz sehr viel wichtiger, damit dann noch ein Rasen wächst in 40 Jahren oder sowas. Also dieses Sortieren empirischer Korrelate einer, wir wissen nicht, was jetzt am allerwichtigsten ist. Niemand kann entscheiden, was wirklich wirklich ist, sondern wir führen halt so Diskussionen und arbeiten uns langsam vorwärts. Wir müssen den Konstruktivismus so ein bisschen ernster nehmen und damit auch, das ist eigentlich paradox, indem man die Diskussionen thematisch so ein bisschen locker auf Augenhöhe und auch austauschbar macht. Sie näher ranführen, um das, um was es uns eigentlich geht und ob wir dann eine unhaltbare oder haltbare oder in welchem Maßstab wir die Haltbarkeit unserer gegenwärtigen Gesellschaftsordnung messen, wird dann immer zweitrangiger, umso mehr man die Diskussionen dahin verlagert.
Ja, aber wenn ich von mir als Individuum ausgehe und über meine Freunde nachdenke, um das ganz konkret zu machen, dann brauche ich nie mehr einen Gedanken an den Klimawandel zu verschwenden.
Sagst du. Ja. Das sagen aber andere Leute ganz anders. Das ist ja eben das.
Nee, das ist ja gerade das Problem, dass ganz viele Leute in einer Weise vom Klimawandel zwar betroffen sein werden, dass man es merkt. Also es ist für mich auch eine Katastrophe, wenn wir diese Hitzesommer oder so haben. Ich gehe dann einfach mehr ins Haus oder gehe irgendwo in ein klimatisiertes Hotel und dann ist das für mich erledigt. Das ist aber keine existenzielle Not.
Ja, aber es gibt Leute, die denken eben ganz anders darüber. Für die ist es eine Akkordeunde. Es gibt Leute, die nehmen Artenschutz in Deutschland super ernst. Die bauen Hüpfelchen an.
Ja, wir können natürlich jetzt eins Beispiel nehmen, aber das ist doch gerade das gute Beispiel für diese Art der Konzentration auf das Selbst. Also wenn ich über Selbstbestimmung, Selbstverwirklichung nachdenke, dann denke ich natürlich auch noch um mein Umfeld nach, weil man sich ja nicht ganz alleine selbst verwirklich. Also will man auch, dass den Freunden gut geht, der Familie. Und da kann ich sagen, ist der Klimawandel als solcher und der Kampf dagegen nicht entscheidend dafür, dass ich mit denen eine gute Zeit verbringe? Da ist die Frage, wo fahren wir hin? Fährt der Zug? Sollen wir das Auto nehmen? Das sind die Fragen. Und wenn hier alle ehrlich sind mit sich, die zuhören, würden sie sagen, ah ja, stimmt.
Und das ist jetzt zu challengeen. Das ist ganz wichtig.
Und das ist aber, und das unterminiert ja gerade mein Bürgersein, dass ich auch darin gründet, dass ich als aufgeklärtes Subjekt sage, ja, ich kann nicht nur an mich denken und auch nicht nur an meine paar Freunde im Umfeld, sondern ich muss erkennen, dass ich auch eine Verantwortung habe für diese Welt und alle Mitmenschen. Und deswegen kann ich nicht einfach durch die Gegend fliegen, wie ich will und kann ich nicht nur darauf achten, geht es den Freunden gut, sondern muss ich mich auch zum Beispiel in einer Pandemie, zum Beispiel bei einem Krieg oder so zurücknehmen, weil irgendwas anderes ist. Und gerade mit Bezug auf den Klimawandel wird das ja so deutlich, dass wir uns da die ganze Zeit in extreme Widersprüche verwickeln, weil wir diese Selbstverwirklichung auch an jedem Ort sein zu können, als einen großen Wert ansehen und zugleich das konfligiert mit dem Wert, wir müssen das Klima schützen. Und das ist ja etwas, was nicht runterzubrechen ist.
Ja, aber genau diesem paradigmatischen Denken versuche ich ja zu widersprechen. Denn ja, wir können natürlich immer sagen, unterm Strich zähle ich. Wenn es nur um mich geht, denke ich nicht ans Klima. Er sagt jetzt, es gibt eine aktive politische Konfliktlinie zwischen denjenigen, die um ihren mittelständischen Wohlstand und Lebensstil fürchten. Und dann, und das meine ich aber mit, da gibt es konkrete Menschen, die konkret anders leben, handeln, denken und mit Freunden und wie auch immer reden. Dann gibt es die anderen, die sozioökologisch transformative, die die sozioökologische Transformation forcieren und damit Bedrohung für die anderen werden. Das ist aber nicht diese Unterscheidung von, eigentlich sind wir alle Egoisten, aber während wir aufgeklärt, würden wir auch noch mal an uns alle denken. Sondern nein, auch Hardcore-Egoisten, ich will es ja nicht so grob sagen, aber es ist durchaus möglich und ich fühle das in mir auch. Und deswegen ist ja dieses Buch da, weil es diesen Anlass, diesen Konflikt eben gibt. Es gibt Menschen, die sagen, es geht mir vor allem um mich, um meine Nachbarschaft, ich möchte hier weiter leben. Die einen sagen dann, ich möchte nicht als Ausländer herkommen. Die anderen sagen, ich möchte nicht, dass Tesla hier mein Grundwasser abpumpt oder wie auch immer. Diese Sachen, Artenschutz, Energiewende, Klimaziele, Agrarwende, das ist nicht sozusagen der Überbau, den man sich noch leisten kann, wenn es mit dem Wohlstand schon passt, sondern es gibt Menschen, die verzichten ganz konkret auf ihren Wohlstand oder fliegen nicht oder was auch immer.
Wie viele sind das?
Naja, also dass es diesen Preis nach entsprechend sehr viele, denn es fühlen sich ja sehr viele in ihrem mittelständischen Wohlstand und Lebensstil bedroht. Deswegen ja diese Konfliktlinie, die er hier aufmacht.
Ja, aber die Konfliktlinie ist ja eine grundsätzliche, also dass der Klimawandel, wenn er so weiter nach vorne dringt, die wirtschaftlichen Bedingungen eher verschlechtern wird. Das ist ja logisch. Aber dann gibt es natürlich diese verschiedenen Gruppen. Also ja, es gibt jetzt, man kann es ja sehr gut sehen, auf der einen Seite das alte Kapital, das den Verbrenner noch lange halten möchte. Auf der anderen Seite gibt es natürlich viele, die mit einer transformativen Lösung auch wiederum sehr viel Geld verdienen können. Das heißt, die Kapitalfraktion steht nicht als eine Einster, sondern ist sehr gespalten dort in verschiedenen Interessen. Aber diese Leute, die du beschreibst, die bereit sind zu verzichten und all das, das ist ja etwas, was Blühdorn skizziert, gibt es nur in ganz seltenen Fällen. Obwohl der breite Konsens da ist, Klimawandel ist ein großes Problem. Also er sagt ja nicht, wir haben in Deutschland 84 Millionen Menschen. Davon sind 50 Millionen nicht bereit zu verzichten, aber die anderen 30 Millionen verzichten. Er charakterisiert ja beispielsweise sehr gut die letzte Generation, er sagt. Entsprechend sind die Aktivistinnen und Aktivisten der Gruppe, die sich diesen Namen gegeben hat, wohl nicht die letzte Generation, die die Klimaerwärmung noch auf das im Pariser Klimaabkommen festgelegte Maß von unter 1,5 Grad begrenzen kann. Dieser Glaube wäre bzw. ist eine fatale Selbstüberschätzung. Und ganz gewiss nicht die letzte Generation vor dem klimabedingten Untergang der Menschheit. Eher sind sie wohl die letzte Generation, die im modernistischen Geiste und in der Tradition der ökoemanzipatorischen Aufbruchsbewegungen seit den 80er Jahren noch daran zu glauben versucht, dass die Klimaerwärmung auf 1,5 Grad begrenzt werden und das Projekt einer sozialökologischen Transformation umgesetzt werden kann. Die spätmoderne ist nicht am Ende der Geschichte, wohl aber am Ende dieser Geschichte. Und das ist etwas, was ich absolut unterschreiben würde. Wenn man die letzte Generation sieht und sich noch mal diese Aktionen ansieht, auch das Festkleben an Straßen, dann ist das 80er Jahre Ideen noch mal ein bisschen digitaler vielleicht gemacht mit Social Media. Aber eigentlich ist es nicht nur die Bildsprache, sondern es sind die Formen und auch die Inhalte und die ideologische Grundlage im Sinne von wir glauben daran, dass man Leute zur Vernunft bringen kann. Denn wir sind auch vernünftige Subjekte, die jetzt folgenden Schritt machen. Wir blockieren hier den Verkehr, damit die Politik auch etwas tut und alle anderen Bürger etwas einsehen. Diese Idee eines aufgeklärten Subjekts ist aber etwas, was so zwar noch hochgehalten wird. Und jeder würde sagen, ich will vernünftig sein oder ich will selbstbestimmt sein. Aber es ist zugleich etwas, was es so nicht mehr geben kann.
Ja, aber das bedeutet, und ich lese im Wortlaut, wie er das jetzt meint, es gibt die letzte Generation, der unterstellt, sie steht ja mit ihren Ansinnen der nächsten Schritte in die Moderne im Weg. Also sie torpediert sozusagen ihr eigenes Ziel unabsichtlich. Und wenn ich diesen Text dann aber lese, frage ich mich, wie ist das jetzt gemeint? Er deklariert jetzt einfach die letzte Generation um, so wie du es beschrieben hast. Es ist nicht die letzte Generation vom Weltuntergang, sondern es ist die letzte Generation, die noch glaubt, dass man über transformative politische Ideen die Unhaltbarkeit der gegenwärtig gelebten Politik noch mal ändern kann in eine neue Nachhaltigkeit. Und er schreibt dann aber, doch der Untergang ihrer Welt bedeutet eben weder die Unbewohnbarkeit des Planeten noch den Untergang der Menschheit. Und ich möchte hier unterstellen, genau so ist es aber gemeint. Die letzte Generation warnt davor, dass sie die letzte Generation ist, die noch etwas ändern kann an einer Unbewohnbarkeit des Planeten. Und die schauen sich dann an. 2024, Indien, Pakistan, 1 Milliarde, 3 Wochen, 51 Grad Celsius. Das ist eine Unbewohnbarkeit dieser Region. Wir hören darüber wenig. Er kann jetzt nicht einfach sagen, ich definiere mal dieses letzte Generationen-Ding um und behaupte dann einfach, und hier keine Belege, nichts, sondern er sagt einfach, weder wird der Planet unbewohnbar, noch wird die Menschheit untergehen. Und da würde ich sagen, warum legt er sich da so fest?
Ich würde mich ja auch genauso festlegen.
Ich werde, also die nächste Gesellschaft, die ihm hier vorschwebt, ist eine, die es zu leben lernen wird, weil sie es irgendwie muss oder wie auch immer, von 51 Grad. Aber das ist ja nicht gleich der Untergang der Menschheit. Und da würde ich sagen, ja gut, dann ist es halt nicht der Untergang der Menschheit, aber Leben bei 51 Grad ist einfach, das wollen wir nicht. Gut.
Wir wissen ja, welche...
Ich will nur sagen, er schlägt sich hier wirklich auf die Seite der alten weisen Männer, die wir im Fernsehen, wo wir relativ viel haben, die einfach sagen, es ist doch gar nicht so schlimm.
Nein, finde ich gar nicht. Und ich will auch nicht in diese Schublade gesteckt werden. Ich will nur mal das deutlich machen. Ich hatte ja mal im 29er Podcast das Beispiel von Indonesien, wie die unter dem Klimawandel jetzt schon zu leiden haben, was die zu erwarten haben, dass die ihre Hauptstadt jetzt mal gerade woanders aufbauen, weil die dort nicht mehr haltbar ist. Also die merken die Unhaltbarkeit wirklich geografisch. Indonesien floriert zugleich. Es produziert unendlich viel Leid, dieser Klimawandel. Und dass diese neue Hauptstadt gebaut werden kann, beruht darauf, dass man nochmal ganz kräftig in sehr schmutzige Energien investiert. Durch Frecking sind die USA Produzenten von unglaublich schmutziger Energie. Das heißt, der Kapitalismus endet nicht. Es wird sehr viel Leid geben und es wird katastrophal sein. Und es ist jetzt schon katastrophal. Und du merkst doch jetzt schon, obwohl wir diese extremen Hitzewellen haben in Pakistan, in Indien, wir hin und wieder mal, wenn wir Wellenspiegel oder so gucken, auch sehen, was das konkret für Auswirkungen hat.
Ja, aber die machen sich doch auf den Weg in den nächsten zehn Jahren. Wir haben das doch gelesen. Ein Grad mehr, also in einem Jahr sind wir flüchtig.
Aber du siehst ja schon, wie gut wir uns gegen diese Wirklichkeit abdichten. Dass wir das mal hier ansprechen, ja. Aber das ist nicht das Riesenthema. Das Riesenthema ist, Carsten Lindemann erzählt irgendwas von Bürgergeldempfängern und Totalverleigern. Das heißt, und ja, die werden sich auf den Weg machen. Und weißt du, was passieren wird? Die EU wird so hohe Zäune machen und mit Scharfschützen daran arbeiten, dass sie nicht kommen. Ja, aber... Also ich will damit sagen, das ist nicht der Untergang der Welt. Das ist für mich ein persönlicher Untergang, weil ich sagen würde, dass man alles, was an Werten da ist, verrät.
Damit bestätigst du doch bis hierhin, dass dieses Buch im Tenor Wir müssen mit 4,5 Grad zu leben lernen ist.
Nein.
Und das kann doch nicht ernsthaft der Tenor eines politischen Buches sein.
Nein, aber ich habe, ich glaube nicht, dass die bisherigen Abwehrstrategien nicht funktionieren.
Schön und gut.
Nein, ich glaube nicht, dass wir auf 4,5 Grad kommen. Es wird sicherlich etwas darunter bleiben, weil ja doch auch viel passiert. Stichwort China und man sieht auch, dass in Europa natürlich eine gewisse Transformation da stattfindet. Aber es ist ja nicht so, also wir sitzen ja beide nicht hier und glauben, dass es 1,5 Grad erreicht wird. Man könnte vielleicht hoffen, das hängt aber sehr von Leuten ab, die wir nicht beeinflussen können, zum Beispiel Chinesen und Inder, dass man möglicherweise noch so ein 2,0, 2,5-Ziel erreicht. Also darüber hinaus, mehr wagt doch niemand mehr zu träumen hier. Das heißt, wir erleben nicht den Untergang der Menschheit, aber wir erleben Folgendes, was er da schreibt. Während der Kapitalismus sich allerdings weiterhin als erstaunlich überlebens tüchtig erweist, gerät das ÖEP nun seinerseits in seinen Grundfesten ins Wanken. Bei der Krise des ÖEP geht es also tatsächlich um sehr viel mehr als nur um die postapokalyptische Erkenntnis, dass sich das Zeitfenster für bestimmte Klimaziele und eine sozial-ökologische Transformation inzwischen geschlossen hat und sich bestimmte Konsequenzen, vor denen die Klima- und Nachhaltigkeitswissenschaft immer gewarnt hat, nicht mehr verhindern lassen. Es geht um die fortschreitende Normalisierung und Entproblematisierung des bisher apokalyptischen und undenkbaren. Auch dieser Prozess macht einen Weg frei. Das beschreibt der Neutral. Also er sagt jetzt nicht, Mensch, da kommen wir in eine schöne neue Moderne an.
Er sagt gar nichts über die Zukunft.
Wir sehen ja hier, dass diese Normalisierung und Entproblematisierung stattfindet, indem man sagt, naja, da ist es wohl heiß in Pakistan. Machen wir mal noch einen kleinen Bericht, wenn wir Platz haben, wenn nicht die Opposition wieder irgendwas hat. Und es findet doch diese ganz große Gewöhnung bereits an diese dramatischen Klimaveränderungen statt. Und nochmal um das hier deutlich zu machen, ich finde das grauenhaft, dass das so ist. Nur glaube ich nicht und sehe auch nicht die ökologischen Bemühungen von großen Akteuren, dass das sich fundamental ändern wird. Sondern ich glaube, dass man sich darauf einrichten kann, dass man auch einem indonesischen Vorbild in gewisser Weise folgt und sagt, ja, da sterben immer ein paar zehntausend Leute im Sommer, weil es dann so heiß ist. Das und das passiert alles. Wir bekommen irgendwelche merkwürdigen Stechmücken hier in Deutschland, die für eine kleine Epidemie mal sorgen. Aber damit lebt man dann. Und das ist ja die Grausamkeit, die da drinsteckt. Und deswegen ist die letzte Generation altmodisch, aber in einem sympathischen Sinne, wenn man so möchte, weil sie ja noch mal einfach versucht hat, als emanzipatorisches Projekt auch aufzutreten. Und ist ja damit krachend gescheitert, wie wir jetzt gesehen haben, dass nicht mal ein einziger Sitz im Europaparlament errungen werden konnte.
Ja, also auf die letzte Generation draufhauen im Sinne von, es war ihre Aufgabe, den Planeten zu retten und sie sind gescheitert. Also den Gedanken kann ich nicht mitgehen. So zynisch will ich nicht sein.
Das macht er doch nicht. Er sagt doch eigentlich, das ist nur noch mal einmal der Beweis für diese allgemeine Entwicklung. Das konnte nicht funktionieren. Also mit anderen Worten, man kann nicht jetzt noch mal anfangen, mit der Kutsche zu fahren. Das wird sich nicht als Verkehrsmittel noch mal durchsetzen.
Die letzte Generation fordert nicht, dass irgendwer mit der Kutsche fährt.
Nein, aber übertragen jetzt im Sinne von diese Art des Aktivismus und der Glaube daran an das aufgeklärte bürgerliche Subjekt. Und das ist ja auch was, was immer adressiert wird, zum Beispiel von Mayer Göpel. Da sagt er, das scheint ja offenbar nicht zu funktionieren. Und das meint er aber nicht hälmisch, sondern er sagt einfach, ich nehme das wahr und ich würde auch sagen, ein Wahlergebnis wie das der letzten Generation bei der Europawahl bestätigt das. Da kann ich jetzt immer in Klammern ein Leider anführen oder so. Aber das bringt doch nichts. Ich kann einfach sagen, es ist so.
Die letzte Generation, ich weiß, sie sind als Partei angetreten. Das ist doch wirklich, also das ist doch nun wirklich ein Vogelschiss in der Geschichte. So warum reden wir darüber? Hier geht es doch um was ganz anderes. Er schreibt doch, statt ihre Geschicke in die Hände von politischen Eliten zu legen, machten die Bürger diese nun für die massiven gesellschaftlichen, ökologischen, politischen, ökonomischen Fehlentscheidungen verantwortlich, die sie seit den 70er Jahren zunehmend sichtbar sind. Der Vorwurf an Leute, die sich politisch engagieren und eine bessere Gesellschaft wollen, kann nicht sein, dass sie ja ihre politischen Geschicke nicht einfach in die Hände der Eliten gelegt haben, sondern jetzt auch noch anfangen, die Eliten zu kritisieren.
Aber das ist doch gar nicht als Vorwurf, wenn der macht das doch rein diskriptiv. Er sagt, es sei doch interessant, dass Ende der 70er folgendes passiert. Man ist unzufrieden mit Blick auf den Klimawandel und sagt sich dann nicht, ach ja, da müssen wir mal gucken, ob Norbert Blüm das regelt oder wer auch immer damals aktiver, sondern man sagt plötzlich, wir müssen was blockieren, dass Atomkraftwerke gebaut werden, dass das und das und so weiter passiert. Und daraus bildet sich ja auch dann wieder eine neue Partei, also die Grünen. Aber er beschreibt das ja erst mal als eine interessante Bewegung, dass man also nicht wie in den 60er Jahren oder 50er Jahren das einfach so über die Politik spielen ließ, sondern man kritisiert plötzlich die Herrschenden. Das ist ja eine Veränderung, die da stattfindet.
Ja, aber diese, wir haben doch schon mal beschrieben, dieses Phänomen, das ist eigentlich interessant. Beim Familienwahlrecht haben wir ja festgestellt, okay, one person, one vote. Wir sagen jetzt nicht Elon Musk, weil er 1000 Beschäftigte hat. Das sind deine Kinder. Du hast die Verantwortung für sie. Wir geben dir jetzt Stimmen. Faktisch gesehen haben wir aber anhand dieser Frage, wer hat eigentlich Termine beim Bürgermeister? Na ja, die 3000 Leute von 400.000 Wählern in Frankfurt, die halt ökonomische Kapazität haben, Termine beim Bürgermeister zu haben. Damit meine ich nicht, die kaufen sich die, sondern die haben halt Termine beim Bürgermeister. Was bedeutet, dass die Kritik an gesellschaftlichen, ökologischen, politischen, ökonomischen Fehlentwicklungen natürlich eine Adresse braucht und diese Adresse ist die Politik? Kritik in diesen thematischen Dimensionen an die Politik gerichtet ist nicht verkehrt. Der Vorwurf, dass diese Menschen dort, statt ihre Geschicke in die Hände von politischen Eliten zu legen, haben sie sie kritisiert.
Ja, aber das ist doch nur eine Beschreibung, dass sie das so gemacht haben.
Nein, das ist keine Beschreibung.
Er sympathisiert doch ganz eindeutig mit diesen Bewegungen.
Nicht.
Doch nicht. Er fragt sich nur, warum sie wirksam waren.
Du hast das als Sympathietext für diese Bewegung. Für mich ist das eine große Abhandlung im Sinne von, ihr habt es doch gesehen, ihr seid doch selber bescheuert.
Nein, es ist ein Abgesang darauf. Ich glaube, wenn man jetzt sagen würde, Herr Blühdorn, Sie dürfen die Welt noch mal erschaffen, wie hätten Sie sie gerne, dann würde er wahrscheinlich sagen, ich hätte gerne das aufgeklärte öko-emanzipatorische Subjekt, und das ganz viele Leute erreicht und davon überzeugt, dass wir nachhaltig werden müssen. Und das würde er wahrscheinlich sagen. Dann würde er aber zugleich hinzufügen, das Problem bei diesem emanzipatorischen, ökologischen, ist, dass diese Selbstverwirklichung auch wiederum das Projekt von Demokratie und Kollektivität unterminieren kann. Und genau das beschreibt er. Und er zeigt ja jetzt nicht auf, einfach das waren Irre, die was gegen die Politiker gemacht haben, sondern dass die Politiker sich darum nicht gekümmert haben. Das war ja schlimm und musste auch einen Kontrapunkt erleben. Und es hat ja auch eine Weile funktioniert. Also die Erfolgsgeschichte der Grünen, diese Gründung und diese Professionalisierung, dann zeigt ja auch, dass also eine Zeit lang genau diese Ansprache funktionierte. Und das wäre jetzt auch meine Frage, die ich erst mal konkret an dich habe. Du beziehst dich ja sehr häufig auf Luhmann, wie wir wissen. Luhmann ist in Bielefeld, also in NRW. In NRW ist damals die Bundeshauptstadt Bonn. Luhmann ist der Soziologe der alten Bundesrepublik und der stirbt bevor die neue Bundesrepublik dann entsteht mit Berlin. Man geht von Bonn nach Berlin.
Er stirbt 1998.
Ja, kommt ja genau dahin. Und Luhmann ist also einer, der eine Gesellschaft beschreibt, die auf einem ganz großen Konsens beruht im Sinne von die Abläufe funktionieren eigentlich. Die Bonner Republik im Ganzen funktioniert. Der Aktivismus, den gibt es und die haben auch ihre Funktion. Die haben auch in diesen Systemen etwas. Luhmann ist ja nicht jemand, der eine Gesellschaft beschreibt, in der zum Beispiel ein ganz ganz großer, nicht ganz großer, aber ein beträchtlicher Teil bereit ist, eine antidemokratische bis faschistische Partei zu wählen. Luhmann ist also nicht konfrontiert mit einer Wirklichkeit, die extrem anti-aufklärerisch ist. Luhmann ist nicht konfrontiert mit einer Gesellschaft, in der das aufgeklärte Subjekt ad acta gelegt ist. Luhmann würde immer sagen, ja das ist auch gar nicht so wichtig. Wichtig ist, dass alles funktioniert. Aber was ist, wenn plötzlich auch diese Vehemenz da reinkommt, von denen, die genau diese Demokratie zerstören wollen und die sagen, eigentlich ist mir das chinesische System oder so lieber, oder das chinesische System ist auch einfach erfolgreicher, dann als das westliche, sondern er erlebt ja seinen Aufstieg, quasi auch mit dem Aufstieg der westlichen Hegemonie und der liberalen Demokratie, die er dann ja auch dadurch erlebt, dass der Zusammenbruch der Sowjetunion stattfindet. Da sind wir ja heute in völlig anderen Zeiten. Deswegen frage ich mich, müssen wir nicht auch lomern insofern historisieren, indem wir sagen, ja, das ist aber auch eine Soziologie, die so nur entstehen konnte, weil es diese ein bisschen gemächtliche, aber alles in allem sehr gut funktionierende Bundesrepublik Deutschland gab.
Auf der einen Seite ja, weil diese Gesellschaft, wie wir sie da vorgefunden hatten, in relativ ruhigen Zeiten und dann mit dem Druck der Bibi-Roma-Generation überhaupt Universitäten geschaffen hat, in denen diese Art von, ich mache ja mal 30 Jahre Budget, Null und so machen kann. Ja, inhaltlich nein und nicht nur nein, sondern absolut nein. Dieses Buch Ökologische Kommunikation, in dem Niklas Luhmann beschreibt, warum die Gesellschaft als das umfassende und dann eben singuläre größte Sozialsystem, also alle Kommunikation, ist Gesellschaft. So, und diese Gesellschaft hat eine Umwelt. Sie hat naturale, biologische Voraussetzungen, die sie braucht, auf die sie nicht verzichten kann, die sie aber nach und nach zerstört. Und bei Luhmann kann man einfach nachlesen, und das ist auch ein sehr gutes Lehrbuch, um Systemtheorie an sich zu verstehen, würde ich sagen. Warum diese Umwelt nicht gerettet werden kann. Also Luhmann wäre nie auf den Gedanken gekommen, außer man beauftragt ihn politisch. Also er hat durchaus Texte für die CDU im Auftrag der CDU geschrieben, um dann irgendwie so Aufklärung zu machen. Also für deren Fragestellungen. Luhmann käme nie auf den Gedanken zu sagen, die Gesellschaft, die wir haben, ist unhaltbar, und die Kritik daran auch, und eigentlich wollen wir doch eine bessere Zukunft, und ich zeige jetzt mal einen besseren Weg oder sowas. Also diese Idee von...
Ja, weil alles super noch lief. Also Luhmann musste sich ja in der Frage des Klimawandels nicht in der Weise gefallen lassen, wie das heute ein Soziologe tun muss.
Naja, aber Luhmanns Gesellschaftstheorie ist eine Gesellschaftstheorie, die einfach als Theorie Gesellschaft beobachtet, ohne noch eine Fantasie oder eine Vorstellung davon zu haben, dass man da jetzt eingreifen kann. Und wenn es eine Gesellschaft im Untergang und der Zerstörung ist, dann ist das halt eine Beschreibung von Untergang und Zerstörung. Ohne dass jetzt der Niklas Luhmann als Beobachter und Theoretiker…
Aber macht das nicht Blühdorn auch? Also ich habe mich mit Unterang an Luhmann erinnert.
Nein, also Blühdorn macht… ich lese mal vor. Doch was auf diesen Zerfall folgt, den die letzte Generation, vor dem sie warnt, sagt, nein, diese Schwelle wollen wir nicht und überschreiten oder die nicht bewohnbare Erde, 8 Grad plus können wir uns nicht leisten, hat der Davolles damals geschrieben, ja? Bei Blühdorn heißt es einfach, doch was auf diesen Zerfall folgt, ist eben nicht die Apokalypse, das Ende der Menschheit und die Unbewohnbarkeit des Planeten, sondern die Politisierung und Neuramung um Welt, Klima und Nachhaltigkeitspolitischer Fragestellung sowie die gesellschaftliche Transformation in eine andere, moderne, jenseits der öko-emanzipatorischen Vorstellungskraft. Darum geht es in diesem Buch. Da würde ich sagen, was auf diesen Zerfall folgt, den uns die Klimawissenschaftler gerade sagen, ist nicht, naja, dann diskutieren wir halt anders und nochmal neu über Umwelt und Klima und Nachhaltigkeitsfragestellung, sondern nein, was auf diese Moderne folgt, wenn wir sie einmal durch unhaltbare Zustände, die wir selbst verursacht haben in unserer Umwelt, sind. Und das haben wir auch schon gesagt, bei 51 Grad ist egal, wer Präsident ist. Also das macht dann einfach...
Naja, aber es sind ja nicht dauerhaft 51 Grad in Deutschland. Also das wird ja nicht sein.
Also es geht nicht um die 51 Grad. Es geht darum, dass die ganze Umwelt, wie wir sie haben, aus dem Gleichgewicht gebracht wird, wenn wir ein paar Grad Erhöhungen haben. Ob das jetzt... Klar, bei 51 Grad sagen wir, also spätestens dann durch die Feuchtkugel-Experimente wissen wir, der Körper kann sich nicht mehr selbst in der Temperatur regulieren. Wir sind akut vom Tod bedroht. Wenn sich die Durchschnittstemperatur in Deutschland von 16 auf 18 Grad steigert, haben wir hier Ameisen, die alle Fundamente durchfressen und dann ist nichts mehr irgendwo was wert.
Aber du weißt, was dann... Es ist ja nicht so, dass jetzt einfach Deutschland von Ameisen aufgefressen wird, sondern dann wird es ja Maßnahmen dagegen geben.
So, und das ist dieser Glaube?
Nee, das ist bei mir kein Glaube. Das ist... Also ich will nochmal hier... Ich möchte ja nicht als Klima verharmloser... Ich würde sagen, jetzt wird ganz schlimm. Das Problem ist nur, dass die Leute sich an das Schlimme gewöhnen.
Aber was heißt ganz schlimm und wer sind die Leute? Das ist ja die Frage.
Ich kann dir das ganz konkret machen. Wenn in Deutschland im Sommer aufgrund der Hitze 200.000 Menschen sterben, wird man das hinnehmen.
Ja, aber das ist doch...
Und das ist das Schlimme?
Das Mindeste. Also 200.000 Leute sterben sowieso im Sommer. Das ist doch schon längst eingepreist.
Ja, aber daran kannst du es doch sehen. Du kannst doch einfach sehen, dass diese Gewöhnungseffekte... Die Gewöhnungseffekte sind doch unglaublich. Deswegen finde ich auch diesen Kontrast zum Krieg, den er da macht. Also das ist ein ökologisches Projekt und dann ist es ein Krieg. Das haben wir doch gesehen. Und da sind ja auch die Grünen wieder beispielhaft für. Es ist Krieg und man sagt sofort, naja gut, jetzt können wir auf keinen Fall... Also da nochmal mit CO2-Bepreisung ist ja eh alles teuer. Jetzt nochmal dies und das geht auch nicht. Lieferkettengesetz? Schieben wir mal auf die lange Bank. Das heißt, man ist sofort bereit, das alles abzuräumen. Man ist bereit, China jetzt zu sanktionieren, obwohl die eigentlich uns eine Technik geben könnten, mit der wir besser gegen den Klimawandel kämpfen, einfach aus geopolitischen Erwägungen. Also das zeigt doch, dass man da sofort bereit ist, dieses klimapolitische Projekt über Bord zu werfen, weil man jetzt gerade woanders ist. Also diese, wie er das nennt, diese Gegenwahrtsfixierung, die da stattfindet, die ist doch eine, die wir gar nicht leugnen können. Und du gehst doch auch nicht davon aus, dass wir unter irgendeiner Regierung in Deutschland oder in Europa eine CO2-Bepreisung bekommen, die so hoch ist, wie sie eigentlich sein müsste.
Das sind doch nicht die Kategorien, in denen ich das jetzt problematisieren möchte. Ich schreibe keine Plädoyer. Ich gehe nicht mal auf eine Demo. Ich schreibe keine Plädoyer zum Thema. Ich beobachte gerade über diesen Text einen Diskurs, von dem ich glaube, Blühdorn beobachtet ihn falsch. Das ist natürlich zu entschuldigen, weil wir hier Zukunft verhandeln, von der wir alle nicht wissen, dass es sie gibt. Aber dieses Szenario, in Deutschland sterben 200.000 Leute im Sommer, ja, das war vor 20 Jahren, so klaren wir uns daran gewöhnt. Dieser Begriff Übersterblichkeit wurde 2003, vor über 20 Jahren, von der Europäischen Union eingeführt, um die Hitze toten. In Frankreich und in Spanien im Sommer, klaren wir uns daran gewöhnt. Es geht auch nicht darum, uns daran zu gewöhnen, dass 200.000 Menschen sterben in dem 80-Millionen-Volk. Wir kennen nicht mal deren Namen und ja gut, die waren auch alle 84 und hätten vielleicht noch ein Jahr gelebt.
So geht das ja dann.
So geht das dann. Nein, das ist schon Vergangenheit. Die Zukunft bedeutet jeden Tag nur noch sechs Stunden Wasser aus dem Wasserhahn. Kein Strom mehr für mehrere Tage. Das ist doch das Szenario, das wir uns vorbereiten müssen.
Das ist ja in vielen Ländern so.
Ja, jetzt kann man natürlich sagen...
Ich habe mit jemandem gesprochen, der Familie in Pakistan hat, der da viel ist. Und er beschreibt dort ein extremes Dasein, das ich höre und denke, das kann gar nicht sein. Das beschreibt er mir aber fast als Normalität.
Das Ansinnen, das zu verhindern, indem wir einfach sagen, keine Inlandsflüge und lieber jetzt schon mal auf ein bisschen Strom verzichten, dafür keine Kohlekraftwerke. Und damit ließe es sich verhindern. Das Ansinnen, das zu verhindern, kann man nicht auf einem Tisch wischen, indem man sagt, wir werden uns schon dran gewöhnen. Und dann fühlen wir halt in dieser nächsten moderne, wie Blühdorn sagt, andere klimatechnische Diskussion.
Stefan.
Das ist doch dann keine Diskussion.
Was jetzt kommt, ist wirklich nicht persönlich gemeint, sondern ich meine, das nur, um es zu verbildlichen. Du hast jetzt gerade die Inlandsflüge angesprochen. Du hattest selbst hier mal einen Podcast berichtet. Und ich habe dir auch gar nicht dann widersprochen, dass das für dich sinnvoll war, von Frankfurt nach Hamburg zu fliegen.
Ja, wenn kein Zug fährt.
Warum? Genau. Und das ist das Projekt, was er nennt, das ist das Emanzipatorische an diesem Projekt, nämlich das Projekt der Selbstverwirklichung. Und seien wir doch beide so ehrlich, dass wir auch dieses ökologische Anliegen, dass wir hier beide sehr klar umreißen können, unterminieren. Und damit meine ich jetzt nicht, das sollten wir auch nochmal durchmachen, es geht jetzt hier nicht um so, der Konsument ist selbst schuld und der CO2-Fußabdruck und so, das ist ja auch wieder alles nur so eine Lobby-Geschichte von den großen schmutzigen Konzernen, das wissen wir. Sondern es geht jetzt wirklich so, dass so eine grundsätzliche Art der Lebensweise die ganze Zeit unterminiert, was man aber auch zugleich will und auch immer wieder herausstellt. Und dieser Widerspruch, der ist einfach extrem da. Und was er ja als Beispiel nimmt, wie wir uns, was man eigentlich jetzt im Theater spielen müsste, und ich gebe ihm absolut recht, ist, man sollte jetzt Beckett spielen. Also der hat eigentlich so eine Gesellschaft gezeigt, in der eigentlich so eine Apokalypse da ist. Aber die Leute sitzen halt in oder auf ihren Mülltonnen und quatschen weiter miteinander irgendein Dolzzeug. Und das ist ja das, was Beckett uns vorführt. Oder man wartet auf Godot und könnte ja vielleicht doch noch was passieren, aber Godot kommt halt nicht. Und in einer solchen Beckettchen-Situation habe ich den Eindruck, befinden wir uns und das sehen auch viele so, die dann sagen, ist das irgendwie alles so frustrierend oder so fatalistisch. Und du weißt selbst, wie häufig wir auch die Frage bekommen bei direkten Begegnungen mit dem Publikum, wie schafft man es nicht irgendwie verzweifelt zu sein und so etwas. Und das rührt ja genau aus dieser Beckettchen-Grundstimmung heraus. Und dann würde ich sagen, dass Blühdorn dies beschreibt. Wo ich eine Kritik äußern würde, ist, dass er vielleicht ein bisschen zu sehr übersieht. Und das ja doch transformatorisch vielleicht auf so einer technologisch kapitalistischen Ebene, wenn wir jetzt gerade nach China blicken oder auch andere Technologien uns ansehen, dass da vielleicht doch mehr passiert, ganz ohne irgendeinen Idealismus oder so, sondern wo man einfach sagt, ja, es gibt technische Möglichkeiten. Solarenergie ist eigentlich ein Gottesgeschenk. Damit könnte man es machen. Also ist vielleicht doch nicht alles verloren. Jetzt ist nur noch die Frage, wird man das schnell genug tun oder wird man zehn Jahre zu viel verstreichen lassen?
Ja, zu den Inlandsflügen. Also meine Argumentation war ja, ich nehme einen Inlandsflug, weil der Zug nicht fährt. Und jetzt sagst du, na das ist ja dieses transformative Projekt. Und dann sage ich nein.
Du könntest ja sagen, schade, dann hat es nicht geklappt.
Dass ein Zug von Frankfurt nach Hamburg fährt, ist für mich Daseinsvorsorge. Das hat mit Klimawandel und Diskussionen zum Thema, du hast aber fantastische Ideen und so gar nichts zu tun. Das ist ganz elementare Daseinsvorsorge.
Meine Großeltern sind niemals in Hamburg gewesen und konnten auch damit leben. Also verstehst du, wir haben einfach andere Maßstäbe. Ich stimme dir absolut zu. Ich wäre wahrscheinlich auch in das Flugzeug gestiegen, wenn ich nicht so viel Gepäck hätte.
Also seit 30 Jahren fahren durch Deutschland ICEs. Wenn wir jetzt sagen, wir bauen diese Flotte zurück, was ja von Friedrich Merz ein ernster Vorschlag ist. Wir bauen die ICE-Flotte zurück. Wir schränken den Dienst der Bahn ein, haben aber noch Inlandsflüge. Also die gehen noch, aber die Bahn geht nicht. Und warum? Weil wir im Haushalt Budgetknappheit haben, da wir ja eine Notlage im Ahrtal klimawandelbedingt von 30 Milliarden bezahlen mussten. Wenn wir das jetzt einpreisen, als, nein, Stefan fordert, dass die Bahn, wenn überhaupt, und dann vielleicht noch pünktlich fährt. Wenn das jetzt schon in dieses sozioökologische Transformationsprojekt zählt, von dem Blühdorn sagt, die sind ja selbst schuld, die haben das falsch geplant, dass das als Vokismus abgelegt wird und sozusagen eine Reaktanz in der Politik entsteht, dann würde ich sagen, dann ist vorbei. Also dann brauchen wir keine politische Diskussion für.
So weit würde ich auch nicht gehen. Nur die Tatsache ist, ich weiß, was du meinst und sehe das ja mit der Bahn ganz ähnlich, nur unsere Anspruchshaltung ist generell eine, die so aussieht, dass wir das autonome Subjekt ganz hoch stellen und zugleich erleben wir diese enorme Frustration darüber, dass wir angesichts des Klimawandels an Autonomie verlieren. Wir aber zugleich wiederum die Möglichkeit haben, mit Konsum wieder eine gewisse Autonomie unter Beweis zu stellen. Und damit sind wir in so einer permanenten Kippbewegung, die dann zu dieser Pointe führt, dass Blühdorn sagt, Demokratien sind Quardemokratien für den CO2-Ausstoß verantwortlich. Das heißt also, das ist quasi auch ein Mehrheitsvotum, dass man sagt, ja, wir wollen jetzt mal so weitermachen. Und ich glaube, dass man sehr gut sehen kann, dass viele versuchen, und das ist nicht nur die letzte Generation, er nennt jetzt zum Beispiel auch die Soziologen Nachtwey und Amlinger, dass man also versucht, nochmal eigentlich anknüpfen zu wollen an ein aufgeklärtes Subjekt. Also alte Normen, sagt er, würden viele dieser Soziologen heraufbeschwören. Aber dass diese Normen irgendwie nicht mehr so richtig greifen. Und damit meint er, es könnte durchaus sein, dass wir jetzt nicht an einer spätmodernen Grenze stehen, die zu mehr Freiheit und einem guten Leben führt, sondern dass wir eigentlich genau davon gerade Abschied nehmen und uns dann in besser oder schlechter Weise arrangieren mit Verhältnissen, die auch so aussehen könnten, dass erstens das Ende des demokratischen Kapitalismus nahe ist. Und wenn ich deinen Ausführungen zu Trump und dem, was er vorhat, folge, dann kann ich das also sogar im Westen dann schon diagnostizieren. Dass zweitens die planetaren Grenzen ganz deutlich da sind und wir aber dann unseren Urlaub noch organisieren, zugleich aber schon die Klimaflüchtlinge dort vielleicht vor Ort sehen. Drittens haben wir eine autokratische Wende, ja, auch dahingehend, dass selbst Aktivisten und Klimawissenschaftler ja plötzlich mehr Technokratie einfordern und sagen, schreib das doch mal ins Grundgesetz rein. Also auch der Demokratie in dem Sinne nicht mehr vertrauen, sondern sagen, na ja, wenn man es irgendwie noch ins Grundgesetz reinbekommt, dann ist es einfach so. Und dann viertens hat man noch so eine Frustration des Subjekts, so dann eine Kränkung des Subjekts, möglicherweise dann durch künstliche Intelligenz. Und das ist, finde ich, erstmal eine sehr allgemein gehaltene Diagnose, aber eine durchaus schlüssige. Plus vünftens kommt dann schon das angesprochene Ding mit China hinzu, die man als Systemrivalen dann verstehen will. Was er sich nicht so eigen macht, was er aber beschreibt als so ein Diskurs, der da ist.
Ihr seht ja ja so ein bisschen, wie prächtig es ist, aber bei einem Satz. Also ich muss ja doch feststellen, ich habe noch andere Unzufriedenheiten mit diesem Buch, als ich dachte, konzeptionell. Schon, weil es unklar ist, über was man hier eigentlich spricht. Also zum einen finde ich, er spielt herunter, was der Klimawandel wirklich bedeutet. Er spricht ja auch nicht von irgendetwas. Er sagt einfach die nächste Gesellschaft oder irgendwas, die kommende und so. Er bleibt ja ganz im Ungefähren. Da finde ich, es spielt das herunter. Auf der anderen Seite, es sind kleine Stellschrauben, von denen wir wissen, warum sie anders gezogen werden. Warum hat es so ewig gedauert, zu dieser Solarenergie in Deutschland zu kommen, dass man jetzt selbst ein Balkonkraftwerk noch genehmigen lassen muss? Was ist das für ein Blödsinn? Warum kauft man nicht einfach bei Amazon so eine Platte und steckt ja in seine Steckdose und betreibt damit sein Fernseher? Warum geht das nicht? Na ja, weil es über politische Programme organisiert wurde, dass Energie zentral hergestellt wird von jemanden, der damit sehr viel Geld verdient. Und mit sehr viel Geld meine ich im zweistelligen und dreistelligen Milliardenbereich gleichzeitig der Gesellschaft Kosten aufbürden. Die sollen mal in 70.000 Jahren noch den Atommüll da irgendwie lagern und so. Wir haben es also hier mit Fehlspezifikationen zu tun, von denen ich mir auch von Menschen, die es kritisch sehen, eine Würdigung erhoffe, wie dämlich es in der Gegenwart ist. Ich will nicht, dass mir die Zukunft heruntergespielt wird, im Sinne von es wird schon nicht so schlimm. Und dass dann die Gegenwart mit, ne, das sind auf gar keinen Fall, also das geht gar nicht.
Aber sagt er, es wird nicht so schlimm. Das sind so große Wünsche. Er sagt, es wird anders, aber es wird nicht, er sagt ja nicht, es wird nicht so schlimm.
Er sagt, es wird nicht schlimm. Es droht weder der Untergang der Menschheit.
Ja, der droht ja auch nicht.
Was ist denn der Untergang der Menschheit?
Der Untergang der Menschheit wäre wirklich das Ende der Menschheit.
Und das ist ja nicht...
Ja, das ist ein Super-GAU, wenn die Welt stattgemacht wird.
Aber jetzt überleg doch mal, wie groß die Probleme in Deutschland sind, wenn es heißt, 1,7% weniger Gas, alle in Panik. Inflationssprünge von 10%. Das Ende der Menschheit wäre natürlich schlimm. In Deutschland sind schon 1,7% weniger Gas in der Versorgung schlimm.
Ja, ich mal dir das jetzt ganz kurz aus. Wir haben jetzt eine sehr deutsche Perspektive. Sprich mit Menschen aus anderen Ländern, die nicht so wohlhabend sind.
Aber wir können das doch verhindern.
Warum akzeptiert es das nicht? Ja, das fragt man sich ja, warum wird es nicht verhindert? Denn interessant ist ja, dass es fast überall in der Welt schlechter ist als in Deutschland.
Das würde ich auch wieder bezweifeln.
Naja, ökonomisch.
Wir sind ökonomisch sehr gut bestellt. Ich glaube, dass wir in Deutschland gar nicht so richtig vorwärts kommen. Naja, wo willst du hin?
Willst du nach Guatemala? Willst du nach Mexiko? Willst du nach Nigeria?
Würdest du gerne in China leben, in Pakistan? Wenn selbst in Afrika vielleicht, denke ich, die Internetverbindungen besser sind.
Wir können auch mal über die Stromausfälle in Südafrika sprechen zum Beispiel, über das Südafrika, das ungleichste Land der Welt ist. Es gibt nicht allzu viele Länder, die zum Beispiel demokratisch organisiert sind, wie unser Land und die wohlhabend sind. Ja, das ist ja die Frage, die ihr hier stellt und die uns tatsächlich doch umtreiben sollte, dass wir eine Unterminierung dieser liberaldemokratischen Werte haben. Und die Frage, die sie stellt, liegt vielleicht daran selbst. Ist also eine Art der Selbstermächtigung, die da drin liegt, eine, die eigentlich wiederum destruktiv ist für das eigentlich demokratische Projekt. Und bedeutet es nicht, dass wenn gerade die Demokratie ihre Ineffizienz ständig beweist mit Blick auf den Klimawandel, dass also dieses Projekt sich überholt und man irgendwo anders ankommt. Und er stellt nicht, er beantwortet nicht, wo wir dann ankommen. Wie Veit Selk auch uns die Demokratie-Theorien dekonstruiert und sagt, na, keine Ahnung, wo wir jetzt da ankommen. Man kann natürlich blicken in andere Länder und sehen, wie es dann da gehandhabt wird. Und da würde ich sagen, das ist nicht für mich eine positive Alternative. Nur, du siehst ja, dass es immer mehr politische Kräfte auch in westlichen Ländern gibt, die durchaus sagen, wir gehen darüber hinaus. Und wir sehen ja auch ein Wählerpublikum, das dazu bereit ist. Und wir sehen deswegen eine andere Moderne. Das ist ja vielleicht das Wichtige nochmal, warum ist es dann immer noch eine Moderne? Weil er sagt ja nicht, es ist einfach eine Regression, dass wir sagen, und bald kommt der Faschismus wieder oder sowas. Und ich würde sagen, dass diese andere Moderne sich an manchen Punkten immer festhalten ist. Also ich fand es zum Beispiel sehr interessant, dass Ralf Schumacher, der Rennfahrer, sich ja kürzlich geoutet hat. Mit Anfang 50, sein Freund ist so Anfang 30. Die leben in Monaco, treffen sich da abends mit den Geissens, weißte, diesen Fernsehmillionären. Und dann hat man herausgefunden, ach, das ist aber eigenartig, dieser Freund von Ralf Schumacher, der folgt ja diesen ganzen Le Pen-Leuten bei Instagram. Und dann sah man, ah, der kommt, der folgt dir nicht nur, der hat auch mal da so eine kleine Parteikarriere gemacht und hat sich aber dann aus der Politik verabschiedet. Und das würde ich sagen, das ist ganz gut, diese andere Moderne schon mal geschildert. Man hat Geld verdient, damit dass man viel Kerosin verbrannt hat. Oder was verbrennen die? Ja, Kerosin und Benzin, also viel geflogen und viel gefahren mit dem Auto. Lebt jetzt in Monaco, also in so einer reichen gated community. Und ist aber in einem modernen Lebensmodell. Das heißt, man hat sich scheiden lassen und lebt jetzt in einer homosexuellen Beziehung. Das ist eine andere Moderne. Das ist auch eine Moderne. Das ist nicht ein Rückschritt. Ich kann nicht sagen, die machen 19. Jahrhundert oder so. Aber es ist so eine komische Parallelität. Nämlich, da ist das immer ein zipatorische Projekt. Sei wer du willst, du kannst zum Beispiel schwul sein. Und damit ist aber auch zugleich sehen wir hier einen Lebenswandel, der auch noch mit nahe rechten Politik offenbar einhergehen kann. Und das finde ich dann an solchen Punkten. Ich will jetzt nicht überhören dieses eine Ereignis. Aber man kann, glaube ich, wenn man so ein bisschen diese Brille aufsetzt, ganz, ganz viele dieser Beispiele finden und findet sie auch in den rechten Parteien ganz explizit, auch in Deutschland im Übrigen, dann kann man, glaube ich, daran sehr gut sehen, wie dieses aufklärische, demokratisch-emanzipatorische Projekt plötzlich unterminiert wird, damit aber nicht alles moderne aufgegeben wird, sondern plötzlich das Moderne in so einer verqueren Form noch da bleibt und dann, also im Sinne von gewisse moderne Lebensziele sind okay, aber zugleich kann man auch ganz rechte Politik oder sowas machen. Das heißt, wir können doch auch bei jemanden wie Peter Thiel sehen, dass er zum einen so ein Technofotorist ist, dass er zum anderen aber ganz viele regressive, rechte Ideologien hat. Und da sehen wir schon, dass also diese Art, wie wir jetzt Demokratie verstehen und wie sie auch z.B. die Grüne Partei verstanden hat und aus einer Idee heraus, in der sie entstanden ist, dass das etwas ist, was immer mehr untergraben wird bzw. nicht mehr genügend Wähler findet. Und das, finde ich, diagnostiziert Blühdorn hier mitunter etwas wortreich. Ich gebe es zu. Aber ich finde es eigentlich so als Diagnose ziemlich treffend.
Ich halte dagegen. Seine Diagnosen sind nicht treffend und ich finde sie auch nicht gut, denn ich wünsche mir etwas anderes. Ich lese vor. Was auch immer er jetzt meint, wenn er die kritische Nachhaltigkeitssoziologie meint. Er hat sich ja schon an Fridays for Future, Last Generation, was auch immer abgearbeitet. Jetzt ist plötzlich diese Nachhaltigkeitssoziologie. Er schreibt, die kritische Nachhaltigkeitssoziologie muss aus ihrem zu engen normativen Horizont ausbrechen. Warum muss sie aus ihrem engen normativen Horizont ausbrechen? Die Klimazerstörer haben doch einen sehr engen normativen Horizont, der mal kognitiv ein bisschen erweitert werden muss. Nun gut, denn die emanzipatorischen Problemdiagnosen und Therapievorschläge, die sie bisher entwickelt hat, haben, vielleicht ungewollt, vielleicht ungewollt und unbewusst, immer auch das weiter so ermöglicht und damit den nahtlosen Übergang in eine andere moderne Jenseits der Autonomiemündigkeit, Würde, Menschenrechte und demokratischen Selbstbestimmungen betrieben. Sich aus nicht-reflektierter Komplizenschaft zu befreien, muss für die kritische Soziologie ein ureigenes Anliegen sein. Ich unterstelle ihm jetzt, er ist ein Komplize des Status Quo. Und die Frage ist jetzt, wer von uns beiden hat denn recht, der Autor oder ich? Wieso unterstellt er denn den Kritikern, da sie eine vielleicht ungewollte Komplizenschaft eingegangen sind und damit mit herbeigeführt haben, dass wir jetzt eine Abkehr von Autonomiemündigkeit, Würde, Menschenrechte und Selbstbestimmung. Nein, das ist doch nicht den anzulasten, die kritisiert haben, dass wir ja auf dem falschen Weg sind. Und die Argumentation vorher, also dieses Aufströseln von, es gibt einen emanzipatorischen Transformationswillen und einen ökonomischen und die beschränken sich so gegenseitig. Und dann übernimmt aber das eine Überhand über die andere, weil man doch so eine Mehrheit politisch hinter sich versammeln kann, wie auch immer. Also Söder, wenn er plakatiert, das Schnitzel muss bayerisch bleiben, hat natürlich immer recht, weil sehr viele Bayern Schnitzel essen wollen und nur sehr wenige nicht. Aber da kann man doch nicht einfach den Kritikern das jetzt in die Schuhe schieben und sagen, ich schlage mich mal als Autor auf die Seite der Gewinner und schreibe ihnen noch ein Pamphlet, in dem drinsteht. Ja, also wenn ihr so kritisiert werdet, kein Wunder, dass ihr da reagtant einfach in den Zug weiter in die Richtung fahrt.
Geht es nicht eher darum, dass er den Kritikern vorwirft, dass sie affamativ waren und wir beide kennen doch allzu viele Leute, die auf Transformationskonferenzen, auf anderen Digitalkonferenzen und sonst wo rumspringen und die Revolution dort ausrufen und dann auch entsprechende Schlagworte in den Mund nehmen und alle Begrifflichkeiten parat haben. Und da sitzt ein Publikum, das besteht aus Regierungspolitikern, aus Wirtschaftsakteuren und die lassen sich das auch alles mal so schön auf der Zunge zergehen. Und dann gibt es am Ende noch so eine Motivationshaltung von Seiten dieser Speaker, die sagen, und jetzt geht es darum, gemeinsam diese Transformation auch zu beschleunigen. Wir brauchen auch sie alle als Initialzündung für das große Ganze. So endet das, großer Applaus. Und genau dies ist etwas, was eine Kritik dann ist, die total affirmiert werden kann. Man suggeriert allen noch mal, ja wir als mündige Subjekte, jetzt bringen wir es aber auf den Weg. Und es geschieht genau nichts. Und ich glaube, dass ganz viele dieser, wir brauchen nur Mut, wir müssen mal alle protestieren gehen, wir müssen mal hinaus und jetzt aber mal richtig, dass diese ganzen Bücher und davon sind ja jetzt in den letzten drei Jahren etwa 700.000 erschienen in Deutschland. Dass die alle in diese Richtung gehen. Die verstehen sich als Kritiker von Markus Söder und die verstehen sich ja als Kritiker von Aiwanger und AfD und so weiter. Aber der eigentliche Status quo, der wird nicht in Frage gestellt, sondern man gibt eigentlich dort so ein bisschen Hoffnung, ein bisschen Kritik und dann wird es schon irgendwie weitergehen. Aber es geht nicht weiter im Sinne von wir verändern etwas.
Ich habe mit Maja Göbel selbst persönlich darüber gesprochen, dass ich für den nicht richtigen Weg halte, den sie einschlägt, nämlich einfach zu versuchen, es reicht, wenn wir die Influencer und Multiplikatoren erreichen, weil dann kommen solche Konferenzsituationen raus, wie du sie beschrieben hast. Ich halte das für einen ganz falschen Weg. Ich würde immer über die Öffentlichkeit mobilisieren, nur wir können nicht alle für alles kritisieren. Also ich sage Maja Göbel geht den falschen Weg, sie sucht da nur nach irgendwelchen Multiplikatoren, die das dann ihrerseits ja was hernehmen lassen, bei dem Applaus. So, offenbar ein falscher Weg. Letzte Generation klebt sich auf die Straße fest. Da ist nichts mit irgendwer Klatsch Beifall, sondern genau das Gegenteil. Unser Kommentar dazu, völlig falscher Weg. Fridays for Future, wir hatten damals Luisa Neubauer bei uns im Aufwachen Podcast. Ich habe ihr gesagt, gestalte es als generationalen Widersatz. Die jungen Menschen wollen nicht die Erde erben, die sie von ihren Alten bekommen. Sie hat damals gesagt, ne, es ist vielleicht nicht eine gute Idee, das so konfrontativ zu machen. Wir versuchen es inklusiv zu machen. Wir sagen heute, also der Ingolf Blühdorn hat gesagt, das ist der völlig falsche Weg. Der summiert die da einfach alle mit rein. Jeder Weg, der bisher gegangen wurde, ist mit sehr guten Argumentationen als der schlechteste Weg deklariert worden. Dann sagst du noch, ja, die letzte Generation ist ja dann noch angetreten und das hat sie auch nicht geschafft. Seht ihr doch, Luisa. So, wir können natürlich einfach alle immer sagen, es war der völlig falsche Weg. Auf die Bühne zu gehen und vor CEOs zu sprechen, falscher Weg. Straßen zu blockieren, falscher Weg. Fridays for Future, große Mediale, niemand wird belästigt, das sind einfach nur Zuhörangebote. Nicht konfrontativ, alles inklusiv, völlig falscher Weg. Als politische Partei anzutreten, völlig falscher Weg. Und das einzige Angebot, was wir von Blühdorn bekommen, ist, die nächste Generation, die nächste moderne wird schon nicht so schlimm, Punkt.
Nee, er sagt gar nicht, er wird anders. Er sagt ja gar nicht, ob die schlimm wird. Er sagt, ein großes Problem ist mit all diesen kritischen Stimmen, mit den aktivistischen Stimmen und auch mit den eigenen Soziologen, Kollegen, und er nennt ja da die großen Namen, Reckwitz, Nachtwahl etc. sei, dass sie nicht die transcendentale Obdachlosigkeit erkennen wollen. Und das meint die normative Haltlosigkeit der Spätmoderne, die nicht nur ohne die Sicherheit und Orientierung der Religion auskommen muss, sondern auch ohne die der Aufklärung, also der emanzipatorischen Fortschrittserzählung vom kollektiven Auszug aus der selbstverschuldeten Unmündigkeit und ohne die hergebrachten Glaubenssätze der kritischen Theorie. Insbesondere blenden ihre Ansätze aus, dass diese modernistischen Werte emanzipatorisch aufgegeben werden können, sodass die Welt, aus der sie verabschiedet wurden, vielleicht gar nicht mehr als Dystopie wahrgenommen wird. Damit meint er aber nicht, dass er das wünscht, sondern was er meint ist, es kann sein, dass die Leute sich dem einfach entledigen und sagen, dann waren das irgendwie so Werte interessant. Und wir machen aber einfach so weiter. Deine Beschreibung des amerikanischen Wahlkampfs, wenn ich an unseren letzten 29er-Podcast denke, ist doch eigentlich ein sehr zynischer Blick. Und mir ist das als Marxist natürlich sympathisch, indem du sagst, die sollen einfach Show machen. Also das heißt, du siehst gar nicht mehr das emanzipatorisch aufgeklärte Subjekt. Das heißt, du sagst doch auch nicht mehr, Mensch toll, jetzt Kamala Harris, das wird noch mal so eine große Transformation los treten, sondern das wird eine Riesenshow und hoffentlich kriegt ihr den verrückten Alten gebändigt und dann ist Trump für immer Geschichte. Das ist die Hoffnung, die noch da dran geknüpft ist. Aber diese transzidentale Obdachlosigkeit, also diese Idee, das spüren wir und die Idee, dass es so einen kollektiven Auszug aus einer selbstverschuldeten Unmündigkeit geben kann, das ist doch etwas, was wir uns wünschen und wahrscheinlich fast alle, die uns hier zuhören und das ist ja auch Teil unserer Mission, wenn man so möchte. Aber wir können doch im Ganzen konstatieren, dass das gesellschaftlich nicht vorzufinden ist und das meint er ja nicht, in dem Sinne, dass er jetzt sagt, ich will mal Maja Göpel und die Iren durch den Kakao ziehen, sondern er zeigt einfach, dass da so wenig ist und man kann es doch gerade sehr gut sehen. Also zum Beispiel macht ja Maja Göpel diese Utopie-Konferenz in Lüneburg und guckt, wer jetzt dort, also ich war auch eingeladen, ich kann aus terminischen Gründen nicht kommen, aber guck, wer da zum Teil auch eingeladen ist. Da sitzt jetzt irgendwie Florence Gaub und so Leute. Das heißt also, die machen jetzt die NATO auf der Utopie-Konferenz. Das ist einfach so idiotisch, wie man es kaum beschreiben kann. Und das zeigt aber eigentlich noch mal eine Bestätigung von Blühdorn, dass dieses ökologische Projekt, wann immer irgendwas kurzzeitiges gerade kommt, über Bord geworfen wird. Und dass man sich damit in eine ganz, ganz merkwürdige Gesellschaft bewegt. Vielleicht aber du als Lumanianer musst jetzt sagen, was ist generell von Ulrich Beck zu halten? Und wie sinnvoll findest du es, so stark sich mit Ulrich Beck zu beschäftigen, wie Blühdorn das tut?
Also, er nutzt ja Ulrich Beck aus einem Grunde, nämlich, dass es da so eine Fortschrittsgeschichte irgendwie gibt. Erste, zweite, dritte, moderne. Kann man ungefähr so zusammenfassen, die erste moderne ist so eine klassische Industriegesellschaft mit einem Fokus auf wirtschaftliches Wachstum, technologischen Fortschritt, gespägt von nationalstaatlichen Strukturen, basierend auf einer Idee eines zentralen Subjekts, das sich irgendwie selbst verwirklicht. Eine Eingangsfrage, ich als Ökonom und, also Ökonom, qua Natura quasi, ich bin halt einfach ein Mensch, der Geld hat und bin deswegen immer ökonomisch, immer unterwegs. Und die Frage ist, kann man das auch so politisch verwirklichen, einfach sein Ansinn? Zweite Moderne ab den 1970er Jahren, da kommt dann dieses öko-emanzipatorische Projekt auf. Man hat ein verstärktes Risiko-Bewusstsein und auch eine Sensibilität für die Umwelt. Die Grenzen des Wachstums werden also auch ideell etabliert. Damit kommen soziale Bewegung auf. Wir sehen irgendwie so Widerstände. Wird ja auch ein bisschen begleitet bei Star Trek am Anfang. Captain BK, alles super. Und dann bei Deep Space Nine gibt es plötzlich den Marquis. Und die Föderation ist gar nicht mehr so cool. Ja, solche Sachen werden natürlich kulturell dann begleitet. Streben nach mehr Demokratisierung und Emanzipation. Also mehr Inklusion. Und damit fühlen sich die ersten schon exkludiert aus der Gesellschaft. Es entsteht so ein Katalog an Versprechen der Moderne, die noch nicht eingelöst sind. Aber jetzt fordert man sie mal so ein bisschen ein. Diese sozioökologische Transformation nimmt also dann in dieser Risiko-Gesellschaft, die Bexil beschreibt, Anlauf. Und wir haben so ein kosmopolitisches Denken plötzlich, das umgreifen kann, aber das keine Traktion hat, sondern so freischwebend. Und die dritte Moderne, spätmoderne, das ist dann so dieses Gegenwärtige. Er sagt jetzt, wir sind in dieser doppelten Unhaltbarkeit angekommen. Wir haben es jetzt durchschaut. Weder die Realität ist haltbar, noch die Kritik daran, sondern beides löst sich auf. Das Subjekt wird immer schwächer in seiner Bedeutung. Von Autonomie und Selbstbestimmung will schon gar keiner mehr so richtig reden. Die Digitalisierung bringt jetzt, und dann auch noch die künstliche Intelligenz, also geht dann weit über Beck hinaus, bringt das da irgendwie rein. Wir haben illiberale und autoritäre Tendenzen. Über die Illiberalität haben wir gesprochen. Also wie ist das Wechselspiel aus Politik und Juristerei? Bringt auch noch für sich Fragen auf, wo kann man überhaupt einen Hebel ansetzen? Und ein Verlust des Glaubens an Steuerbarkeit in gesellschaftlichen Entwicklungen bricht sich bahn. Und zwar auf allen Ebenen. Nicht nur wer sich an der Straße festgebt, hat so eine, ich kann ja gar nichts machen, ich bin dem ausgeliefert, sondern auch Olaf Scholz wacht morgens auf, Angst schlottern, was ist denn jetzt schon wieder weltlos? Wie kriege ich denn das erklärt? Handlungsunfähig, unhaltbar. Der Koalitionsvertrag, drei Wochen alt, antike Geschichte. So, diese Gemengelage also. Jetzt kann man sich ja ernsthaft fragen, ist es nicht wahnsinnig intuitiv plausibel? Stefan hat es jetzt auch ziemlich flüssig vorgetragen. Das macht total Sinn, das so zu sehen. Und jetzt möchte ich aber einwenden, vielleicht auch nicht. Vielleicht brauchen wir hier wirklich eine ganz große andere Brille. Vielleicht sollten wir mal diese ganzen Ideen von, sie begegneten uns in Kinderbüchern und dann auf der Opernbühne. Ja, das eine sind eben Kinderbücher und das andere ist Bühnrealität. Stand das Subjekt wirklich immer so zentral? Ist eine formale Struktur erst heute von einem Kanzler nicht mehr zu bändigen? Oder war das schon immer so? Vielleicht sah es einfach nur alles anders aus. Und vielleicht gibt es aber unter diesen Veränderungen, die wir heute erleben, und da würde ich jetzt sagen, eine der primären Veränderungen ist einfach und davon handelt ja mein erstes Buch. Vor 30 Jahren hat man sich halt fünf Minuten am Tag mit Politik befasst, wenn überhaupt. Heute wacht man morgens auf und guckt sich erstmal drei Stunden YouTube-Klips an von Trumps Auftritt am Vortag. Vielleicht hat sich einfach nur unsere mediale Rezeptionsgeschichte verändert, aber vielleicht ist unter diesem ganzen, ich sehe die Politiker ganze Zeit, ich fühle mich ihnen ganz nahe. Vielleicht ist es nur Partizipationstheater, wie Dietmar Daert sagte. Vielleicht war eine Formal-Jahr schon immer streng. Vielleicht war ein Bundestag schon immer abgeschottet wie heute. Vielleicht waren die Zugangsregeln einfach schon immer hart ins politische System. Wer hat sich denn damals durchgesetzt und wer leitet darunter, sich heute nicht durchzusetzen? Naja, die Leute, die sich heute nicht durchsetzen, haben sich auch damals nicht durchgesetzt und damals haben sie nicht drunter gelitten, weil, wem sollten sie es sagen? Sie hatten keinen Twitter. Sie konnten das nicht auf Facebook komplizieren. Da haben nicht 100 Leute geschrieben, ich fühle mich auch usw. ausgegrenzt. Vielleicht sollten wir zum einen mal das Subjekt uns selbst ein bisschen rausnehmen aus dem Bild und uns nur die Art, wie wir kommunizieren, anschauen. Und daneben uns die harte Realität formaler Zugangsregeln in Erwerbsbiografien, in Parlamente, in den wissenschaftlichen Betrieb, dass wir einfach jeder kommuniziert so jeder die ganze Zeit so vor sich hinaus und verbinden damit die ganze Zeit so eine Wirksamkeitserwartung. Das ist wirklich nur ein Privatspaß, den wir so haben. Die Uniklinik forscht nicht so. Der Bundestag arbeitet nicht so. In der Arbeitswelt darf man sich das auch nicht erlauben. Das war damals so und heute so. Da unterscheidet mir nicht zwischen erster, zweiter, dritter, moderner oder was auch immer. Wenn wir also feststellen als Autoren, dass wir heute Bücher brauchen, die den Diskussionsstand aufgreifen, und wir sagen dann, dieses Buch gibt es aber noch nicht, ich schreibe es selbst, und dann legen wir so ein Buch vor, das überhaupt nicht reflektiert, das sich vielleicht nur die Art und Weise der Diskussion verändert hat und man deswegen eine Lücke sieht für sein Buch, aber die harten empirisch nachweisbaren, sichtbaren, formalen Realitäten dieser Gesellschaft sich gar nicht so hart geändert haben, sondern wir relativ viele Sachen unabhängig des medialen Stresses, der um sie entsteht, runterbrechen können auf in der Politik pragmatische, programmatische, inhaltliche Entscheidung. Dann könnten wir ganz anders darüber diskutieren, warum der Bundestag zum Beispiel dieses klar sehr hohe Ideal des Gemeinwohls aus dem Blick verliert, nur weil im Lobby irgendwelche Leute rumrennen. Diese Kritik daran, es gibt Lobbyismus. Gilt einfach immer. Und sie widersteht und widersetzt sich immer der demokratischen Natur, dass wir ja eigentlich one person one vote haben und nicht einer hat noch einen Zugangsschlüssel für die Lobby. So, diese, wie ich ja selber finde, wenn ich darüber rede, völlig banale, völlig althergebrachte, überhaupt nicht innovative Kritik, ist vielleicht trotzdem die zeitgeistigste und inhaltlich richtigste, die anzubringen ist. Statt hier irgendwie so einen Popanz zwischen Unhaltbarkeiten und so aufzuziehen.
Aber es ist doch jenseits dieser Einflussnahmen durch Lobbyismus, den ich ja nicht hier leugnen will.
Es ist ja nicht nur Lobbyismus, ich habe jetzt nur mal so ein...
Verschiedene andere Dinge. Es ist ja auch so, dass er eine grundsätzliche Konstellation beschreibt, dass also diese aufklärerischen Werte zum einen hochgehalten werden und auch wichtig sind. Und zum anderen aber, sie auch die ganze Zeit missachtet werden. Das ist ja etwas, was er beschreibt. Und er beschreibt außerdem, dass wir natürlich nicht jetzt davon ausgehen können, es gab den absolut aufgeklärten Bürger und das waren alle Bürger. Und dann wurde das alles immer schlimmer. Insofern soll das ja auch nicht wie bei Veit Selk einfach so eine Geschichte sein, dass man sagt, damals war alles toll, dahin könnte man wieder zurück. Er beschreibt ja tatsächlich, dass auch durch diese Modernisierungen, die dann von Beck nachgezeichnet werden, ja sehr viel Positives auf den Weg kommt. Zum Beispiel die Anerkennung verschiedener Lebensstile. Das ist ja alles etwas, wo er nicht wieder hinter zurück will.
Das sind alles Sachen, die nichts kosten.
Genau.
Die also in einer Arena stattfinden, in denen nichts verteilt wird außer Anerkennung, Achtungserweisung, was auch immer.
Der Klimawandel kostet ja nicht nur jetzt irgendwelche Lobbyisten oder Unternehmen sehr viel Geld, sondern der würde ja auch unser Leben drastisch verändern.
Der kostet wirklich Geld.
Wenn wir eine entsprechende Klimapolitik machen, also eine Klimaschutzpolitik. Und da sehen wir ja schon wieder, wo wir nicht so ganz bereit sind, bei allem mitzugehen und dann natürlich hier große Reden schwingen können, aber dann auch im Ganzen uns nicht verändern wollen. Also wollen wir überhaupt, so könnte man ja auch mal fragen, wollen wir überhaupt, wenn die politische Macht da wäre, diese große Transformation, die nötig wäre für den Klimawandel, oder wollen wir die eigentlich gar nicht, wollen wir die immer wieder auch heraufbeschwören und sagen, Mensch, die müssten aber mal und tun nichts. Und wir wollen das vielleicht nicht. Und damit sind wir doch beim Kern dieses Buches angelangt.
Nein, wir sind im Kern des Problems angelangt.
Doch, das ist das Kern des Buches. Weil er beschreibt, dass das mit unserem Selbstverständnis, mit unserem öko-emanzipatorischen Selbstverständnis, das auf Selbstverwirklichung und all das hinaus läuft, dass eigentlich etwas ist, was nicht so gut miteinander vereinbar ist, weshalb ja auch einige davon ausgehen, dass autokratische Staaten, die also nicht sich um den demokratischen Willen scheren müssen, möglicherweise sehr viel effizientere Klimamaßnahmen treffen können. Und das ist ja etwas, was uns jetzt, es ist ja auch nicht von ihm Plädoyer und deswegen sollten wir alle Autokratien jetzt werden, sondern er sagt, das ist also ein Widerspruch mit dem, mit dem wir leben. Na, es ist natürlich ein böser Blick auf die Welt, wenn man so möchte, aber nur wenn man ein bisschen böse auf die Welt kriegt, kriegt man auch die Wahrheit. Und dann kommt, beschreibt er diese Modernisierungen bei Ulrich Beck und fragt sich, wo geht es da weiter? Und Beck hat ja dann noch so eine Vision, wie die Gesellschaft sein könnte. Und ich glaube, dass diese Vision heute nach wie vor sehr vertreten ist. Zum Beispiel bei Richard David Precht in seinem Buch, das wir jetzt besprochen haben, über das Jahrhundert der Toleranz, nämlich sagt er ja, vielleicht kann der Klimawandel uns dazu führen, dass wir uns als Gemeinschaft aller Menschen begreifen.
Das ist doch genau so eine Träumerei.
Aber du fandest das ja sogar gut. Du fandest das ja sogar gut. So, und jetzt lass uns das hier zitieren, was er über Ulrich Beck schreibt. Es war immer ein Widerspruch, dass Beck einerseits, so wie Gerhard Schulze, Sigmund Baumann, Andreas Reckwitz und andere es später weitergeführt haben, die Auflösung kollektiver Identitäten und etablierter sozialer Strukturen beschrieb. Andererseits aber daran glaubte, die geteilte Risikoerfahrung könne und werde eine globale Risikogemeinschaft begründen. Zweifellos hat die Individualisierung neue Vergemeinschaftungs- und Identitätsbedürfnisse geschaffen. Die werden in der spätmodernen aber nicht in einer globalen Risikogemeinschaft befriedigt, sondern eher in Neogemeinschaften und kommunikativen Blasen, die spezifische Sinnerzählungen pflegen, ohne dabei die Komplexität realer Personen, Lebenswelten und gesellschaftlicher Verhältnisse abbilden zu müssen. Siehe Donald Trump, der eigene Wirklichkeiten baut. Es ist aber nicht nur auf der rechten Seite, sondern es gibt natürlich diese Blasenbildung auch bei der Mitte, bei Linken, wo immer. Das heißt, diese Neo-Gemeinschaften, die auch entstehen, also Neo-Gemeinschaften kennen wir alle, mit wem wir uns in Städten treffen und wer da plötzlich mit uns ganz eng ist. Da entstehen also Neo-Gemeinschaften, aber es entsteht keine Weltgemeinschaft, keine Weltrisiko-Gesellschaft, wie sie Beck sich vorgestellt hat. Und er nimmt also ein Irrtum von Beck, um zu sagen, das hat nicht stattgefunden. Aber möglicherweise müssen wir erkennen, dass andere Gemeinschaften entstehen und dass auch etwas anderes entsteht als ein liberal-demokratisches Projekt. Und das ist natürlich etwas, was durchaus beängstigen kann.
Mein abschließender Gedanke dazu ist, wie folgt, direkt darauf reagierend, denn man kann das so vorlesen und dann nochmal kontextualisieren und beschreiben und nochmal affirmativ oder nicht begleiten mit einer Kommentierung. Ich könnte mir aber gut vorstellen, dass man das jetzt gerade in der Bahn hört oder auf dem Weg zur Arbeit oder wie auch immer. Und heute Abend schon weiß man nicht mehr genau, was der Blühdorn da meinte. Man kann es einfach nicht. Es ist einfach, auch wenn es nur ein kurzer paar Sätze waren, es ist einfach zu kompliziert. Und ich habe ein Gegenmodell. Ich habe einfach ein Gegenmodell. Wir haben dieses Gespräch begonnen mit deinem Widersatz zwischen ökonomischer und politischer Agentenschaft. Und ich habe das aufgeschlüsselt mit, ja, bei dem einen können wir auf heller und pfennig durchrechnen. Was bedeutet was? Wo ist meine Selbstwirksamkeit? Was kriege ich von der Welt dafür? Was gebe ich der Welt zurück? Ja, man gibt seine Arbeit raus für Geld. Man kauft was für Geld. Man hat einen Kassenzettel. Das ist alles abrechenbar. In der Politik gilt das nicht. Wenn wir uns jetzt fragen, warum scheitert eigentlich der Klimawandel, können wir natürlich im politischen Felde bleiben und uns dann ergötzen an der Art und Weise, wie wir politisch darüber diskutieren, was zu diskutieren ist, weil es ja ganz wichtig ist, über den Klimawandel zu diskutieren. Und dann kleben sich die einen auf der Straße fest, die anderen machen so Influencer-Veranstaltungen und wir stellen irgendwie fest, dass Diskussionen irgendwie nicht der Bringer sind und noch mehr Diskussionen auch nicht der Bringer sind. Es wird nur komplizierter. Ich meine, diese Idee zu sagen, es gibt eine Unhaltbarkeit, die Diskussion läuft falsch, da hätte man jetzt auch irgendwas anderes herleiten können. Es müsste jetzt nicht dieses sozioökonomische, trans- und so weiter Projekt sein. Und dann hätte alles sich irgendwie aussehen können. Deswegen meine Ansage soziologisch fundiert. Ganz einfach, der Klimawandel führt uns aus einem Grund ins Verderben. Wir sind nicht bereit, die Kosten zu tragen. Und damit meine ich nicht politische Kosten, bei denen wir nicht genau wissen, was es bedeutet, dass jetzt wen müssen wir wählen, mit welchem Programm, was soll im Wahlprogramm stehen, sondern wir sind nicht bereit, die völlig transparent vor uns ausanalysierten, auf einen Bierdeckel passenden Kosten, den Klimawandel zu verhindern, zu bezahlen. Punkt. Dass man das dann programmatisch und so weiter ausdiskutieren könnte, wer will das nicht bezahlen und so weiter. Ja, jetzt, also okay, Blühdorn sagt das. Was wünsche ich mir für ein Buch, das auf dieses Problem reagiert? Keins zum Thema, wie wir politisch diskutieren, sondern wie so eine kleine Aufstellung. Erstmal, wie hoch sind die Kosten? Wer müsste sie davon bezahlen? Wer müsste sie bezahlen? Wer muss das Geld mobilisieren? Wie könnten wir denjenigen, der das Geld bezahlt, entschädigen? Und zwar rein finanziell. Jemand bezahlt etwas dafür, ein Kohlekraftwerk auszuschalten. Wieviel sind wir bereit, ihm dafür zu geben? Jemand ist bereit, den Wald, den wir da irgendwie brauchen, nicht mehr zu zerstören. Wie viel Geld sind wir bereit, ihn zu bezahlen? So, das sind politische Diskussionen, die sich nur ums Geld drehen, weil wir über Geld Motivationen, und das ist der einzige Punkt, wo für mich Subjekte eine Rolle spielen, Motivationen organisieren können. Hier geht es nicht um Steuerungs-Fantasien, hier geht es nicht um irgendwelche Visionen oder was auch immer, sondern es ist eine ganz einfache Kalkulation. Wir ermitteln ja, wie viel CO2 wir ausstoßen. Wir ermitteln, wie viel Energieerträge wir davon haben. Einfach durchkalkulieren, kristallisieren, und einen Strich drunter machen und fragen, sind wir dazu bereit? Ja oder nein? Aber das, was wir gerade vorfinden, ist doch nicht, dass Fridays for Future irgendwie, keine Ahnung, falsch diskutiert, sondern das Problem ist doch...
Nein, er meint ja auch nicht einzelne Aktivisten, sondern er meint die gesamte Gesellschaft. Also alle, die den Konsens akzeptieren, Klimawandel ist ein Problem.
Aber das Problem, das ich jetzt markieren möchte, ist nicht, dass irgendwo irgendwie und wir das alles hoch abstrahieren können, auf eine riesige Bewegung und die macht das falsch, sondern unser politischer Handlungsraum für Deutschland ist die Besetzung des Bundestages. Da dreht ein Zehn Parteien an und 3000 Leute. Es ist nicht unüberschaubar, deren Programmatik hinsichtlich Klima für uns zu strukturieren, dass wir verstehen, um was es da geht. Dass die FDP einfach ein halbseitiges Text-Ding dazu schreibt, wir machen das mit Zertifikate-Handel und die, die beim DIW dann ausrechnen, ja, das würde bedeuten 680 Euro pro Tonne CO2. Dann ist das der programmatische politische Teil, über den zu diskutieren ist und nicht über irgendetwas anderes. Wenn man das kontextualisieren will, muss man das mit den Modellen, wie die Grünen das machen und die SPD und die Linken vergleichen. Aber wir können nicht nur, weil es Klima und irgendwie unbestimmt und uns die Menschheit jetzt einfach anfangen. Wir machen das in der amerikanischen Wahl auch nicht, dass wir jetzt sagen, es ist zwar ganz schön, dass Kammerler es ist und es ist Trump-Kammerler, ich wünsche mir doch noch mal eine dritte. Nein, es gibt keine dritten Werte in diesen Diskussionen. Es gibt kein, Ulrich Beck hat auch was dazu gesagt, ja schön und gut, das ist mir total egal. Kein politisches Programm bezieht sich auf Ulrich Beck. Also warum sollten wir uns jetzt auf Ulrich Beck nochmal beziehen?
Na ja, weil er schon als Soziologie erprägend war für die rot-grüne Regierung 1998.
Ja, das ist, wie lange ist das her? 1998, 25 Jahre, 26 Jahre?
Dieser Geist von Ulrich Beck ist glaube ich schon sehr wirkmächtig gewesen.
Wir brauchen heute nicht den Geist von Ulrich Beck.
Er will ihn ja nicht wiederbeleben, er will ja gerade auch an den Irrtümern von Beck zeigen, wie die Gesellschaft sich in andere Richtungen verändert. Lass mich abschließen.
Wir brauchen Ökonomen, die uns politische Programme, die wirklich zur Wahl stehen, runterbrechen auf die Frage, was kostet uns?
Aber die Wahrheit ist doch, dass auch kein ökologisches Programm vorhanden ist. Ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass man sagen würde, wir hätten alle die gewählt, dann wäre alles in Ordnung. Sondern er will uns doch eigentlich hier deutlich machen, dass diese Idee, die Einzug hält mit der ökologischen Bewegung, das meinen nicht die einzelnen Leute, die einzelnen Aktivisten, sondern meint eine Gesellschaft, die sich auf den Weg macht, den Klimawandel als Probleme anzuerkennen. Sagt zum einen, erleben sie ihr eigenes, authentisches Selbst. Sagt zum anderen, bitte verstehen sie sich aber auch als ökologischer Citoyen, der bereit ist, diese vernünftigen Maßnahmen zu tun. Denn sie wissen ja, Kant definiert den Menschen als ein Vernunftswesen. Wir haben gerade gesehen, dass wir in einer Gesellschaft leben, die eine Frustration verspürt. Und was steht ihr dann zur Verfügung? Und auch angesichts des Klimawandels eine Frustration verspürt. Eine Bewältigung durch die Zerstreuungsindustrie. Darauf kommt ja noch zu sprechen. Smartphone und Co.
Eben, wir diskutieren halt anders. Wir haben andere Medienarbeiten und so.
Und nun ist es aber so, dass auch die demokratischen Werte, die vertreten werden eigentlich von so öko-emanzipatorischen Bewegungen, nicht mehr so richtig geglaubt werden. Weshalb er auch einen Shift beobachtet von dem eigentlichen Satz Listen to the people zu Listen to the science. Also doch nicht mehr die Leute. Also doch nicht mehr Demokratie. Also Demokratie meinte also, Repräsentation war immer schon Ausschluss des Volkes. Und da gibt es ja auch eine Tradition, die darauf zurückkommt. Und das bedeutet, dass da, wo man also das demokratische mehr zulässt, eher die Demokratie wieder bedroht wird durch die Institutionen. Denn wir haben über das Bundesverfassungsgericht geredet. Man könnte sagen, wenn es der demokratische Wille von Deutschland ist, von der deutschen Bevölkerung, der deutschen Wähler ist, dass die AfD eine große Mehrheit hat, dann muss es auch demokratisch dazugehören, dass die AfD bestimmt, wer dort in Karlsruhe als Richter sitzt. Was kann man sich jetzt da einmischen? Das ist ja eine Demokratisierung. Und da sagen wir aber, hm, es ist aber vielleicht doch nicht so toll mit der Demokratisierung. Zugleich wollen wir aber mehr Demokratisierung bei der Schuldenregel haben, wollen die aus dem Grundgesetz rausnehmen. Das heißt, wir sehen selbst, wie wir uns in Widersprüche verstricken und plötzlich Demokratie nicht mehr so hoch ansehen, wo sie uns möglicherweise hinderlich ist, wo unsere Ziele nicht da sind. Und all das führt uns ja noch mal zu einem Subjektbegriff. Und ich glaube, das ist eine genuine Stärke dieses Buches, dass man sich selbst noch mal sehr gut versteht. Und nicht im Sinne so einer neoliberalen Anrufung. Ja, siehst du, da hast du aber auch selbst nicht Müll getrennt, sondern noch mal so ganz grundsätzlich, wie wir als westliche Subjekte angerufen werden. Nämlich ausgerechnet die radikale Aufwertung emanzipatorischer Werte und der Idee des autonomen Subjekts in der stillen Revolution soll, sollte endlich den Schutz der Natur und die gesellschaftliche Transformation erreichen, die die älteren Naturschutzbewegungen mit ihren jeweiligen Triebfedern und Referenzen nie zu Wege gebracht hatten. Doch der Schutz der Unversehrtheit von Natur und Umwelt unter dem Vorzeichen der Autonomie des Selbst und des Subjekts, das sich überhaupt nur durch eine Emanzipation von Natur und Natürlichkeit konstituiert und behauptet, bedeutet ein Widerspruch in sich. Die Integrität der Natur erfordert die Begrenzung und Unterordnung des Subjekts. Die Autonomie des Subjekts hingegen bedeutet das Überschreiten vermeintlich natürlicher Grenzen und die Beherrschung der Natur. Und in diesem Widerspruch oder in diesem Dilemma, muss man da eher sagen, befinden wir uns. Ich glaube schon, dass es auch noch Wege daraus gibt. Ich würde vielleicht nicht ganz so fatalistisch das behandeln, auch wenn er immer wieder unterstreicht, so fatalistisch sei das gar nicht. Aber ich würde sagen, dass das als Zustandsbeschreibung sehr hilfreich ist.
Okay.
Ein großer Augenmerkstück von dir sieht mich an.
Ich finde, wenn Bücher so ein bisschen thematisches Pointengewitter abfeuern, das ist schon nicht verkehrt. Aber dieses Buch stellt sich eine Aufgabe, nämlich zu verstehen und uns zu erklären, warum der Klimawandel nicht so funktioniert, wie einige, die ihn forcieren mit guten Argumenten, nicht weiterführen. So, und unter dieser Fragestellung kämen wir, wenn es anders wäre, zu einer anderen Gesellschaft, in der wir mit weniger Klimawandelproblemen auskommen müssten. Wenn diese Frage in diesem Buch vorkommt, möchte ich erstens wissen, wie sieht der Weg dahin aus und was kostet es. Alle anderen Diskussionen haben wir jetzt seit 50 Jahren geführt. Also ob man dann 2024 nochmal an den 30 Jahre alten Backtags erinnert oder 2004 an den 10 Jahre alten Backtags, ist mir dann auch schnuppel irgendwie.
Wir gehen zum nächsten über. Hiroko Oyamada ist eine japanische Schriftstellerin, die jetzt im Rovold Verlag übersetzt erscheint. Ihr Roman Das Loch ist ganz schmal, aber er hat es in sich. 120 Seiten sind es. Aber es ist ein Roman, der uns in eine ganz andere Welt führt. Und zunächst einmal sieht gar nichts danach aus, denn es beginnt geradezu alltäglich in Japan. Die Ich-Erzählerin beginnt. Ich bin mit meinem Mann hierher aufs Land gezogen. Ende Mai hatte er erfahren, dass er versetzt werden würde in eine Geschäftsstelle, die sich zwar in derselben Präfektur, aber an der Grenze zur Nachbarpräfektur befindet. Es ist die Gegend, in der mein Mann aufgewachsen ist und in der seine Eltern auch jetzt noch wohnen, weshalb er gleich meine Schwiegermutter anrief, um zu fragen, ob sie nicht vielleicht von einem passenden Haus oder einer Wohnung wüsste. Warum zieht ihr nicht in das Haus nebenan? Nebenan? Das Haus, das wir vermieten, ist gerade frei geworden. Sie sprach so laut, dass ich hören konnte, was sie sagte. Meine Schwiegereltern hatten ein Haus, das sie vermieteten. Davon erfuhr ich zum ersten Mal. Und nun verlassen sie also den urbanen Raum, ziehen da in eine ländliche Gegend. Und diese junge Frau, die durchaus auch einen Kinderwunsch hat, die ist jetzt eigentlich dort primär Hausfrau. Sie muss ein bisschen sich um die Einkäufe kümmern, hat aber auch jetzt nicht zu viel zu tun, weil nun keine Kinder da sind und auch der Kontakt zu den Schwiegereltern nicht so eng ist. Sie bekommt aber einen eigenartigen Anruf von ihrer Schwiegermutter, ob sie da mal gerade mit Geld aushelfen kann. Sie hatte da vergessen, etwas abzuheben. Es ist alles ein bisschen merkwürdig. Und erstmal haben wir so einen Realismus des Schreibens, der dann aber in Surreale kippt, erstmal um so einen realistischen Ansatz zu schildern. Ganz in der Nähe gibt es einen großen Fluss. Bis zum Meer ist es zwar noch ein Stück, denn der Ort liegt eher am Oberlauf, aber der Fluss ist schon recht breit und das Wasser trübe. Ich hatte gedacht, es müsste so nah am Fluss kühler sein, doch dem ist nicht so. Ich spüre das Wasser, bevor ich es sehen konnte. Aber es war weniger eine frische Feuchte, die in der Luft lag, als der Geruch von stickigem Gras und wehendem Wasser. Und dann ist da auch noch mehr. Das Haus verlasse ich eigentlich nur, um zum Supermarkt zu gehen. Das aber tue ich möglichst nicht tagsüber, denn da ist es zu heiß. Der nächste Supermarkt heißt Maruchiku und hat schon ab 7 Uhr morgens geöffnet. Vielleicht, weil in der Gegend viele betagte Menschen wohnen oder aber weil Sommer ist. Sobald ich meinen Mann verabschiedet habe, frühstücke ich und mache mich dann als erstes zum Supermarkt auf. Davor ist ein riesiger Parkplatz. Wahrscheinlich geht man davon aus, dass die Kunden alle mit dem Auto kommen. So früh am Morgen ist es noch leer. Doch gegen neun oder zehn Uhr füllt er sich. Ältere Ehepaare fahren mit dem Auto vor und erscheinen kurze Zeit später mit schweren Taschen oder Einkaufswagen. Da sie so voll bepackt nicht über den Parkplatz laufen wollen, bleiben die Frauen in der Nähe des Ausgangs stehen und warten darauf, dass ihr Mann oder jemand anderes sie mit dem Auto einsammelt, was regelmäßig zu Staus führt. Wir kennen diese Situation. Wir können uns vorstellen, wie diese Lebenswelt jetzt ist. Dieser jungen Frau, sehr viele alte Leute sind da, also Überalterung der Gesellschaft. Es ist ja nicht so, dass nur ihre Schwiegereltern leben, sondern es gibt auch noch einen Großvater, der auch noch lebt, der den ganzen Tag den Rasen wässert, der immer nur lächelt, den man aber nicht ansprechen kann. Es ist fast so ein David Lynch Szenario, an das man denken muss wie Blue Velvet oder ganz normales Japan. Das ist das Interessante, wenn plötzlich sich alles etwas verschiebt. Denn sie geht dort ein bisschen durch diese Flusslandschaft. Dort sind Bäume allerlei gestrüpp, dort sind sehr viele fliegen. Und dann heißt es plötzlich, den Blick auf meine Füße gerichtet, lief ich weiter. Auf dem Boden lagen ein Plastikbecher mit halbverspeisten Instant-Nudeln, ein paar Papiertaschentücher, ein paar Arbeitshandschuhe sowie eine zerbrochene Mückenspirale. In jedem meiner Atemzüge mischte sich das Zirpen der Zikaten. Wie viele mochten es sein und wie weit reichte das Zirpen der Zikate? Überall lagen ihre leeren Hüllen auf der Erde, doch nirgendwo sah ich ein totes Tier. Wie konnte es sein, dass bei so vielen Zikaten, die ein derart kurzes Leben hatten, der Boden nicht mit ihren Leichen bedeckt war? Plötzlich sprang eine große braune Heuschrecke, so groß wie meine Handfläche, aus dem Gebüsch am Deich. Zitternd schloss sie ihre Flügel und bewegte sich ein Stück auf mich zu. Sie stand da, kam ein paar Schritte näher, drehte sich um, breitete plötzlich die Flügel aus und flog davon. Ich sah ihr nach und in dem Moment entdeckte ich das schwarze Tier. Es lief den Weg entlang. Dieses Tier ist nämlich kurz vorher schon ihr einmal begegnet. Ich dachte schon, ich hätte es mit der Hitze eingebildet und sah noch einmal hin. Aber da war zweifellos dieses Lebewesen ohne Frage ein Säugetier mit Hinterbein. Es war so groß wie ein mittelgroßer Hund oder vielleicht größer. Die Schultern waren breit, während die Beine an den Oberschenkeln noch recht stramm, nach unten hin dünner wurden und unterhalb der Knie eher Stöcken ähnelten. Der Schwanz war lang und geschwungen, die kaum sichtbaren Ohren rund. Ich erarrte die Ritten, doch der runde, robuste Rücken schien über seine ordentliche Schicht Fett und Muskeln zu verfügen. Es hatte pechschwarzes und borstiges Fell und warf, da die Sonne im Zenit stand, so gut wie keinen Schatten. Und mit diesem fast schattenlosen Körper trottete es in kleinen Schritten zügig voran. Es ähnelte weder einem Hund noch einer Katze, auch nicht einem Wiesel, Tanuki oder Wildschwein. Es war das einzige Tier auf dem Weg. Was ist denn das für ein merkwürdiges Tier?
Grüffelow.
Hier wird die Welt surreal. Hier kann man in ein Loch fallen. Und das ist immer symbolisch, hochsymbolisch aufgeladen. Denn hier fällt jemand in ein Loch aus dem sozialen Gefüge, in dem man vorher unterwegs war, heraus. Ist jetzt dort in einer Welt, die von sehr vielen Alten bevölkert ist, mit einer eigenartigen Kommunikationsstruktur. Es gibt eine Nachbarin, die ein paar eigenartige Fragen stellt. Aber eigentlich weiß sie auch so recht nicht über ihren Mann Bescheid. Und welch ein fremdetes Leben führt man, beziehungsweise in welch ein fremdetes Leben ist man da plötzlich hineingeschlittert. Und das schafft die Autorin, mit diesen kräftigen, surrealen Bildern zu zeichnen. Und das ist etwas, was ich sehr zur Lektüre empfehlen kann.
Sehr gut. Japan, immer gern gesehenes Thema. Ich habe ja kürzlich auch mit Hörer, das finde ich seinen Namen leider nicht, der in Japan, ah, Max, war ja hier und hat ja wirklich seltsames berichtet. Also ich glaube, Soziales Surrealismus ist doch Alltag. Zur Diskussion gestellt, steht über diesem Papier des Bundesjugendkuratoriums Generationengerechtigkeit, die Rechte junger Menschen in der alternden Gesellschaft stärken. Ist natürlich im doppelten Sinne mein Thema. Alt und neues Buch. Autorenschaft ist dieses Gremium aus unterschiedlichen Autoren. Ich nenne mal nur Aladin El-Mafalani. Die haben also sich hier eine vierseitige Bekanntmachung gemacht. Demografische Wandel ist seit den 1970er Jahren bekannt. Wirft also die politische Frage auf, wie man die Beteiligung der jüngeren Generation in der Bundesrepublik strukturell absichern kann. Das Bundesverfassungsgericht kriegt man strukturell abgesichert. Bei der Jugend ist es schon ein bisschen komplizierter. Aber es gibt eine unangemessene politische Gewichtung derzeit auf, sie nennen hier, drei Politikfelder. Nummer eins, generationale Schieflage der Demokratie. Die Hälfte der Wählerschaft ist heute 53 Jahre und älter. Der Anteil der unter 30-Jährigen 14 Prozent. Also Argumentationen, die wir kennen. Wir haben also eine altersbezogene Schieflage im Hinblick auf demokratische Gewichtung der Generation. Läuft bei mir unter dem Satz, die Demokratie setzt die Demokratie Schachmatt. Wird hier auch so gesehen, die größte Wählergruppe ist systematisch nicht mehr im Erwerbsleben beteiligt. Wenn wir uns also fragen, was ist mit den Bildungseinrichtungen und so? Ne, schon die ganze Arbeitswelt ist davon bedroht, quasi, dass bei politischen Wahlkämpfen und die werden nun mal von den Wählern initiiert, im Sinne von ihnen wird das Angebot gemacht. Da ist selbst das Erwerbsleben schon jenseits der eigenen Lebenswelt. Solche Fragen nach knapper Ressourcenverteilung, Risikobereitschaft, Zugangs-, Zukunftsorientierung, Nachhaltigkeit, Dynamik, also da sieht es schlecht aus. Es gibt eine Diskrepanz zwischen dem abnehmenden Gewicht, quantitativ, der jungen Wählergruppe und ihrer zunehmenden Bedeutung. Ich bin natürlich gespannt, das wird natürlich fortlaufend erarbeitet. Gerade Malavallani macht ja selber auch ein Buch über Kindheit in Deutschland. Die zunehmende Bedeutung, also hier steht nur dieser eine Satz, aber ich finde es schon witzig, dass umso kleiner die Gruppe wird, umso wichtiger ist die Bedeutung jedes Einzelnen. Also da steckt so ein kleiner heimlicher Humor von Gott drin. Problemfeld Nummer zwei, generationale Schieflagen im Sozialstaat. Öffentliche Finanzen, wir diskutieren ja eh häufig darüber, haben heute immer höhere Sozialausgaben für Rente, Gesundheit und Pflege auf der einen Seite, Fachkräftemangel im Gesundheits- und Pflegesystem und dann Infrastruktur der Bildung für Kinder und Jugendliche. Hier haben wir einen hochgradigen Investitionsbedarf, das sagt natürlich die andere Seite auch, die alten Leute brauchen wir das auch, aber die Jungen auch. Das Bildungs- und Berufsbildungssystem ist in einem nicht akzeptablen Zustand. Sehr stark ersetzt. Für ein Gremium, das direkt der Bundesregierung reportiert. Seit mehr als zehn Jahren zeigen alle relevanten Studien einen Abwärtstrend im Hinblick auf die Kompetenzentwicklung, und zwar auf jeder Ebene des Schulsystems und in allen Bundesländern. Es gibt großen Zweifel, ob die flächendeckte Umsetzung des ab 2026 gewährten bundesweiten Rechtsanspruchs auf Ganztagsförderung eigentlich zufriedenstellend gelingen wird. Also Deutschland hat durchaus formale Entscheidungen getroffen, von denen ich ja auch zuletzt sagte, das ist halt Sozialstaat. Wir brauchen Familienpersonal und ich denke auch, das wird es so nicht geben. Wir haben Austeritätspolitik und Konsolidierungen, also Sparungen im Haushalt, um Balancen herzustellen, was eben jetzt bedeutet, wir haben Kinderarmut, Altersarmut und Erwerbstätige, die sich um diese Kinder und um diese Alten kümmern in der Lebenswelt, während die Politik mit nicht vorhandenen Programmen und dann auch im Abseits irgendwo abgeschottet bei bewirteten Terminen im Bundestag mit eigener Polizei darüber redet, dass man da nichts tut. Problemfeld Nummer 3, Aufwachsen in Widersprüchen. Das finde ich ein sehr gutes Kapitel. Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie da der ausführliche Text dann, wenn später was kommt, aussehen wird. Denn die junge Generation, sagen sie, rutscht immer häufiger in eine Zuschauerrolle. Schon allein, weil sie nicht wählen darf, steht hier nicht drin, aber ich will es kurz anwenden. Sind also da insbesondere als Objekt der Politik und nicht als Subjekt zu sehen. Jüngere Generation kommt immer wieder in diese Zuschauerrolle, wird immer häufiger darauf zurückgeworfen, während sie von den aktuellen Krisen und Entscheidungen am stärksten betroffen sein werden, steht hier. Ein Recht auf Zukunft, wie zuletzt mehrfach vom Bundesverfassungsgericht, zugebilligt. Was bedeutet das eigentlich konkret? Fragen Sie. Gleichzeitig werden junge Menschen weiterhin vielfach aus einer Risikoperspektive betrachtet und nicht mit Blick auf ihre Bedeutung für die Gestaltung der zukünftigen Gesellschaft. Finde ich auch gut. Gerade auch, weil es einen großen antinatalistischen Bewegungsapparat gerade gibt, der einen ja wirklich das Kind, Kinderkrieg ausstreibt wegen Klimabelastung und so weiter. Also ist ja auch alles nicht gering zu schätzen. Sozialpolitisch werden vor allem Pflichten der jüngeren Generation formuliert. Ich sage immer nur Wehrpflicht und so. Kaum Rechte. Die jüngere Generation ist heute klein. Das ist der eine demografische Faktor, der hier rauszuheben ist. Aber sie ist auch sehr viel heterogener. Also wenn Politik, Politik macht nicht nur für nicht die jungen Politik, sondern auch im nicht passenden Modus, muss man dann sagen. Also es ist eine sehr gute kleine Beobachtung. Soweit über Infrastrukturen in Deutschland diskutiert wird, wird prominent pointiert formuliert, mehr über die Löcher in Straßen- und Autobahnbrücken gesprochen als über die Löcher in der Bildungs- und sozialen Infrastruktur der jungen Generation. Minderheitenschutz, insbesondere Altersdiskriminierung, wird heute hauptsächlich auf ältere Menschen bezogen. Aber es gibt ja auch eine Altersdiskriminierung der Jüngeren. Und in der Hinsicht ist das ein sehr guter kleiner Aufschlag. Das waren schon diese vier Seiten. Wir haben Forderungen nach Kinderrechten im Grundgesetz, Rechtsansprüche auf Betreuungen, Urteile des Bundesverfassungsgerichts, Recht auf Bildung, Klimaschutzgesetz, Recht auf Freiheit. Nichts davon schlägt sich irgendwo nieder. Eine Rückbesinnung auf die zentrale Idee des gesellschaftlichen Generationen-Vertrags erscheint zwingend erforderlich, schreiben sie. Da würde ich jetzt sagen, schade. Also der Generationenvertrag ist nun wirklich, weiß nicht, wir haben halt einen bei der Rente. Aber ansonsten, so Generationen- und Gesellschaftsverträge sind für mich immer eine Semantik, die so ein bisschen ins appellative Plädoyer und präampelhafte abdriften, aber nicht jetzt in programmatische Politik. Na wie auch immer. Also dieses Bundesjugendkuratorium ist eine von der Bundesregierung eingesetzte Sachverständigengremium, steht hier noch. Es berät die Bundesregierung in grundsätzlichen Fragen der Kinder- und Jugendhilfe. Bin mal gespannt.
Die Erkenntnisse sind ja jetzt dann alle da.
Ja, so. Ja genau, es fehlt halt jemand, der Druck macht. Und Mal Lafani macht ja nun publizistisch sehr guten Druck. Er hat ja das Ding auch bei Beisenerts im Podcast vorgestellt, berät hier direkt die Bundesregierung. Also es sind ja auch Texte an die, die da nicht einfach vorüber gehen können, aber wir wissen selber, wie es läuft. Na mal sehen.
Opfer Nationalismus, Erinnerung und Herrschaft in der postkolonialen Welt heißt das Buch von Ji-Hyeon Lim, er ist Historiker und er stammt aus Korea und hat sich mit den Erinnerungskulturen in Korea und Polen zunächst beschäftigt und ihm sind da Parallelen aufgefallen und dachte, ach ja, da stilisieren sich manche zu Opfern, die gar keine waren oder leugnen die Opferschaft anderer.
Wir schulden dir noch 1 Billion Euro, hast du nicht gehört?
Das ist ja wie bei uns zu Hause. Er hat also gesehen, da passiert etwas in zwei Ländern, die erstmal ja gar nichts miteinander zu tun haben. Also hat er auch seinen Blick erweitert und fragt sich, was ist da eigentlich los und er sagt, es entsteht ein neuer Opfer-Nationalismus. Er sagt Folgendes dazu. Inspiriert von Sigmund Baumann und seinem Konzept des ererbten Opferstatus, entwickle ich die These vom Opfer-Nationalismus, um die verflochten Erinnerungen an Krieg und Genozid in Polen, Deutschland, Israel, Japan und Korea begrifflich zu fassen. Ich verstehe den Opfer-Nationalismus als eine Erzähl-Schablone, die Nationen mit ererbtem Opferstatus, der eine Gruppe in der Gegenwart und die Opfer einer Vorfahrens-Generationen-Postum aneinander bindet, moralische Gerechtigkeit verschaffen und zu historischer Legitimation verhelfen kann. Indem sie das Vermächtnis der Opferschaft der Vorfahren weiterführt, erscheint die Nation mit ererbtem Opferstatus als moralisch rein. Im Zuge der Globalisierung der Erinnerung und in der Entstehung von globaler Empathie mit Opfergruppen hat sich der Schwerpunkt in nationalistischen Erinnerungsdiskursen verschoben. Vom Heldentum verlagerte er sich zum Opferstatus.
Ich glaube, das ist wirklich wahnsinnig interessant.
Was wir alle sofort so intuitiv bestätigen könnten.
Ich war vor zehn Jahren bei einem Parteitag einer Partei in Berlin, die hieß die Freiheit. Und die hat so ein bisschen... Wie lange ist das her? Das ist sehr lange her. 2011 war das. Da wurde die AfD noch gar nicht gegründet. Das war kurz vor der AfD. Und da stand ein Parteichef auf der Bühne, der nicht Strongman war, sondern der sozusagen ich fühle mit euch, ich bin ein Opfer wie ihr. Wir können das Sammelbecken der Opfer sein. Und ich habe das damals auch so beschrieben und fand das sehr skurril. Das ist eben nicht über diese Strongman-Schiene, sondern wir sind hier einfach mal mutig mit Opfer. Es war halt das Schicksal, das über uns hereingebrochen ist. Aber wir stellen das jetzt heraus.
Ja, jeder möchte Opfer sein und generiert daraus einen neuen Nationalismus. Das heißt, manche sind Opfer geworden, wenngleich jetzt Lim sehr genau hinschaut, von welchen Opfern sprechen wir da eigentlich und wo waren doch die, die sich als reine Opfer sehen, auch Kollaborateure. Er zeigt es dann sehr gut an zum Beispiel den Diskurs von polnischen Rechten, die sich natürlich als absolute Opfer darstellen wollen, dann aber zum Beispiel ausgeblendet wird, wie sie mit schuldig wurden an den Verbrechen an den Juden. Wenn man über den Postkolonialismus spricht, dann ist der Holocaust nicht weit und das ist natürlich eine ganz problematische Debatte. Vielleicht ist es deshalb so interessant, dieses Buch zu lesen, weil es so eine Außenperspektive ist. Denn wir kennen natürlich diese ganzen Diskurse, inwieweit der Holocaust vergleichbar ist. Im Zuge des Historikerstreits, wenn Ernst Neute da die Singularität des Holocaust infrage stellte und sagte, das sei ja auch eigentlich eine Antwort gewesen auf stalinistische Verbrechen oder es ist nur die andere Seite dessen. Das ist etwas, was Ji Heon-lim ablehnt. Was er aber sagt, ist, dass sich etwas Interessantes verschoben hat. Also wir haben zum einen die rechten Historiker beim Historikerstreit, die den Holocaust quasi relativieren. Heute sehen wir das umgekehrt, dass Linken, die dem postkolonialistischen Denken angehören, bereit sind, nicht den Holocaust gleich zu relativieren, aber doch eine Vergleichbarkeit herstellen. Und der fragt sich, inwieweit kann man das eigentlich machen und worum geht es dann jeweils? Und da versucht er, Trendschaft zu unterscheiden. Also versucht jemand, einen Vergleich mit dem Holocaust anzustreben, um sich zu entschulden? Oder geht es wirklich um eine Verhältnissetzung, deshalb, um daraus eine Handlung abzuleiten, dass man sagt, so etwas Ähnliches darf nicht noch mal passieren. Er sagt, die historische Singularität des Holocaust ist jedoch nicht gleichzusetzen mit einer Unvergleichbarkeit. Also die Singularität ist da aber, es heißt nicht Unvergleichbarkeit. Statt Vergleichbarkeit auszuschließen, ermutigen historische Singularitäten zum Vergleich. Das Tabu der Unvergleichbarkeit des Holocaust zu brechen, ist eng mit dem Bestreben verbunden, die nationale Erinnerungskultur in Deutschland zu entprovinzialisieren. Aus der Perspektive der globalen Erinnerungsformation offenbart, der Membembestreit in den Völtons, fand er vor ein paar Jahren statt, den postkolonialen Nexus der Holocaust-Erinnerung, der die Einzigartigkeit und Unvergleichbarkeit des Holocaust als Markstein des kritischen Gedenkens in Deutschland nach 1968 überschreitet. Und da ist jetzt die Frage, wie reagiert man darauf? Also seine Idee ist also eine, dass er sagt, die alleinige nationale Verantwortung Deutschlands für den Holocaust hat wie eine Deckerinnerung gewirkt, auch dann für viele außerhalb, um auch eine nicht-deutsche Mittäterschaft wiederum zu verschleiern. Also zum Beispiel die, die beim Vichy-Regime mitgetan haben, konnten danach sagen, also das ist nicht unsere Angelegenheit gewesen. Also wir sehen, dass also diese Konzentration darauf natürlich auch eine Entschuldigung wieder für andere darstellen kann. Ist es so, dass er schreibt, wenn man den Holocaust als eine ethische Schablone heranzieht, um über andere Genozide und Verbrechen weltweit nachzudenken, erscheint er nicht mehr nur als eine ausschließlich deutsch-jüdische Erfahrung. Vielmehr wird er zum Ausgangspunkt für eine transnationale Ziviltugend in der globalen Erinnerungsforschung. Ich verwende in diesem Buch daher die Begriffe kritische Relativierung und radikale Gegenüberstellung als konzeptuelle Wertzeuge, mit denen sich sowohl das relativierende Abwälzen von deutscher Verantwortung als auch die schematische Annahme kritisch hinterfragen lassen. Der Holocaust sei mit dem Kolonialgenozid des Westens nicht zu vergleichen. Er bezieht sich da zum Teil auf Arendt, sagt auch, man müsste eigentlich schon so sagen, ironisch betrachtet wüsste man heute nicht, ob Hannah Arendt überhaupt noch den Hannah Arendt-Preis gewinnen könnte. Aber ich glaube, also dieses Buch umdreht, ich will ein paar Punkte gleich noch bringen, um auch da herauszustellen, was gut ist. Was grundsätzlich an dem Buch zu bemängeln ist, ist, dass wir keine Aussage eigentlich bekommen, inwieweit Antisemitismus sich von Rassismus unterscheidet. Und das ist auch etwas, was ich vielen postkolonialen Theoretikern vorwerfe, dass sie das immer so in eins denken. Dass aber Antisemitismus noch mal in anderer Weise funktioniert und auch noch mal in anderen Gesellschaftsschichten sich wahnbrechen kann, nämlich z.B. in sehr, sehr intellektuellen Geschichten, ist etwas, was hier nicht thematisiert wird. Ich glaube, dass diese Engschaltung, die oft stattfindet, Rassismus, Antisemitismus oder dass man den Antisemitismus am Ende nur als eine Form von Rassismus auffasst, das ist etwas, womit ich nicht nur große Probleme habe, sondern ich glaube, das versperrt sehr viel an Denken. Wir müssen ja die Singularität des Holocaust allerdings, und da finde ich es schon wieder interessant, das Buch daran festmachen, dass der Holocaust von so vielen herangezogen wird, für einen Vergleich. Das heißt, das zeigt ja, dass man sich nicht eines anderen Verbrechens bedient, der Menschheit, sondern dass man sich damit auseinandersetzt. Mit dem Holocaust will man sich dazu in ein Verhältnis setzen. Wie ist das jetzt, und das ist vielleicht das Interessanteste, mit diesem neuen Nationalismus. Er sagt, wenn Schuldige nicht wegen ihrer individuellen Verfehlungen verurteilt werden, sondern wegen ihrer ethnonationalen Identität, bilden sich stabile nationale Erinnerungskollektive von Opfern wie auch von Tättern heraus. Die besonders starken Bindungen, die in Erinnerungskollektiven über die Opferschaft entstehen, gehen einher mit einem Alleinanspruch auf den Prozess der Vergangenheitsaufarbeitung. Eine Folge davon ist, dass bestimmte Dimensionen dieser Vergangenheit verdrängt werden. Die Priorisierung des Opferstatus im Erinnerungsraum erleichtert und rechtfertigt somit den Nationalismus von Nationen, die sich als Opfer verstehen. Heutzutage konkurrieren Nationalstaaten darum, sich in der Rolle als Opfer von Aggressornationen zu etablieren. Meine These vom Opfernationalismus erklärt diesen Wettbewerb als neuartiges Phänomen eines regenerierten Nationalismus im Zeitalter des globalisierten Erinnerns. Ohne eine transnationale Reflexion über den Opfernationalismus lassen sich die Prozesse der Vergangenheitsaufarbeitung nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg nicht begreifen. Und ich glaube, das ist etwas, was wir sehr viel sehen, dass wir so ein transnationales Erinnern haben, also dass immer Bezüge gemacht werden. Die Welt ist da wirklich das Dorf geworden, das Marshall McLuhan gesehen hat. Aber das bedeutet zugleich, dass wir nicht zusammenwachsen als Menschheit, sondern man hat also verschiedene Verbrechen der Menschheit, versucht dort in eine Hierarchisierung einzutreten, versucht sich zu der Singularität des Holocaustenverhältnisses zu setzen, umbaut dann auf diese verschiedenen Erinnerungslinien, die man dort ausmachen kann, einen neuen Nationalismus auf, der dann ja einer ist, der von aller Täterschaft befreit sein kann, weil man ja aus dem Opfersein heraus diese Nationalität bildet. Und wir haben das ja jetzt auch zum Beispiel ganz schön gesehen, als Ronzheimer sagt, ja, können Sie ja nicht verstehen, dass die Ukrainer da nicht so nahe mit Russland und auch die anderen Länder. Und dann sagt er, ja, was erzählen Sie mir von Russland? Wir waren mehrmals okkupiert. Keiner weiß besser, wie es ist, unter russischer Herrschaft zu leben, als wir Ukrainer, äh, als wir Ungarn. Das heißt, auch er ist natürlich in einem Opfer-Narrativ oder sieht sich als Opfer von Brüssel an. Das ist also etwas, was weit, weit verbreitet ist. Und das mal klarzumachen und aufzudecken, finde ich sehr gut. Und ich finde auch interessant, dass er sich verschiedene Diskurse anseht. Also zum Beispiel, wie geht Japan mit Hiroshima um? Also man hat zum Beispiel auch da zum Beispiel ist man dazu übergegangen, sich plötzlich als reines Opfer zu sehen, was den ganzen zweiten Weltkrieg anbelangt. Also man versucht dann daraus, so einen Nationalismus abzuweiten. Und selbst noch auch gute pazifistische Bewegungen, die sagten, also nie mehr Japan bewaffnen, haben natürlich die Atombombe gern als so einen Ausweis davon genommen, dass am Ende sie Opfer waren. Und das ist also interessant, wie kollektive Identitäten sich da bilden. Oder wir haben das ja auch im Diskurs zwischen Österreich und Deutschland, dass rechte Historiker sagen, Österreich war das erste Opfer Hitlers. Also nicht Polen oder so, sondern es ist Österreich. Dann ist ganz bemerkenswert, dass er zeigt, dass es so eine Überkontextualisierung gibt. Da sagt er folgendes zu. Mit den ihm eigenen Prozessen der Überkontextualisierung und der Dekontextualisierung erweist sich der Opfernationalismus als ahistorisch. Wenn der Mechanismus der Überkontextualisierung, der mit dem historischen Kontextualismus verbunden ist, zu historischer Gleichförmigkeit im Bezug auf alle möglichen Geschehnisse der Vergangenheit führt, dann mündet die Dekontextualisierung in eine ahistorische Rechtfertigung geschichtlicher Konsequenzen. Japanische Vertriebene wurden zu Opfern von Koreanern und nach der Kriegsniederlage litten deutsche Vertriebene unter den Vergeltungsmaßnahmen von Polen und Tschechen. Doch japanische und deutsche Vertriebene waren schwerlich unschuldig an den Gräuel des Kolonialismus und des Nationalsozialismus. Durch die einseitige Hervorhebung des Opferstatus wird das dekontextualisierende Moment, das im japanischen und deutschen Opfernationalismus wirksam ist, zum Auslöser wütender Reaktionen auf der jeweiligen Gegenseite, die vor und während des Krieges viktimisiert wurde. Die deutsche und japanische Dekontextualisierung wird daraufhin mit einer Überkontextualisierung erwidert, die die von der Gegenseite verübte Gewalt gegen vertriebene japanische bzw. deutsche Zivilisten zu rechtfertigen scheint. So bleibt am Ende nur der Kampf sich gegenüberstehender Opfernationalismen, ungleicher Opfer, um die Rolle des wahren Opfers. Das ist also der Streit, der ausgefochten wird dann. Und dass das den Diskurs nicht glüger macht und im Ganzen nicht weiterbringt, kann man sich in etwa denken. Ich finde, dass diese Diagnose des Opfernationalismus, woher er rührt und wie er funktioniert und wie er politisch eingesetzt wird, hochinteressant. Es gibt dann weiter diese Idee von, wie kann man über Holocaust und Kolonialismus reflektieren. Da geht es darum, dass der Holocaust auch zu einem globalen Erinnerungsmuster wird. Also man kann sagen, alle Erinnerungskulturen, die sich mit Genoziden auseinandersetzen, orientieren sich in irgendeiner Weise am Holocaust. Es soll nicht immer eine Gleichsetzung oder ein Vergleich sein, aber das ist so ein Ausgangspunkt, von dem das stattfindet, beobachtet er. Und er sagt aber auch, es gibt dann so eine Problematik bei dieser Kosmopolitisierung des Holocaust. Wenn ich das noch vortragen darf, er sagt da, die Kosmopolitisierung des Holocaust wurde häufig nur durch anachronistische und oberflächliche Vergleiche möglich. Eine mechanistisch verstandene symmetrische Reziprozität in der Erinnerungsformation kann dabei eine allzu vereinfachte Sicht der Welt vermitteln. Im absurden Extremfall wurde gar die Entjudaisierung des Holocaust notwendig, um die Erinnerung an den Holocaust weltweit lebendig zu halten. Der Schritt von der Kosmopolitisierung zur Bulgarisierung der Holocaust-Erinnerung ist deutlich kürzer, als man sich hätte vorstellen können. Die Allgegenwart des Holocaust als Erinnerungsvorlage besteht jedoch nicht nur auf Synchronas und auch auf Diakrona-Ebene. Was er jetzt hier beschreibt, ist, wie zum Beispiel Nelson Mandela sich auf Anne Frank bezieht. Wie aber auch…
Wie hat er das denn gemacht? Im Sinne von eingesperrt, biografisch zurückgehalten.
Ja, also es ist folgender Maßen…
So viele Ideen noch…
Auch in Südafrika unter der Apartheid gab es ähnliche Verbindungen zwischen Schwarzen und Juden. Viele bekannte Anti-Apartheid-Aktivisten schätzten das Tagebuch der Anne Frank. Im berüchtigten Apartheid-Gefängnis auf Robben Island wurden handgeschriebene Kopien des Buchs herumgereicht. In einer seiner öffentlichen Reden als Präsident des demokratischen Südafrika erinnert sich Nelson Mandela, wie das Buch seine Zuversicht gestützt und seine Überzeugung bestärkt hatte, dass sich der Kampf für Freiheit und Gerechtigkeit nicht unterdrücken lässt. Also ganz interessant, wie so eine Aneignung da stattfindet.
Das ist vor allem handschriftlich zu duplizieren.
Es gibt aber dann sehr viel Holocaust-Instrumentalisierung für einen Opfer-Nationalismus, kann man sich vorstellen. Er beschäftigt sich ja vor allem mit Deutschland und mit Polen und Korea und Japan. Ich hätte das schon auch nochmal gerne gehabt, dass man nochmal untersucht, wie denn eigentlich diese postkolonialen Theoretiker so drauf sind, weil die ja doch, würde ich sagen, auch bei allem Vergleichen, das ich jetzt nicht grundsätzlich ablehne, mitunter aber blind werden ja für eigene Verfehlung oder autoritäre Regime dann plötzlich nicht mehr so schlimm finden oder so, wenn es dann die Sache ist oder so. Also ich glaube, dass man eigentlich doch fragen müsste, findet nicht nur so eine Relativierung des Holocausts durch manche Vergleiche statt, sondern ist das nicht auch eine Möglichkeit für sehr viele postkoloniale Theorien geworden, jetzt das auch so in Anschlag zu bringen, dass man jetzt sagt, ja jetzt müssen wir, wir sind so sehr Opfer, dass auch über andere Dinge jetzt nicht gerade gesprochen werden braucht. Und das ist etwas, was so ein bisschen da fehlt bei diesem Buch. Das heißt, ich finde schon es interessant, diesen Bezug zwischen Holocaust und Kolonialismus aufzumachen. Aber wo er dann in so eine Richtung geht, wo er sagt, ja natürlich haben die Nazis ein koloniales Projekt verfolgt, in dem sie den Osten besiedeln wollten und in dem sie dort Lebensraum schaffen wollten. Das war ja Edlers Idee auch von Wirtschaftspolitik. Und das ist das eine, das ist das Kolonialistische am Nationalsozialismus. Und das geht auch dann einher mit einer eliminatorischen Ausrottung der Juden. Nur ist nicht damit gleichzeitig der eliminatorische Antisemitismus mit Kolonialismus zu verquicken, sondern es wurde ja bei dem Umgang mit den Juden tatsächlich eine Ausrottung der Juden betrieben, während wir bei einer kolonialistischen Beherrschung zwar auch Unterdrückung und auch Morde und all das erleben, aber es geht nicht darum, eine völlige Ausrottung herzustellen. Und das ist ja auch ein Unterschied zum Beispiel zur Sklaverei, die anders funktioniert, als ein Holocaust funktioniert. Und ich glaube, diese Differenzen könnte man klarer bringen, wenn man erstmal den nationalsozialistischen eliminatorischen Antisemitismus klarer definiert und vom Kolonialismus abgrenzt und wenn man an sich auch den Antisemitismus noch mal vom Kolonialismus abtrennt. Nicht um zu sagen, das hat alles nie irgendwas miteinander zu tun. Natürlich gibt es da Linien. Und aus diesen Linien kann ja auch wieder dann eine Verantwortung oder so etwas erwachsen. Aber der Holocaust ist ja kein Kolonialismus. Sondern es ist etwas Singuläres. Und das sagt er ja auch dann. Und deswegen, glaube ich, ist dieses Buch irgendwie heilsam zu sehen. Oder was heißt heilsam? Aber es ist doch zu sehen, dass man mal eine andere Perspektive auf das Ganze einnehmen kann. Und muss nicht immer nur in diesen urdeutschen Debatten sein, wo auch eigentlich nur die 80er Jahre aufleben in verwandelter Form. Sondern man kann den globaleren Blick einnehmen. Ich würde nur dann auch sagen, müsste man es ein bisschen radikaler noch tun, indem man auch mal da einige Leute, das muss nicht mehr ein Member sein, vielleicht andere, durch ist bereit ist, stärker zu dekonstruieren, dass man da auch nicht sagt, wir müssen die ein bisschen zu sehr beschützen. Insofern aber ein Buch, das man sicherlich inspirativ lesen kann. Ich finde eigentlich diese Überlegung zu Opfernationalismus, um wie dieser entsteht, viel interessanter, bringt uns auch geopolitisch, glaube ich, weiter als die hundertste Erklärung über, wie weit das Verhältnis zu beurteilen ist von Holocaust und anderen Genoziden. Ich glaube, dass also dieser erste Teil des Buchs lesenswerter ist.
Ja, interessant, sich da so ranzutrauen. Denn man kann ja immer schon beim Titel dann anfangen, sich die Unterscheidung aufzumachen. Also Opfernationalismus. Gibt es auch einen Täter-Nationalismus? Ja, neu aufflammend wieder. Also stolz darauf zu sein, was man schon mal erhoben hat. Und der Rest war ja nur Fliegenschiss auf der Geschichte oder Vogelschiss. Aber eigentlich kleben wir ja das Opfer als Zuschreibung an diejenigen, die eben gerade keine Nation haben. Sind die in Roma? Kriegen die Juden wieder einen Staat? Weil ja auch genau diese Frage, über die sich die Schicksalshaftigkeit dreht. Also haben wir es eigentlich mit bisher Täter-Nationalismus zu tun. Oder Täter-Nationen und Opfer ohne Nation, sagen wir es mal so. Und dass dann eine Identifikation über die ehemalige Opferrolle, man leidet ja nicht mehr konkret, sind die eigenen Eltern oder so, die gelitten haben. Ich hätte jetzt gedacht in dem Buch, dass er das noch so ein bisschen austreibt. Also, dass die vierte Generation der Nachkriegszeit diese Billionenforderung an Deutschland in Polen so formuliert, fand ich überraschend, weil Tusk sie ja in der neuen Regierung auch nicht wirklich austreiben konnte. Also, das Thema ist ja immer noch geblieben. Dann auch diese Fragen mit dem Holocaust. Also, an den Holocaust soll gedacht werden. Aber jedes Mal, wenn jemand an ihn denkt, wird genau darauf geachtet, ob man auch richtig an ihn denkt. Da steckt ja auch ein Paradox drin. Denn wir wollen ja nicht, dass er vergessen wird. Aber wir wollen auch immer singulär. Und jetzt sagst du, da steht drin, relativ häufig wird er als Folie behandelt. Ja, natürlich. Es ist dann ganz wichtig, zwischen Vergleich und Gleichnis zu unterscheiden. Das andere wäre ja verschweigen. Also, dass man da einen Maßstab anlegt, ist ja schon irgendwie da. Dass man das mit dem Kolonialismus, finde ich gut. Als ich es so sagte, dachte ich, okay, Kolonialismus ist noch mal wie Holocaust, aber mit Sachgründen, statt nur Ideologie. Man will das Land, man will die Ressourcen.
Und sicherlich auch die Art der Gewalt ist eine andere. Und auch die Organisation dieser Gewalt. Und auch diese Vernichtung von Menschen, die man als Gruppe definiert hat. Und ich würde sagen, dass es bei dem Kolonialismus ja um eine Erweiterung der Wirtschaft geht. Und das ist auch das Projekt Ost von Hitler. Das aber der Holocaust an sich, also Ausschwitz und all das. Nochmal davon... Es hat damit zu tun, aber man muss es auch nochmal davon separieren. Und das kann man aber nur, wenn man auch nochmal eine Unterscheidung macht zwischen dem Antisemitismus und einem Rassismus, der wiederum dienstbar gemacht wird, um wirtschaftlich prosperieren zu können oder so. Und diese Differenzen muss man bereit sein zu machen. Und das fand ich ja auch gerade bei den Dokumenten, dass man gesehen hat, dass man nicht bereit war, diese zu machen. Was ich wirklich sehr gut finde, ist diese Beobachtung des Opfernationalismus. Denn wir können es ja auch sehen, jetzt besonders auf Twitter, da haben wir ja viele Osteuropahistoriker, die ganz stark diese opfernationalistischen Narrative jeweils hegen und pflegen, um zu begründen, warum man jetzt aber auf keinen Fall nachgeben darf in Bezug auf Putin oder so. Oder auch jetzt dann soweit gehen zu sagen, es geschieht ja auch eine eigenartige Geschichtsumschreibung. Das haben wir jetzt auch doch erlebt. Ich meine, Deutschland wurde von den Alliierten befreit, zu den Alliierten gehörten die Sowjets. Das ist aber jetzt in der Erinnerung seit Beginn des Krieges in der Ukraine immer mehr verschüttet gegangen. Also man muss ja jetzt dafür nicht Putin einladen und den feiern. Aber mitunter hatte man den Eindruck, dass irgendwie die Sowjets gar nicht mehr an der Sache beteiligt waren oder so. Oder manchmal hat man den Eindruck gehabt, ach so, es ging eigentlich darum, die Sowjets zu bekämpfen oder was. Also da hat sich schon sehr Merkwürdiges verschoben. Und da kommt man vielleicht mit so einem Begriff Opfer Nationalismus weiter.
Zurück in die Gegenwart, in die ganze Gegenwärtigkeit. Wir nehmen es natürlich heute ausnahmsweise mal so fünf, sechs Tage aus, bevor wir es dann aussenden. Was bedeutet, es ist dann schon wieder Zeit ins Land gegangen zwischen dem, was ich jetzt vorstelle und dem, was wir dann sehen. Aber die Fragestellungen, die hier so drinstehen, sind dann doch unsere Fragen. Also ist es richtig, dass sich die Demokraten um Kamala Harris scharen? Fragt Ezra Klein in einer Audio-Version. Wir haben im Ausschnitt gehört im letzten Podcast und wollen hier nochmal auf den Gedankengang eingehen. Die Republikaner hatten also einen Parteitag, der, wie wir gehört haben, ein Megagottesdienst in einem Casino in Las Vegas unter dem stets wachsamen Blick eines lebendigen Gottes war. So, das ist die eine Seite. Diese Partei hat sich eingeredet, dass der Ehrgeiz eines Mannes, seine unersättliche, unstillbare Gier nach Macht, selbst auf Opferung ist. Für ein Staat angeblich. Ein Führer in göttlicher Mission, auserwählt und beschützt von einem allmächtigen Gott. So, diese Botschaft der Republikaner 2024 ist also, Trump steht an erster Stelle. President Biden ist daraufhin zurückgetreten, ein paar Tage später. Und jetzt schreibt Ezra Klein, so sieht es aus, wenn das Land wirklich an erster Stelle steht. Und wir markieren nochmal, gerade weil es da auch Widerworte von Adam Two's gab und so weiter, würde ich auch sagen. Am Sonntag also stellte Biden einen wieder einen Gegensatz her zwischen ihm und Trump. Trump würde nicht mal nach einer Wahlniederlage darauf verzichten, Kandidat und dann Präsident zu sein. Biden macht das sogar vor der Wahl und verzichtet. So sieht es also aus, wenn man Amerika an die erste Stelle tritt. Es ist nicht der republikanische Personenkult, sondern die Demokraten haben gezeigt, dass sie eine politische Partei sind und kein Personenkult. Dann hat Ezra Klein ja diese Entscheidung aufgemacht oder diese Unterscheidung angeboten. Wir könnten ja einen offenen Parteitag machen, also gar keine Vorwahlen landesweit, sondern alles mit den Delegierten vor Ort klären. Oder eine Krönung. Dafür braucht man natürlich, also fürs erstere Personal. Was den Demokraten bis hierhin gefehlt hat, war ja Informationen über ihren Kandidaten. Relativ spät haben sie dann, aber immer noch rechtzeitig in der Debatte gesehen, ach so alt ist der. Und jetzt ist die Frage, wie kann man das eigentlich wieder vermeiden? Dass man wieder einfach Kamala Harris ausruft und dann so drei Wochen vor der Wahl feststellt, ach so Mist, das hätten wir vorher wissen sollen, wenn irgendwas passiert. So und das unter der Gemengelage, dass die Partei derzeit erschöpft ist, jetzt natürlich so eine Euphorie treibt. Aber wir haben jetzt keine Organisationsgrade, auch nicht bei den anderen Kandidaten. Wir haben es ja besprochen, die da irgendwie im Raum stehen, weil die konnten ja gar nicht vorher. Trotzdem will man jetzt die Aufmerksamkeit wieder auf Trump richten, Geld sammeln, Wählerstimmen sammeln, Anzeigen schalten. So lang ist ja nicht mehr bis Parteitag und dann Wahl. Und jetzt macht Ezra Klein diese Unterscheidung auf, die hier wirklich wahnsinnig informativ für uns ist. Tangible und intangible Eigenschaften von Kandidaten. Ich würde jetzt sagen, unter dieser Unterscheidungsfolie müssen wir JD. Vance beobachten. Denn es gibt die greifbaren Dinge, was auf dem Papier steht, was macht einen guten Kandidaten zu einem guten Kandidaten. Zum Beispiel, er ist schon Gouverneur. Er hat sich also schon mal irgendwo bewährt und durchgesetzt. Vielleicht sogar Gouverneur in einem Swing-State. Er war schon mal Astronaut, wie auch immer. Oder er führt die größte Volkswirtschaft der Welt, also dann so kalifornischer Kavogauvernör. Also es gibt so relativ viele. Auf dem Papier sieht das super aus, aber dann muss es auch funktionieren. Wir hatten jetzt aber den Republikanern auch. Also der Sentes da aus Florida, wo alle dachten auf dem Papier, das ist ja der Super-Republikaner, hat dann gar keine Chance gehabt. Und daneben gibt es eben diese immateriellen Faktoren, auf die es jetzt auch ankommt. Wie reagiert ein Kandidat unter Druck? Wirkt er auf die Wähler authentisch? Wirkt er opportunistisch? Ist irgendwas falsch an ihm? Bei JD. Vance können wir gerade sehen, wie das nicht funktioniert. Und auch nicht durch Beratung oder Training irgendwie hinbiegbar ist, sondern der Typ steht einfach wieder da, so wie er da steht und dann klappt es einfach nicht. Und für die Demokraten, und diese Frage beantwortet sich so langsam, sind die Leute bereit Memes, die intangible Charakterzüge einer Kandidatin zeigen, zu teilen, ihren Freunden zu schicken. Finden sie das lustig, was sie da sehen? Wie wirkt das Charisma? Also diese Dimension nochmal hervorzuheben zeigt, wir brauchen nicht unbedingt, also klar ist auch ein großer Faktor jetzt, dieses Supreme Court Urteil, um zu sagen, das ist irgendwie so ein bisschen anarchisch, vormodern, wie auch immer, sondern nein, grundsätzlich, wenn das so auf Personen zugespitzt ist, haben wir es hier mit diesen etwas vormodernen Prinzipien zu tun. Es ist kein Verwaltungsposten, sondern jemand muss da auch eine Show abliefern. Oder ich habe es ja ein bisschen übertrieben und sage dann einfach nur eine Show abliefern. Diese tangiblen, sichtbaren, formalen Kriterien, ja, da gehen wir einfach mal davon aus, dass die schon funktionieren. Und selbst bei Trump haben wir gesehen, zur Not ist dann halt Personal im Oval Office, das irgendwie die Geschäfte führt. Harris hat also bisher den Ruf gehabt, über diese immateriellen Eigenschaften nicht richtig zu verfügen. 2020, man erinnert sich an ihre Kandidatur. Die Kampagne hatte keinen richtigen Kern, keine Vision, keine Botschaft. Es hieß, ihr Büro sei schlecht geführt. Relativ wenige Berater, Personal, das sie angestellt hatte, wurde fluktativ sehr hoch einfach durchrotiert. Er weist also darauf hin, es gibt ja durchaus noch ein paar Sachen zu klären. Seit dem Abend der Debatte hat Kamala Harris aber einen eigenen Wahlkampf geführt, Argumente gegen Trump vorgebracht, die beiden selbst nicht vorbringen konnte und die fast unerträglich heikle Lage, beiden absolut zu unterstützen und gleichzeitig den Demokraten zu zeigen, dass sie in der Lage ist, seinen Platz einzunehmen, falls etwas passiert. Er sagte also jetzt, okay, es gibt diese intangibenden Mechanismen, auf die muss man achten. Und in diesem Punkt hat sie da schon mal, sozusagen, kassiert. Sich sofort um Harris zu scharen, fühlt sich für einige Demokraten sicher an. Für andere Demokraten ist es riskant. Sie riskieren den gleichen Fehler, wie bei beiden zu machen, nämlich aus Angst vor Uneinigkeit, nicht die Informationen zu sammeln, die sie jetzt brauchen, um zu wissen, wie ihr Kandidat wirklich abschneiden wird. Da würde ich sagen, ja, das stimmt. Ich habe es selbst in mir gefühlt, als ich dachte, gegen Donald Trump anzutreten und dann aber den Versuch zu wagen, auch gleichzeitig die erste Frau ins Amt zu wählen. Heikel. Sollte man das nochmal abchecken mit Gegenkandidaten oder wie auch immer. Aber Ezra Klein sagt hier, die Wahrheit ist, alles ist riskant, es könnte immer alles schief gehen. Nur dann muss man halt den Weg mal gehen. Lassen sie ein paar aufstrebende Kandidaten ihre Argumente gegen Donald Trump vorbringen, schreibt er jetzt, obwohl man sich für Harris entscheiden hat. Lasst uns ein paar CNN-Townhalls machen, ein paar Multikandidatenforen veranstalten. Also trotzdem Debattenbühnen bieten. Ich habe ja schon betont, wie ich es cool finde, dass jetzt so Pete Buttigieg oder so war. Die ganze Zeit ist er jetzt auch nicht in den neuen Posten. Nur Kamala Harris ist in den neuen Posten. Plötzlich sieht man sie aber überall. Statt einen vor Panik schlotternden Gavin Newsom zu sehen, der noch mal sagt, klar, stehen wir hinter unseren beiden, nee. Jetzt blüht das ja alles ein bisschen auf. Also ich finde, es geht schon so in diese Richtung, wie er sich das vorstellt, wenn auch nicht jetzt so ein CNN-Townhall anberaumt wurde. Aber man kann jetzt durchaus eine Reihe jüngerer Kandidaten mit Harris auf eine Bühne stellen. Er sagt, betrachten sie es nicht als einen Wettbewerb, sondern als eine Ausstellung, eine Exhibition. Und das finde ich einer der wirklich sehr guten Ideen, denn Donald Trump kann genau das nicht. Donald Trump kann nur sich zeigen. Schon andere Leute auf der Bühne, wenn sie ihm Fragen stellen, werden sie gleich beleidigt. Wenn es seine Running-Mates sind, funktionieren sie nicht, wie er das will. Also das macht ihm auch keinen Spaß. Er muss wirklich singulär allein auf der Bühne stehen. Und allein dazu zeigen, es tritt nicht Kamala Harris gegen Trump an, sondern Trump tritt gegen eine Partei, eine Idee, keine Ahnung, ein Movement. Diese ganzen Dinger, die wir jetzt gesehen hatten, mit Fundraiser online und dann sind irgendwie 100.000 Leute in dem Zoom-Call, aber alle mit Kamerabild. Dann sieht man so ausschnittsweise, dass das einfach viele sind. Also allein diese Botschaft finde ich, die sollte man jetzt echt mal betonen. Diese demokratische Partei hat also jetzt nur wenige Wochen Zeit zu zeigen, dass sie nicht nur als eine Person zu verstehen ist. Und er sagt, man kann auch eine strategische Zweideutlichkeit, also eine Ambiguität jetzt zulassen zur Frage, was findet denn da gerade medial statt? Ich sehe nur Pete Buttigieg überhaupt. Was heißt denn das? Bewirbt er sich gerade als Running Mate? Ja, nein und so. Und solche Fragen, die treiben ja auch Medienöffentlichkeit. Also er meint, da kann man ruhig mal jetzt einfach sie mit ihren eigenen Waffen schlagen. Trump weiß, wie er sich kostenlos Medienzeit erarbeitet und die Demokraten sollen es jetzt einfach auf. Pseudokonflikte, also so steht es nicht drin, aber ich würde jetzt sagen, Pseudokonflikte, Theater, Show, Termine, bei denen man nicht genau weiß, was passiert denn da und dann einfach irgendwas abliefern. Nun gut.
Wen prophezeist du eigentlich als Vizekandidaten?
Mark Kelly, den Astronaut in einem Swing-State und vor allem Weißer Mann, Glatze. Genau diese Art von Nicht-Strongman, aber demografisch mitten aus Amerika. Also, mal sehen. Keine Ahnung. Es kann auch irgendwelche Überraschungsleute geben. Die Partei ist ja wirklich riesengroß. Sie haben ja mehrere Gouverneure zur Auswahl und so. Es ist ja wirklich erstaunlich. Gut. Er hat außerdem ihr Buch gelesen von 2009. Smart on Crime. Damals war sie noch Staatsanwältin. In diesem Buch geht es um politische Maßnahmen und Programmen zur Verhinderung und Verringerung von Kriminalität und darum, das Gefängnis zu einem Ort der Rehabilitation zu machen, statt zu einem Ort, der nur noch härtere Verbrecher hervorbringt. Sie schreibt, er zitiert jetzt, Nichts ist wichtiger als die Art und Weise, wie wir uns selbst, unsere Familien und uns gegenseitig schützen. Man betreibt, oder mich treibt, schreibt Kamala Harris, immer noch der Gedanke um, dass Sicherheit ein grundlegendes Bürgerrecht ist. Ich glaube, dass die Menschen ein Recht darauf haben, sich auf den Straßen und in ihren Häusern sicher zu fühlen. Und sie haben ein Recht darauf, die Dinge, für die sie gearbeitet haben, zu behalten und zu schützen. Also großes Thema Sicherheit für diese Kampagne der nächsten dreieinhalb Monate. Und jetzt schreibt er, Trump ist unsicher. Ein starker Mann, aber er macht uns weniger sicher. Unsere Demokratie ist unter Trump weniger sicher. Die Welt ist weniger sicher. Durch Trumps Entscheidung für den obersten Gerichtshof werden grundlegende Rechte ausgehebelt. Die Leute, die er in Spitzenposition berufen hat, die Leute, die er in Zukunft ernennen würde, sie machen unser Wasser und unsere Luft schmutziger und unsicherer. Sie machen unsere Finanzvorschriften schwächer. All das steht im Project 2025. Und ich finde es wahnsinnig klug, so eine Strategie hier vorzuschlagen. Öffentlich als Audio-Essay und geschriebenen Text in der New York Times, sodass man nicht drum rumkommt, sondern Leute dann, Kamala Harris, auch fragen, was ist jetzt die künftige Idee? Wie geht es hier weiter? Nachdem der Hype die Euphorie so abgeschwellt ist. Mit der Wahl von JD. Vance hat sich Trump nicht für eine beruhigende Wahl entschieden. Er hat sich für jemanden entschieden, der die Botschaft vermittelt, dass es dieses Mal niemanden geben wird, der Trump zurückhält, niemanden, der ihn kontrolliert. Sehr klug. Das ist eine einfache Beobachtung. Aber das hier in der Verbindung mit diesem Vor 15 Jahren hat sie, bevor sie überhaupt ein politisches Amt anstrebte, klar, der Posten ist auch ein Wahlposten, aber es ist sehr klug, das jetzt daran noch mal zu erinnern. Harris Vorstellungen über Kriminalität von vor 15 Jahren sind, wie er jetzt etwas zurückhaltend schreibt, keine Grundlage für eine Kampagne. Aber Sicherheit, das ist ein Wert, den ich gerne von den Demokraten zurückgewinnen würde. Ich halte diese Idee, auf die Sicherheitsthema zu gehen, für eine der klügsten Gedanken überhaupt, die mir jetzt untergekommen ist.
Das müsste aber auch soziale Sicherheit sein. Für ein bisschen mehr Polizei.
Er hat es ja aufgezählt, genau. Es ist auch soziale Sicherheit. Es ist die Frage, die Sicherheit der Kinder an den Schulen. Wie geht man mit diesen Waffenrechten jetzt wirklich um? Wie viel Angst müssen wir haben vor dem nächsten Financial Crash? Also dieses Sicherheitsthema, glaube ich, das muss man auch nicht. Das versteht sich so subkutan. Es hat so eine gewisse... Da ist der Motor schon eingebaut, würde ich sagen. Insbesondere, weil die Republikaner ja auch mit Sicherheit argumentieren, aber das eben auf das Individuum und seine Pistole runterbrechen usw. Während der Zustand, was eben alle fühlen, anders ist. Und es könnte für mich, ich glaube, das ist so wirkmächtig wie der eigentlich nicht sehr große, aber doch erstaunlich deutliche Mut zu sagen, die sind einfach weird. Also wenn Trump vor acht Jahren schon behinderte Menschen auf der Bühne nachefte, dann muss man das irgendwann jetzt mal kommentieren. Und diese Botschaft zu senden, das ist weird. Und ehrlicherweise, man guckt da drauf und sagt sich, ja, das ist weird und es macht uns unsicher. Also jetzt aus dieser Euphorie, die sind irgendwie weird und wir müssen was gegen die tun, ein Programm über Sicherheitsargumentation zu machen, das holt, glaube ich, das wird sehr viel abholen. Also es ist wirklich ein sehr kluger Text. Und auch strategisch so gut, selten so eine clevere Publikation erlebt.
Kommen wir zu einem Artikel aus der Financial Times. Meine Aufgabe wird es sein, euch frei zu machen. Das sagte Donald Trump zu den Krypto-Anhängern auf der Bitcoin-Konferenz in Nashville vor drei Jahren. Da war für Donald Trump noch klar, Bitcoin und all das ist ein Betrug, eine Bedrohung für den US-Dollar. Inzwischen hat sich das aber sehr gewandelt. Und seine Worte hatten wohl auch einen Effekt. Kurzzeitig kroch der Bitcoin immer weiter nach oben. Sogar die 70.000-Dollar-Marke war kurzzeitig geknackt. Damit war er dann schon sehr nah am Alltime hoch. Trump sagte, ich denke, Entschuldigung, der Risikokapitalgeber Sherwin Peshava sagt, ich denke, er wird der erste Kryptopräsident sein. Biden war kein besonderer Freund von Kryptowährungen. Hier sagen manche sogar, Biden hätte einen brutalen Angriff verübt auf die Kryptowährungen. Der Ansicht ist zum Beispiel Mark Antresen, also dieser Risikokapitalgeber von Antresen Horowitz. Wir hatten mal über sein libertäres Manifest gesprochen. Er ist auch selbst einer der größten Krypto-Investoren. Und zwar hat er 8 Milliarden Dollar für den Sektor aufgebracht. Also hat er ein großes Interesse daran, dass da Liberalisierungen stattfinden. Trump ist jemand, der jetzt wirklich, wie Antresen sagt, eine vollständige, durchgängige, einheitliche Umarmung der gesamten Sache auf den Weg bringt. Und interessanterweise sollte Kamala Harris auch in Nashville sprechen. Sie sollte da auch eine Rede halten, ja. Sie hat hier eine Nähe zum Silicon Valley. Also das darf man jetzt nicht ganz vergessen. Sie kommt aus Kalifornien, ja. Und sie ist dann in diese Kreise reingekommen. Sie war ja auch nie eine Vertreterin der Kritik am Silicon Valley, wie jetzt Elizabeth Warren. Also das hat sie sicher nie zu eigen gemacht. Aber sie kam nicht. Also da hat sie sich tatsächlich dagegen entschieden. Der Mitbegründer der Kryptoburse Kraken, Jesse Powell, sagte, dass er bereits eine Million Dollar in Ether an Trump gespendet hat. Trump hat gesagt, ihr seid die neuen Addisons und so weiter. Man kann es sich vorstellen, was er denen da alles erzählt.
Also ich glaube, solange man immer noch sagt, er hat acht Milliarden Dollar als Bitcoin oder eine Million in Ether. Also solange man immer noch die Referenzgröße Dollar hat, weiß man eigentlich, dass es irgendwie bescheuert ist, oder?
Ja, natürlich.
Etabliert wäre es ja, wenn man jetzt. Genau.
Wenn man umrechnen würde in die andere Richtung. Ja, aber das passiert natürlich nicht und das würde auch niemals passieren. Aber der Bitcoin wird und auch die anderen Kryptowährungen werden dadurch enorm aufgewertet. Und es steht also nicht ein Verbot an. Und es wird so sein, dass diese Kryptowährungen wichtiger werden. Aber die haben natürlich überhaupt keine Chance, jetzt dem Dollar Konkurrenz zu machen. Das ist völliger Blödsinn. Wie heißt es weiter? Die Konferenzteilnehmer waren besonders beeindruckt von Trumps Versprechen, einen strategischen nationalen Bitcoin-Vorrat anzulegen. Und zwar hat die Regierung 210.000 Bitcoins beschlagnahmt, aus irgendwelchen Gründen. Und das sei jetzt die Reserve, die wird nicht verkauft oder sowas, sondern da sitzt jetzt Trump drauf, wacht darüber. Wenn er Präsident ist, dann gibt es also sehr viele, die Kryptowährungsfans sind und auch Trump-Spenden. Es heißt, dass Trump 25 Millionen Dollar an Krypto-Spenden bereits erhalten hat.
Warum nicht?
JD. Vance ist auch in Bitcoin investiert, aber nicht mit einer hohen Summe. 250.000 Dollar, das ist jetzt nicht so viel.
Also für mich wäre das viel, für ihn ist es wahrscheinlich nicht so viel.
Also wenn wir hier über sehr reiche Leute reden, da kann man jetzt nicht sagen, ach so, und dann macht er das alles deshalb. Und die sagen, nee, der hat ja noch andere Sachen im Portfolio, nehm ich mal an. Warum Trump das überhaupt macht, ist gar nicht so klar. Also einmal, um Wähler zu bekommen, aber auch aus einem Protektionismus vielleicht heraus, dass man so die US-Börse auch wieder stärken kann, wenn sich sonst das Krypto-Geschäft zu sehr ins Ausland verlagert. Und dann heißt es noch, als Zeichen der Besorgnis der Demokraten über das Ausmaß der Krypto-Unterstützung für Trump haben die Berater von Kamala Harris in den letzten Tagen versucht, die Beziehungen zwischen der Partei und der Branche wiederherzustellen, indem sie Kontakt zu Mitarbeitern von Unternehmen wie Coinbase und Ripple aufnahmen, wie die Financial Times schon berichtet hatte. Das heißt, diese Kryptowährungen werden sich doch weiter ausbreiten, wir werden jetzt nicht ein Für und Wider erleben, sondern beide werden sich für diese Bitcoins und all die anderen Coins stark machen.
Bei Bitcoin gibt es ja zwei große Kritikpunkte, die kennen alle. Also zum einen dieses, wie soll man sagen, neue Menschenbild oder neue Gesellschaftsbild, was dahinter steckt, dass man so, wenn der Staat nicht mal funktioniert und so. Und das andere ist natürlich die Umweltzerstörung durch die ganzen, aber das wollen wir jetzt im AI-Zeitalter sowieso ausblenden. Es ist ja alles dasselbe. Nun ist ja so, dass der Bitcoin derzeit auch erfolgreich ist, weil er zum Beispiel von diesen Aufsichtsbehörden anerkannt wurde, hinsichtlich, ja, man darf ihn jetzt auch verbriefen. Leute handeln jetzt mit Bitcoin, aber in verbriefter Form. Sie haben keinen Zugriff auf den echten verschlüsselten Bitcoin, sondern eine Verbriefung. Das widerspricht komplett der Logik und zwar der einzigen Logik, warum der Bitcoin überhaupt attraktiv ist. Wenn jetzt Trump den auch noch verspricht, ich lege eine strategische Reserve an, was soll denn das bedeuten? Also wenn der Bitcoin doch eine Währung ist, die postapokalyptisch dann ihre sozusagen, also man breitet sich schon mal drauf vor. Das Szenario, in dem es so brenzlig wird, dass Amerika plötzlich zum Verkäufer von Bitcoin wird, aus welchen Gründen auch immer.
Das ist wie bei Gold. Aber man kann natürlich auch auf den Goldpreis spekulieren, ohne jetzt zu Hause Goldklumpen zu sammeln.
Gold habe ich ja, also in Gold gibt es ja immer dieses, für ein Stück Gold, irgendwie so eine kleine Münze, kannst du einen Mantel kaufen. Vor 200 Jahren, vor 100 Jahren, in 100 Jahren. Du brauchst dafür keine Elektronik und so. Du kannst es zu Hause lagern. Das ist bei Bitcoin alles nicht so. Der Bitcoin ist ja sehr voraussetzungsvoll. Nicht nur musst du ihn beichern, du brauchst auch immer einen operierenden Computer, der diese Blöcke gerade verifiziert oder was auch immer. Man kann ja nicht einfach so, nicht mal mit dem Lightning-Network, das geht ja auch immer nur so temporär so ein bisschen, kann man so einen kleinen Puffer aufbauen, aber irgendwann muss es ja wieder verifiziert werden. Also ich verstehe diese ganze Logik, verstehe ich einfach nicht.
Naja, man kann doch damit wunderbar spekulieren und das reicht doch dicke aus.
Aber nur solange die Gesellschaft funktioniert, wie sie bisher funktioniert und der Dollar immer noch da ist.
Jaja, also der Erfolg des Bitcoins hängt vom Erfolg des Dollars ab.
Also für mich ist das immer eine Spielerei.
Man kann höchstens sagen, dadurch, dass der Dollar ein bisschen angegriffen wird, dadurch, dass andere Nationalstaaten sich was überlegen und auch Gold sehr stark zukaufen, wird der Bitcoin auch aufgewertet, dadurch, dass man sagt, wir brauchen noch mal eine Alternative zum Dollar, also versuchen auch institutionelle Anleger in den Bitcoin oder so reinzugehen. Das bedeutet aber dann immer noch, dass der Dollar die Referenz bleibt. Also wenn der Dollar als Referenz im Ganzen wegbrechen würde, würde das ja nicht…
Würde nicht mal Blühdorn noch ein Buch schreiben, wo drin steht, jetzt gehen wir mal einen Schritt weiter.
Würde ja nicht der Bitcoin als Ersatz plötzlich aufkommen.
Ja, das ist einfach absurd. Ein Blick ins Innere der neuen Rechten, wo Peter Thiel seine größten Wetten platziert. Das ist also dieser Vanity Fair Text. Sie sind nicht MAGA, sie sind nicht 2NN. Curtis, Jarvin und die aufstrebenden Rechte entwickeln eine andere Art konservativer Politik. In dem Falle empfehle ich wirklich sehr, diesen Text selber zu lesen, denn ich kann jetzt einfach ihn zusammenfassen mit, okay, das ist so ein Sittenbild von jemand, ist auf so einer Konferenz, wo sich so neu rechte Leute irgendwie treffen, stellt dort fest, die sind aber alle ganz schön jung, 20 Jahre ein bisschen plus, und dann haben die aber so Koryphäen dabei, irgendwo steht da JD. Vance rum, und Peter Thiel hält auch noch eine Rede, und das wird dann so ein bisschen zusammengebaut, und ich habe dann Claude gebeten aus diesem Text, wenn man ihn liest, sitzt man schon so eine Stunde dran, mal die programmatischen und personellen zentralen Figuren für uns, dieser Text ist ja zwei Jahre alt, herauszukramen, damit wir jetzt abklopfen, was ist heute für uns interessant, und zwar insbesondere interessant, weil dieser Text eben schon zwei Jahre alt ist. JD. Vance zog gerade ein in den Senat, oder im Kongress, im Senat oder im Kongress, naja, wie auch immer. Also er ist jedenfalls da politisch auffällig geworden, hat Wahlen gewonnen, wenn auch knapp. Und heute plötzlich hat dieses ganze Ding so Traktion, was wir da als Milieustudie bekommen. Also wirklich als Kammerspielartiges, einmal bei einer Konferenz sein, dort vor Ort mit den Leuten reden, sich nochmal mit JD. Vance treffen und ein einzelnes Gespräch führen und so weiter. Also die Personen sind JD. Vance, Autor von Hillbilly Elegy und Senatskandidat Ohio, zentrale Figur der neuen Rechten und tatsächliche Koryphäe. Also das ist ja erstaunlich, wie das damals, also in diesem Text 2022 schon zu lesen ist, wie er da angehimmelt und da auch so eine Traube an Jünglingen um sich hat und so. Dann natürlich Peter Thiel, Milliardär und Tech-Unternehmer, der die neue Rechte finanziell unterstützt. In dem Text wird aber deutlich, dass diese Thiel-Bucks oder Peter-Bucks, wie sie es nennen, gar nicht so, also es gibt jetzt nicht unendlich viele Leute, die so hier mal 10.000, da mal 20.000 dann irgendwie davon profitieren. So scheint diese Mentoren-Art wohl dann doch nicht zu funktionieren, aber bei Vance hat da immerhin diese Wahlkämpfe von Black Masters und eben mit 10 Millionen Dollar unterstützt. Also bei der Frage, wo kriegt man Kapital her, Peter Thiel steht dann doch da. Curtis Jarwin, ehemaliger Programmierer und Blogger, der als intellektueller Vordenker der neuen Rechten gilt. Er propagiert eine radikale Umgestaltung des politischen Systems. Ja, in dem Text wird dann gut deutlich, wie er eigentlich nur noch vom Regime spricht und Kathedralen und die müssen alle zertrümmert werden. Also der will wirklich eine postapokalyptische und sei es, dass die Gefahr eines Weltuntergangs besteht. Amerika muss jetzt den Schritt weitergehen. Also der will sozusagen alles hinter sich lassen.
Über diese Idee der Kathedral, die zerschlagen werden soll, hatten wir ja mal im Podcast auch dann in Bezug auf diesen Vanity Fair Artikel und auch auf andere Berichte darüber gezeigt, wie sich da so eine neue Jugendbewegung oder neue intellektuelle Bewegung kreist, die da in New York sich an irgendwelchen Orten trifft und dort das politisch Inkorrekte zelebriert. Ich glaube, es ist so anderthalb Jahre her, dass wir im Podcast mal darüber sprechen.
Ja, genau. Das ist die Zeit, wo es aufgekommen ist, durch dieses Peter Thiel Buch auch, 22 und so. Blake Masters wird hier noch genannt. Damals, also hier in diesem Text noch einfach auf Augenhöhe mit JD. Vance. Wir wissen heute, er ist nicht nur ein weiterer Thiel-Unterstützer und damals auch Senatskandidat, sondern er hat ja dann auch diese Stiftung geleitet und so. Also er ist wirklich Thiels Handlanger geworden. Interessanterweise unterlag er 2022 bei dieser Senatorenwahl, die damals noch ausstand, Mark Kelly. Also es sind wirklich erstaunlich kleine Kreise, in denen plötzlich die eine Partei sagt, da könnte ich mir meinen Vizekandidaten holen und die andere Seite sagt, denen wollte das Wahlvolk damals nicht, ich hole ihn zu mir. Also es ist jetzt wirklich meine rechte Hand. Meine acht Milliarden, die ich da politisch investieren möchte, werden jetzt über Black Masters organisiert. Also wirklich gruselig. Außerdem zentral natürlich Tucker Carlson, der schon dockwisselmäßig, damals noch bei Fox News immer schon, die Signale aussendete, wo man sich denn jetzt hier versammelt und was wichtig ist und so. Diese soziale Landkarte ist wirklich interessant. Also Vance ist ein ehemaliger Mitarbeiter von Teals Mithril Capital und Masters. Bis vor kurzem, also das ist ein Zitat aus dem Text, bis vor kurzem CEO von Teals sogenannten Family Office leitet auch die Teal Foundation, die zunehmend mit diesem Ökosystem der neuen Rechten verflochten ist oder wie wollen wir es denn, zentral. Teal hat mehr als 10 Millionen Dollar an Superpacks gespendet, die die Kandidaturen beider Männer, also Vance und Black, unterstützt und steht beiden sehr nahe. Und diese drei Teal, Vance, Masters sind alle mit Curtis Jarvin befreundet, einem 48-jährigen ehemaligen Programmierer und Blocker, ich hatte ihn ja vorgestellt, der diese Schlüsselfigur und auch ideologischer Vorreiter da ist. Die Menschen haben oft Schwierigkeiten, damit Teals Beteiligung an diesem Ökosystem einzuordnen. Letztes Jahr veröffentlichtete der Journalist Max Jeffkin– wir haben das Buch gelesen– eine Biografie über Teal mit dem Titel The Contrarian, in der er Jarvin als den hauseigenen politischen Philosophen in diesem Netzwerk beschrieb, das oft als Tealverse bezeichnet wird. Also sehr gute Charakterisierung. Masters und Vance unterscheiden sich von Horley und Cruz, schreibt Jeffkin in dem Buch. Die beiden Ersteren, also Vance und Masters, sind Erweiterungen, Extensions von Teal. So, jetzt haben wir also die totale Landkarte, Programmatik, Claude hat mir sieben Punkte rausgesucht, politisches System und jetzt Zitate aus dem Text. Wir befinden uns in einer späten republikanischen Phase, sagt Vance später und beschwore damit die gänge Gesicht der neuen Rechten auf Amerika als Rom, das auf seinen Cäsar wartet. Wenn wir dagegen ankämpfen wollen, müssen wir ziemlich wild werden und uns ziemlich weit hinaus wagen in Richtungen, die für viele Konservative derzeit unbequem sind. Zweitens, Bürokratie und Verwaltung. Feuert jeden einzelnen Bürokraten der mittleren Ebene, jeden Beamten im Verwaltungsapparat, ersetzt sie durch unsere Leute. Dieses Programm kürzen die mit Rage ab. Retire all government employees. Bildungssystem. Vance prangerte Elitenuniversitäten als Feinde des amerikanischen Volkes an. Er schlägt schon lange vor, ihre Bundesfinanzierung zu streichen und ihre Stiftung zu beschlagnahmen. Er war ja ein Jehl. Er weiß, was er will. Wirtschaft. Mastersprogramm beinhaltet die Rückverlagerung der Industrieproduktion, drastische Kürzung der legalen Einwanderung, Regulierung großer Technologieunternehmen und schließlich eine Umstrukturierung der Wirtschaft, sodass ein Gehalt ausreicht, um eine Familie zu ernähren. Also Abbau aller Erfolgsrezepte ökonomischer Natur in Amerika. Diese Elite-Universitäten, die die ganzen Talente ins Land holen, Silicon Valley zurückbauen und dann aber politisch organisieren durch Befehl oder was auch immer, dass das Gehalt einer Person ausreicht, um eine ganze Familie zu ernähren.
Aber die können sich ja jetzt wirklich schon die Hand geben mit den Kubi-Checks.
Ja, das geht auch einfach gar nicht. Die schreiben voneinander ab. Also es ist wirklich erstaunlich. Einwanderung und Kultur.
Lass mich gerade einfach einfallen, weil das jetzt glaube ich für Leute, die das jetzt so zum ersten Mal hören, wahnsinnig verwirrend deshalb klingt, weil du jetzt eben ausgeführt hast, dass Peter Thiel da mit den Millionen nur so rumwirft. Wir wissen, JD. Vance ist auch kein armer Mann und die sind auch Unternehmer. Diese ganzen Leute gehören ja auch zu Tech dazu, gehören aber nicht zu den Tech-Konzernen, den wir so kennen. Google, Apple, all der ganze Kram. Das sind ja eher die, die die als, das sind die Wurken, die überlegen nochmal, ob irgendwas nicht divers genug ist. Das sind natürlich die, die richtig die Millionen in der Hand, die die Milliarden in der Hand haben oder die jetzt dann die Billionen bald bewegen können. Und hier sind wir eigentlich in so einer Stufe darunter. Und da ist aber ein ganz, ganz großes Rumoren. Und das ist ja auch eigentlich interessant, wie das so in der amerikanischen Wirtschaft jetzt zu beobachten ist. Es gibt dieses Kapital von globalen Unternehmen, das eher auf Distanz geht zu Trump. Also wo man eher so ein bisschen, man vielleicht ist man am Ende froh, dass er es wird und nicht Bernie Sanders. So, ne? Das hat ja auch mal Tus angedeutet. Aber die würden jetzt sich nicht mit dem Trump gemein machen und auch nochmal sagen, wir schicken die Mexikaner nach Hause. So, aber dann gibt es diese Liga darunter. Irgendwelche Family Office Leute, irgendwelche, die mit Ölfirmen ihr Geld verdienen. So eins darunter sind die, aber nicht die, die Megakonzerne sind. Genauso auch hier beim Digitalen. Und die sind wiederum für alles, was unmöglich wäre zu sagen auf einer Aktionärskonferenz als Apple-Konzern oder so. Affen. Und drehen da vollkommen frei und haben da auch solche Fantasien von, wir bauen da mal wieder irgendwas auf, weil ich meine, all diese Konzepte, dass man jetzt zum Beispiel die Frau aus dem erwerbstätigen Leben ausnimmt, würde ja einfach jede Volkswirtschaft ruinieren.
Also ich habe vorhin dieses Blühdorn-Buch sehr kritisiert, weil ich gerade weil er es unhaltbar nennt und ich aber seine Herangehensweise selber für unhaltbar halte. Nun ist es ja so, dass diejenigen hier auch so einen publizistischen Apparat haben, der aber nur in ihrer Blase publiziert und wirkt. Das heißt, die kriegen nie Widerworte. Also es gibt jetzt keinen Salon-Podcast in Amerika, der sich mal kritisch mit diesen Sachen auseinandersetzt, sondern die gären wirklich so eine ideologische Soße in sich. Einmal 90 Minuten in einem Kolokium da drauf geblickt und Close Reading das mit Theorieapparaten abgeglichen, weiß man, es wird nicht funktionieren, es ist Wünscherei. Das Problem ist nur, sie können auf zwei verschiedene Arten scheitern. Entweder weil sich ein erfolgreicheres Konzept, und sei es der Status Quo, den Kamala Harris jetzt anbietet, fortsetzt und sie einfach aussortiert werden, oder weil sie das wirklich versuchen, auf die Straße zu kriegen und alles vor die Wand fahren. Ja, es gibt aber keinen dritten Weg, sondern diese Konzepte sind so ideologiegetrieben und durchdacht, und vor allem ungetestet. Das wird nicht funktionieren. Wir sehen das jetzt an JD. Vance. Kamala Harris galt immer als, haben wir ja vorhin gelesen bei Ezra Klein, fragwürdig, ob die Intangiblen, kann sie wirklich das Charisma ausstrahlen, kann sie Freude hervorrufen und so weiter. Und jetzt sehen wir, einmal Vizepräsidentin sein, einmal einen Wahlkampf auf der großen föderalen Bühne mitmachen, reicht schon, um ihr so viele Disziplinen einzutrichtern, zu wissen, ich gehe jetzt hier raus, ich bin nicht ich selber, ich spiele jetzt hier Kandidaten vor. JD. Vance geht derzeit raus und glaubt, er könne sich selbst verwirklichen auf der Bühne. Und dieses Scheitern zu sehen, auf dieser Ebene, er kriegt nicht mal seine eigene, mit wem wird er das noch verhandeln, also er muss nur seine eigene Idee von sich als Kandidat auf die Bühne bringen und man sieht, wie er damit scheitert. Eine Idee, die nicht nur sich ihn selbst, sein Selbstbild betrifft, sondern ganz Amerika will dieser Mann jetzt auf die Straße kriegen und es wird ein ganz großes Feuerwerk, also es wird einmal laut blitzen und dann liegt da sehr viel Asche auf dem Boden. Also diese Gefährlichkeit, die da drinsteckt, unabhängig davon, dass das, was die wollen, auch gefährlich ist, muss man wirklich, deswegen jetzt auch diese Appelle an die Journalisten, sich das genau anzuschauen und jetzt nicht sozusagen an der Performance irgendwo kleben zu bleiben. Na gut, also programmatisch Punkt 5, Einwanderung und Kultur. Ein Land ist nicht nur eine Wirtschaft, sagt Masters, kürzlich dem desidenten rechten Medium IM 1776. Das sind auch wieder solche Namensgebungen, wo man denkt, ja, okay. Man braucht auch eine Vorstellung von sich selbst als Nation, als Volk und als Kultur. Und genau das fehlt Amerika zunehmend. Die Daily-Show ist ja auch beim Parteitag gewesen, da haben die Leute gefragt, wann war Amerika great? Und egal, welche Antwort kam, war dann immer, ja gut, mussten halt die Frauen drunter leiden. Ja gut, gab es halt noch Sklaven. Aber damals war Amerika great. Und manche sagen dann wirklich, als Amerika gegründet wurde, und Amerika wurde ja aus Gründen gegründet, man wollte eine Lebenslage verbessern, also es war wirklich eine sozusagen Abwendung, Hinwendung zu einer guten Idee aus einem tiefen Tal. Und wenn die hier sich hier, was auch immer im bedeutet, dabei werden 1776 eine Jahreszahl ist im Sinne von ja, das ist unser das ersehnte Land. Da wollen wir zurück. Das ist einfach absurd. Das ist wirklich Albert. Punkt 6 Technologie und Medien. Maastas hat öffentlich gesagt, er denke, jeder sollte das Anti-Tech-Manifest des Unabombers, das ist ja sowieso deren großer Onkel, genau, den nennen sie ja Onkel Dings, die industrielle Gesellschaft und ihre Zukunft lesen, dass er als eine nützliche Analyse dafür sieht, wie Technologie unsere Welt formt und wie erniedrigend und ermüdentwürdigend sie für das menschliche Leben sein kann.
Ich habe das ja gelesen, dieses Manifest.
Ja, teilweise kenne ich es auch. Und ich kenne sehr viele, die es auch sehr interessante und unterstützenswürdig finden.
Ne, die kenne ich jetzt wiederum nicht. Also Techno Schintzki ist ja jemand, der diese Terroranstecke dann verübt. Und der damals aber in diesem Manifest schon so ein merkwürdiges Gespenst zeichnet von einem Kultur-Marxismus und Feminismus. Also das ist bei ihm schon alles gekoppelt. Also einmal diese Technisierung der Welt ist jetzt nicht einfach eine Kritik an zu viel Überwachung unter all dem, sondern zugleich verbindet er diese Diskurse, also diese Technik-Kritik mit einem Anti-Feminismus, mit einem Anti-Links-Sein, mit einem völlig kruden Anti-Marxismus. Also er hat natürlich gar kein Verständnis von Marxismus. Und dass das jetzt hier unter den Leuten, die ja zum Teil durch Big Tech sehr, sehr reich werden, also wie etwa Peter Thiel, als ein positives Referenzwerk aufgeführt wird, ist ja maximal absurd eigentlich.
Ja, diesen programmatischen, ich habe eine andere Idee, Teil kenne ich jetzt nicht so sehr. Was die Zeitdiagnostik in diesem Text angeht, kenne ich aber ein paar, die das auch jetzt sozusagen, okay, das ist irgendwie okay. Ich will nur darauf hinweisen, die Frage ist ja immer, wie kommt so eine Idee in die Welt? Kann man im Falle des Unabombers eine Diskussion führen, Werk und Künstler zu trennen? Nein, schwierig irgendwie. Wir können es aber in anderen Feldern machen, wie zum Beispiel Matrix, dieser Film. Die sehen sich alle in der Matrix. Ausgeliefert fremden Mächten, einem Erweckungsereignis, das notwendig ist, und dann ist alles besser und wie auch immer. Das heißt noch nicht, dass wir deswegen den Film Matrix schlecht finden oder sowas. Also diese Umgänge mit diesen kulturellen Artefakten und wie man sie für sich ausarbeitet, sind hier wirklich noch mal interessant, denn Keanu Reeves ist hier auch zu schützen.
Was bei Ted Krasinski ja ganz interessant ist, ist diese Sehnsucht nach einer Autonomie und nicht einem Regelwerk untergeordnet zu sein. Und das ist natürlich ein Projekt, das nicht vereinbar ist mit einer modernen Gesellschaft, die nur nach Regeln funktionieren kann. Und Ted Krasinski hat ja auch in so einer Hütte im Wald gelebt und war von allem abgeschottet. Ich empfehle sehr die Serie. Ich glaube, sie ist bei Netflix. Man findet das schnell raus, wenn man Ted Krasinski, Una Bumba, Bumba Gugge. Es gibt eine sehr gute Serie, die macht nachher so eine leider psychologische Herleitung für all das, was er gedacht hat. Das ist ein bisschen einfach gestrickt. Aber so im Ganzen kommt man dieser Philosophie nahe und kommt vielleicht damit auch so einem Subjektbegriff, das da bei den Republikanern ist, nahe.
Ja, das stimmt. Da können wir nochmal reingucken. Siebter letzter Punkt Außenpolitik. Vance sagt kürzlich in einem Interview, also damals 2022, der Krieg begann gerade erst. Ich muss ehrlich sagen, es interessiert mich nicht wirklich, was mit der Ukraine passiert. Als Seitenhieb darauf, dass er denkt, die von Amerika geführte globale Ordnung diene ebenso sehr. Und ich würde sagen, vielleicht ist das das Problem, dass er glaubt, das dient noch mehr der Bereicherung von Rüstungsunternehmen und Denkfabriken als der Verteidigung amerikanischer Interessen. Das sind natürlich, hier wird es ja wirklich heikel, denn das Außenministerium und das Weiße Haus ist ja jetzt gerade noch besetzt von Leuten, die sagen, kein Millimeter weichen wir zurück. Alles, was sich China nimmt, kriegen wir nie wieder. An Einflusssphäre, an Materiellen, keine Ahnung, die hängen da in Serbien rum und holen sich dieses Zeug wie ihre Batterien oder so. Und hier droht ja in außenpolitischen Sachen, also da, wo man nicht einfach inländisch, ja, wir haben so Blumenkot, wir machen hier ein weiteres Schicksal in Sheriff, sondern in Sachen Außenpolitik geht ja wirklich was verloren für Amerika. Nur, das kann Amerika in diesem Wahlkampf auf gar keinen Fall explizit thematisieren. Das kann man höchstens in so einem, keine Ahnung, dann wirklich colloquium unter sich, wenn man mal so jemanden an irgendeiner Uni dann da hat. Aber hier wird es ja wirklich gefährlich für Amerika. Also, dass diese Leute, und sei es nur, dass ein Jahr lang unklar ist, wer jetzt diese Wahl wirklich gewonnen hat, da einfach Raumgewinne gemacht werden von anderen Kräften, die Amerika so einfach nicht, also die dann wirklich alles in Turbulenzen bringen. Wir haben jetzt schon über kleine außenpolitische, geopolitische Turbulenzen gesprochen. Hier wird es also wirklich brenzlig insgesamt. Interessant finde ich Folgendes als abschließenden Punkt dazu. Diese Leute lehnen Amerika, wie sie es vorfinden, ab. Die Politik ist doch nur ein Hierarchieapparat für Leute, die sich erbereichern wollen. Für uns tun die doch gar nichts. Die Wirtschaft ist auch einfach nur eine riesige Gemengelager und Organisation gegen Familien. Das müssen plötzlich alle arbeiten und die Kinder auch noch. Das ist ja alles so. Also die lehnen alles, wo wir jetzt sagen, okay, das sind so Formalien, das sind Organisationen, das ist das, wofür wir uns im Bildungssystem vorbereiten, eine Prüfung zu bestehen und so. So Schritte biografisch nach vorne zu gehen. Und obwohl die das so ablehnen, haben sie sich trotzdem so diszipliniert, diesen Marsch durch die Institutionen jetzt aber einfach zu gehen. Und das finde ich erstaunlich, ehrlich gesagt. Weil wir reden jetzt immer so über den amerikanischen Präsidenten, als wäre das so, ja, kann man ja mal machen, wenn man Lust hat da antreten, schon Gewerkschaftsvorsitzender zu werden. Überhaupt in irgendeinem Vorstand, wo es Budgetsentscheidungen gibt, mal einen Termin zu bekommen. Das ist alles superharte, schwere, langwierige Arbeit. Diese biografischen Entscheidungen so zu treffen, dass man irgendwann, und der Typ ist jetzt mit 40 Jahren oder was, Vizepräsidentschaftskandidat für die United States of America geworden. Also das passt in meinem Kopf nicht so ganz zusammen, wie man diese Ideologie, aber gleichzeitig diesen, man muss sich wirklich tagtäglich damit befassen, dass man in diese Posten kommt, das vorbereiten, Trial and Error und so weiter. Also für mich kommt das, passt das irgendwie noch nicht so richtig zusammen. Es kann natürlich auch einfach alles ein großer Glücksmoment sein. Ich glaube Donald Trump ist einfach ein großer Glücksmoment für die. Aber man muss doch ganz schön viel organisieren und planen, obwohl man das Organisieren und Planen ganz schön scheiße findet. Schon erstaunlich.
Es hat eine Initiative begonnen, die heißt Data Workers Inquiry. Darüber hat netzpolitik.org berichtet, hat ein Interview geführt mit einer der führenden Köpfe dort, nämlich mit der Soziologin und Informatikerin Milagro Miceli. Miceli wird interviewt und befragt dazu, wie geht es eigentlich den Datenarbeiterinnen, die zum Beispiel die KI's betreuen, dass die nicht zu viel Unsinn reden oder Hate produzieren. Sie wird dazu befragt, sie sagt, Datenarbeiterinnen sind unverzichtbar für die Entwicklung und Wartung der beliebtesten Plattformen und Systeme, die wir nutzen. Es gibt keine KI ohne die Arbeit, die in die Datensammlung, Bereinigung, Kommentierung fließt und ohne algorithmische Überprüfung. Das muss man sich klar machen, wenn man immer ChatGPT oder irgendwas benutzt, dann ist das so. Wer arbeitet da eigentlich? Amazon hat ja selbst eine Plattform geschaffen, wie man auch an Datenarbeiter kommt, nämlich mit Amazon Mechanical Turk. Das ist vor 20 Jahren geschehen. Da sagt sie, das Mechanical Turk Modell macht eine große Anzahl von Arbeitskräften weltweit jederzeit und zu günstigen Preisen verfügbar. Dann heißt es, dass sie sich ja viel auseinandergesetzt hat, global. Und darum geht es ja auch bei diesem Zusammentreffen, dass man Arbeiter global zusammenbringt. Und überhaupt mal zu wissen, wie wird denn da gearbeitet, in welchen Bedingungen und wo. Zum Beispiel in Venezuela, Syrien, Kenia, aber auch Deutschland. Die meisten Datenarbeiterinnen haben einiges gemeinsam. Sie werden nicht für ihre Zeit bezahlt, sondern nur für erledigte Aufgaben. Meist erhalten sie magere Stundenlöhne von gerade einmal zwei US-Dollar in Kenia, 1,7 US-Dollar in Argentinien. Sie haben keine Arbeitsrechte, keinen sonstigen Schutz. Die meisten Arbeiterinnen unterliegen Geheimhaltungsvereinbarungen. Und die gehen so weit, dass ihnen dann auch angedroht wird, wenn sie psychologische Hilfe aufsuchen für das, was sie da die ganze Zeit bearbeiten. Zum Beispiel irgendwelche Gewaltbilder. Dann verstoßen sie gegen diesen NDA, den sie doch unterschrieben haben. Man spricht deshalb auch von Ghost-Work, also Geisterarbeit, Arbeit, die gar nicht gesehen wird. Und man will also herausfinden, was passiert da eigentlich. Micheli sagt, wir laden die Datenarbeiterinnen ein, die Führung zu übernehmen. Also die sind dann alle dort vor Ort. Sowohl bei der Entscheidung, welche Themen und Fragen sie für dringlich halten, als auch bei der Wahl des Mediums und des Formats. Also ganz interessant, dass also nicht jetzt die Forscher da sind, sagen so, wir interviewen euch mal schnell, sondern die sollen selbst sich interviewen, weil sie überhaupt nur wissen, welche Fragen relevant sind. Das kann man von außen einfach nicht mehr sehen. Sie nennen das, das sind die Community-Forscher und die interviewen dann in ihrer Community, natürlich unter Aufsicht sozusagen, diese anderen Leute. Und sie verweist dann auch auf herzzerreißende Berichte über psychische Probleme bei Content-Moderatoren, die für Meta arbeiten. Sie wird dann auch gefragt, wie man denn überhaupt das jetzt so einordnen kann. Was sind das für Arbeiter? Und zwar ist es so, dass sie sich bei den Fragen, die sie dann wiederum stellen, an die Arbeiter an einem Fragebogen von 1880 orientieren, den Karl Marx entwickelt hatte, um die französische Arbeiterklasse zu untersuchen.
Sieh mal einer an. Das ist empirische Arbeit.
Wirklich erstaunlich. Und ich musste nämlich, als ich so begann, das Interview zu lesen, also keine Rechte, die werden da irgendwo gehalten. Und die würden aber auch am besten nicht so therapiert. Also dürfen sie gar nichts machen. Das ist so ein Mensches der Kapitalismus. In modernster Form, aber durch KI. Und ja, sie sagt dann, die Schlüsselrolle der Datenarbeiterinnen für das reibungslose Funktionieren der KI erinnert an die grundlegende marxistische Annahme, dass nur menschliche Arbeit Mehrwert schaffen kann, ungeachtet der Versuche, sie auf bloße Anhängsel von Maschinen zu reduzieren. Datenarbeit sollte folglich als eine Produktionsweise analysiert werden, die die Entfremdung verschärft, indem sie die Arbeiterinnen physisch von ihren Produkten trennt. Das erschwert es, den Datenarbeiterinnen sich zu organisieren und die Kontrolle über die Produktionsmittel auszuüben. Denn Outsourcing ist natürlich das große Stichwort hier. So können sich auch die Konzerne der Verantwortung entledigen. Wie viele es überhaupt gibt, wie viele Datenarbeiter? Es ist unklar, die Weltbank hat so eine grobe Schätzung. 150 bis 430 Millionen werden es sein. Und viele, wie gesagt, im globalen Süden. Also bei Facebook, das ist ja schon ein sehr großes Netzwerk.
So 30.000 Content-Moderatoren in Bangladesch oder so.
Und dann nochmal Outgesourced daran. Also ich finde auch 150 Millionen ist ja schon eine enorme Zahl. 430 Millionen. Naja, man kann überlegen, wo überall noch Datenarbeiter gebraucht werden, wo Kommentare gecheckt werden müssen, wo möglicherweise jung gefährdende Inhalte kommen könnten. Das muss ja alles gecheckt werden. Ich finde es auch eine verrückte Zahl.
Amazon hat ja damals, das war ja einfach ein Weihnachtsgeschäft, mussten die Bilder der Cover von der ganzen Musik, die sie dann auch mitverkauft haben und so weiter da eingeplädt werden, Bildunterschriften unter Artikel und so. Ganz am Anfang hat man das noch an Studenten gegeben. Also untergebrochen einzelne Tasks. Dann gab es auch irgendwann so Ideen, dass man so Apps, wie man sie heute hat, also heute fotografiert man ja einfach mit perplexity so ein Regal und fragt, was steht denn da so drin. Und ich glaube, es war Amazon, die hatten mal so eine Funktion in der App, dass man ein Foto schicken konnte und dann hat die App einem gesagt, was ist denn das im Sinne von ich will es auch kaufen und gibt es das bei Amazon. Und das war einer dieser relativ frühen auch Mechanical Turk. Das kommt ja aus dieser Idee, dass dann doch doch ein Mensch da unten die Spielsteine schiebt. In diesem Tisch, auf dem gespielt wird. Dass den Leuten, den Kunden schon vorgegaukelt wird, das macht die Maschine, aber im Hintergrund arbeitet doch noch ein Mensch. Weshalb dann auch die Anreize kam, umso schneller du das Bild bearbeitest, umso besser wir vorgaukeln können, als die Maschine die Antwort gegeben hat. Wenn du jetzt sagst, da arbeiten bis zu hunderte Millionen Menschen, da hat man ja fast Sorge, dass die Cloth Antwort am Ende doch noch von einem Menschen schnell geschrieben wird, statt von der KI.
Ja, für 1,70 Dollar.
Ja. Und die Leute, da ist Entfremdung wirklich das Zauberwort, weil die wissen nicht, was sie tun. Die kriegen einfach so ein Bild vorgelegt und dann die Frage, sieht man hier sexuellen Kindesmissbrauch? Ja, nein. Nächstes. Zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack. Die wissen gar nicht, wo das herkommt. Bleiben wir technisch, also die Ehe, aber optimiert. In, oder hier steht so, San Francisco Paare, sind natürlich die Vorreiter, klären ihre Probleme mit Offsides und Leistungsbewertungen. Sie haben hier ein Bild von einem Pärchen. Du siehst zwei junge, sympathische Menschen, die ein Handy in der Hand haben. Es ist Sammy Packard, eine Beraterin, die hat sich eine zweite Dicke auszeitig genommen für ihre Ehe.
Muss sie sich auch leisten können?
Ja, das ist eine gute Urlaubheit. Ich würde sagen, das läuft noch eine Runde Urlaub. Sie hat dann für diese Auszeit ein detailliertes Programm geschrieben, denn das Ziel ist es gewesen, die Art und Weise, wie unser Haushalt funktioniert, so zu entwickeln, dass sich unsere aktuellen Bedürfnissen besser entsprochen wird. Die Ehe ist also uns strudeln geraten, so wie bei vielen Paaren, die sich in wichtigen Lebensfragen nicht einigen können. Diese Lebensfragen entstehen, weil selbst der Tech-Sektor in der Bay Area den Angestellten nicht mehr genug Gehalt zahlt, damit sie da ihr Leben bestreiten können. Also nicht nur werden da relativ viele Leute entlassen, sondern nein, es ist halt wirklich teuer. Kaufen wir das Haus für 3 oder 7 Millionen. Da nützt es auch nicht, 250.000 im Jahr zu verdienen. Um diese Krisen zu bekämpfen, gibt es natürlich verschiedene Techniken und neuerdings den Glauben, man könnte seine Ehe so optimieren, wie man seine Arbeit optimiert hat. Also über Leistungsbewertungen und kleine Retreats, wo man sich mal reflektiv damit auseinandersetzt, in welcher Sackgasse man hier eigentlich ist. In dem Falle des Pärchens war es die langfristige Wohnsituation. Sie wollte da leben, wo man ein Netzwerk aufbaut, Nachbarschaften hat und dann die Kinder unter Freunden aufwachsen. Er wollte lieber alle zwei Jahre woanders wohnen. Er fand das sonst claustrophobisch und so. Und da konnten sie sich nicht einigen. Also hat man sich mit Hilfe von Vision Boards, Balkendiagramm und zahlreichen Postezetteln angefangen Gedanken zu machen, bis man dann auf die Idee kam, wir müssen es irgendwie anders strukturieren. Unsere gemeinsamen Werte, unsere Verpflichtung, unsere Erziehungsansätze, unsere Rituale. Das kann man ja nicht einfach nur mal ebenso am Wochenende besprochen, sondern das muss ja ordentlich gemacht werden. Also haben sie dann versucht, das mit Google Slide Decks zu machen. Sind dann auf 19 Slides gekommen, die ihnen da irgendwie wichtig waren. Diese Geschichte haben sie dann bei LinkedIn publiziert. Darüber ist dann auch das journalistische Interesse gekommen. Und nach sieben Jahren Ehe, wie sie sagen, drei Häusern, zwei Kindern haben sie ihr Betriebsmodell geupdatet mit Kabeldom, also einer, in dem Falle noch, Plattform, die eine Art Klausurtagung bedeutet. Also man kann sich da anmelden als Paar. Und dann für 500 Dollar so eine, wie sie sagen hier, eine Heimwerkerklausur, da sozusagen eine Paartherapie auf neuerem, auf neuerer Ebene zu machen. Sie haben auch programmatisch für 3000 Dollar, kann man sich da rein mieten. Ist aber immer noch sozusagen, wir treffen uns vor Ort. Und dann kamen diese Apps, zum Beispiel, oder hier ist eine Therapeutin, das ist auch witzig. Also sie reden hier mit einer Therapeutin, die bei Open Mind Health arbeitet. Also nicht in einer Praxis, sondern in einem Start-up für Tele-Therapie, wo dann gesehen wurde, ach so, das sind so die Probleme unserer Kunden vermehrt. Also reagieren wir mal darauf. Und dann werden hier so ein paar Apps genannt, mit denen man jetzt seine Ehe da strukturieren kann. Und dann zum Beispiel auch große Lebensentscheidungen. Wirklich in so einem Ablauf. Das ist ein Projekt. Da gibt es eine Deadline. Und dann wird entschieden. Und dann guckt man, wie man damit umgeht. Und ich muss dann immer daran denken, wie Jeff Bezos davon erzählt, dass man, wenn man eine Entscheidung hat, also durch eine Tür geht, durch die man ja mehrfach gehen kann, dann kann man ja erst mal durch die Tür gehen. Aber man muss immer beobachten, manchmal hat man Türen, die sind danach zu. Dann kann man nicht mehr revidieren. Diese Logiken jetzt einfach wunderbar da einfach einbauen kann. Also man kann es so weit treiben, bis der eine sagt, nee, sorry, aber jetzt verlasse ich dich. Und dann hat man auf jeden Fall, die Revision wird dann schwierig. Naja, aber das sind ja die großen Themen. Es gibt ja viele kleine Themen. Hausarbeit, wie kontrolliert man die Hausarbeit? Eine App, die man da nutzen kann, ist Coexist. Das finde ich auch witzig. Das ist nicht zusammen wohnen, zusammen leben, sondern coexistieren. Also diese Tools, die hier vorgestellt werden, ist schon vom Namen her sehr witzig.
Aber es ist doch recht unromantisch, wenn ich das sage.
Es ist sehr unromantisch, vor allem, weil die Apps hier immer nicht ausreichen. Am Ende braucht man dann doch nochmal Asana, das kenne ich nicht, Notion, Google Docs. Alles wird zusammengebaut. Jeder versucht die bessere App, die jetzt wirklich alle Fragen behandelt. Aufgabenlisten, Essensplanung, Einkaufslisten, Packlisten für Reisen, Vorschläge für Filmabende.
Also da muss man doch nochmal drüber nachdenken, ob nicht-allein-leben auch was schönes ist.
Ja, ich finde, wenn manche Sachen, die nicht von alleine funktionieren, funktionieren dann einfach nicht. Da muss man dann mal in den Saurenabwild beißen. Aber ja, Coexist zum Beispiel hat damals 120.000 Dollar Entwicklungsgeld kassiert. Es sind Budgets da für solche Sachen. Am Ende werden solche Apps geschrieben und man versucht dann zum einen, sein Leben besser zu machen oder diesen Bedarf aufzugreifen und Apps für 6,49 Euro im Monat zu verkaufen. Ich weiß noch nicht so ganz, was ich davon halten soll, aber wandert natürlich auch ins Buch.
Ja, einfach mal ausprobieren. Diese 1000 Apps, die es da gibt. Nur noch eine Meldung, die unter anderem im Spiegel zu finden war, Spiegel online. Ich lese vor, der ukrainische Grenzschutz hat nach eigenen Angaben einen Deserteur unweit der moldauschen Grenze erschossen. Diese habe Grenzschutzbeamte angegriffen, heißt es dann. Zur Begründung weiter, demnach wurde am Sonntagabend eine Gruppe von vier Deserteuren in einem Auto an einem Kontrollpunkt etwa 15 Kilometer vor der Grenze angehalten. Zwei sollen versucht haben zu fliehen. Später habe einer der beiden bei seiner Entdeckung Widerstand geleistet und sei nach einem Warnschuss an den Folgen eines zweiten direkten Schusses gestorben. Also man schießt jetzt auf die eigenen Leute, ehe sie fliehen. Da heißt es, Angaben der staatlichen Ermittler zufolge ist die Gruppe von einem Übungsplatz per Taxi im Gebiet Odessa geflohen und war auf dem Weg in Richtung des von pro-russischen Separatisten kontrollierten Gebietstransnistrien in der Republik Moldau. Der Rest der Gruppe sei festgenommen worden. Also es ist wirklich erstaunlich, dass man Leute hat, die jetzt auf einer Übungsgruppe sind, sagen, so, so haben wir das Wagen, wir versuchen mit einem Taxi irgendwie wegzukommen. Also wie dramatisch das einfach ist, muss man sich vorstellen.
Das ist eine wirkliche Fluchtszenarie. Ja, wir kennen es ja hier aus der deutsch-deutschen Geschichte, dass man so, ah, morgens sind wir so relativ nah an der Grenze. Räuber, Räuber, wir müssten dann so 100 Meter rennen, dann Räuberleiter und dann hoffen, dass keiner guckt.
Dem Behördensprecher zufolge waren Grenze bereits mehrfach zum Schusswaffeneinsatz gegenüber flüchtenden Männern gezwungen. Insofern, der gute Staat...
Ah, gezwungen, von wem denn? Schöne Formulierung.
Das wissen wir nicht. Das müssen wir... Ich glaube, da gibt es viele Leute, die bei Twitter uns das ganz genau erklären könnten, warum das jetzt schon richtig ist. Das ist ja eine...
Die würden hier sich bei uns Bürgergeld holen.
Das ist natürlich... Der DDR-Vergleich ist natürlich nicht stadthaft, den du da machst. Das werden wir dir nochmal genau erklären. Ja, zum Schluss dieser Meldung heißt es noch, Wehrpflichtige versuchen sich daher auch durch Flucht über die Grüne Grenze in den angrenzenden EU-Staaten oder nach Moldau, dem Kriegsdienst zu entziehen. Wusste ich auch nicht. Der ukrainische Grenzschutz errichtet deswegen auch an den Westgrenzen zunehmend mit Stacheldraht versehene Zäune, um die Männer an der Flucht zu hindern. Damit beenden wir den Salon für heute. Mit sehr viel politischem haben wir es zu tun gehabt. Im Sommersalon wird das sehr anders aussehen. Wir freuen uns auf euer Kommen oder die nicht kommen, können das natürlich dann alles nachhören. Und wer den Salon jetzt noch günstig verschenken will, kann das jetzt noch tun. Ab 24. August ist es dann ein bisschen teurer. Und dann freuen wir uns auf einen hoffentlich angenehmen August.
Haut rein!